[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et ben ça y est on y est mesdames et
messieurs oh la dernière partie du match
de championnat du monde le dénouement
Fab qui sera peut-être aujourd'hui
peut-être demain puisque nul reste quand
même le résultat le plus probable d'une
partie d'échec mais le suspense est à
son paroxysme et petite fille Fab qui
est en train d'arriver pour ouais bah
pour dire bonjour bonjour messieurs
non bon quoi dire parti bon de toute
façon c'est dur de faire des pronoms
c'est comme d'hab on a eu plein de
surprises dans ce match maintenant à
qu'on s'attendre en contenu ça dépend
beaucoup plus de lignes je pense nepo
satisfait très bien du nul
donc Ding bon déjà il a les blancs et de
deux
de deux qu'est-ce qui pense
de ces
probabilités de victoire en rapides
alors moi je vois pas pourquoi ce serait
moins fort mais lui ok il a un ressenti
il a déjà joué une époque plusieurs fois
en rapide il a son équipe derrière lui
et donc ça va dépendre de ça est-ce que
juste il veut sécher faire nul et aller
au rapide est-ce que il veut jouer un
peu sans prendre trop de risques et il
voit ce qui se passe et c'est rien de
spé bon bah vas-y on fait nul ou alors
il se dit bon ok je suis moins fort
là j'ai les blancs j'ai ma chance je
risque donc ça dépend de risque qu'il
est prêt à prendre et donc
voilà voilà on est pas dans sa tête on
n'est pas
on n'est pas avec leur équipe donc du
radis après j'ai fait mes petites
recherches
niveau stats
pour pour leurs affrontements rapides
justement tu vois pour avoir une petite
idée de voir si il suivait vraiment quoi
et
bon enfin je suis pas tant que ça leur
score en fait en rapides c'est 10 à 7
pour dépôt avec 9 nulles donc bon il y a
pas un écart de ouf mais surtout que la
première fois qu'ils sont juste en 2009
il y avait un match en Chine
mais en fait il faut rappeler qu'il y a
deux ans d'écart entre les deux et donc
en 2007 tu vois en 2009 je veux dire
Ding il est 17 ans nepo était proche de
19 20 ans donc ça joue un peu plus 19
ans
il y a quand même un écart et en plus
Ding il a progressé dans un deuxième
temps
ils vont sortir la balle il fait une
double poussée et
donc on voit une une zone aujourd'hui
bon écoute on va voir moi j'espère une
petite répète dans la berlinoise quand
même ouais non mais c'est pas tant
étonnant qui joue des quatre quand même
c'est son coup numéro 1 même si vous
jouez pas mal d'anglaise dans le match
ou quoi mais maintenant
ouais à voir que je vous dis je sais pas
à quel point est-ce qu'il y a quoi
j'ai pas les caméras donc juste un petit
test pour essayer de les lancer mais ok
joue cette île avec des deux du coup qui
est assez à la mode
mais pas tant surprenant
non mais après enfin après je sais pas
si Ding la version répertoire ou quoi
mais j'ai on l'a déjà vu beaucoup fou
des deux c'est pas comme tour à deux ou
je ne sais quoi tu vois
c'est
je suis en train de régler il y a deux
trois je sais pas pourquoi aujourd'hui
évidemment comme c'est la dernière onde
il a décidé de faire les
et la grande caméra centrale on voit
tout le monde ma salade je l'ai
et on peut pas peut-être qu'on appelle
setup près genre on a la grande caméra
on les voit voilà et puis bon on a les
chic et là-bas vu que c'est le début
comme ça si vous voulez c'est pas c'est
pas trop petit pour vous
c'est quand même histoire d'avoir les
cames au début ouais je pense que Fab a
raison bon enfin bah toujours raison en
fait
fabette de chez fabd
donc
je vais peut-être essayer de la attends
est-ce que je peux encore améliorer tu
vois surtout qu'on peut on pourra un
petit peu modifier tout ça au bout d'un
moment si jamais on a besoin d'analyser
sur le Grand Échiquier
ouais bah c'est la dernière partie de le
dernier dernière partie d'un match
championnat du monde à camé envie Fab de
voir les les joueurs en grand surtout si
les caméras
mon époux chemise bleu aujourd'hui
on voit pas l'aîné non non non
[Musique]
3 à 3 chemises différentes quoi là la
rouge rose saumon
la blanche c'est moi il y a du soleil
qui tombe dans la dans la pièce là tu
vois il y a des ombres est-ce que c'est
de la lumière ou est-ce que c'est c'est
le soleil d'ailleurs
peut-être des zombies je ne sais pas
on ne sait pas Fab et à 3 jouer vite il
repart ah ben voilà le les beaux petits
aller-retours la femme ça nous avait
manqué ce ballet des joueurs
en fait
regarde il rampe
non mais c'est trop pourquoi ils les
font ramper en fait c'est quoi les
consignes je pense que une caméra tu
vois juste derrière regarde un genre de
trépied il doit y avoir une caméra au
dessus et il passe dessous quoi
pas zoomer là-bas plutôt qu'on regarde
les chiquer c'est beaucoup plus
intéressant je crois de voir
par terre
ouais c'est la rampa
[Musique]
sous la caméra
particuliers quand même cette scène moi
j'aurais jamais vraiment réussi à m'y
faire ça fait pas final de championnat
du monde je sais pas trop comment dire
tu vois ça tu as pas l'impression que tu
dois voir en fait pas le truc léopard
par terre autour et des gens qui
rentrent quoi les 5 photographies et
demi en jogging tu vois enfin je sais
pas trop comment dire en costume enfin
pas forcément costume mais ça fait ça
fait mal de classe de fin d'année en 4e
dans dans un collège
du Périgord ouais franchement ça fait
penser à ça sans manquer de respect au
Périgord mais ça fait pas ça fait pas
finale de championnat du monde quoi
mais distribuer des cartons rouges du
siffle à fond quand il revienne
et tiens je crois qu'on a juste un truc
ou qui signale dans le chat c'est que
nebodding tu vois ils sont
alors attends effectivement un Ding a
bien les blancs les amis
voilà
on est beaucoup mieux
après de toute façon il se passe rien là
ça va on a le temps
il se passe vraiment rien c'est ça qui
est beau dans cette finale et qui fait
plaisir
tu as le livre d'ouverture
pour un peu ce qui sont censés faire
d'habitude le livre d'ouverture c'est
pas les stades dans la position ah tu
veux dire les
il faut que je pense et en gros ça
ressemble à
un grand bidame bon ou juste à le foot
case noire des blancs qui est pas passé
devant quoi
on demande un petit match nul là ce
serait sympa d'avoir le département
rapide et d'ailleurs pour la petite
anecdote ce serait vraiment génial
puisque c'est vrai qu'on a vu Magnus qui
voulait que le match en championnat du
monde change le cadence et soit plutôt
rapide mais ça voudrait dire que sur les
quatre derniers matchs de championnat du
monde les trois il y aurait eu trois qui
se réjou en rapide donc finalement que
les 14 premières parties longues sont un
échauffement mais j'ai lu cette critique
à plusieurs reprises avec laquelle je
suis entièrement d'accord c'est étonnant
quand même d'avoir des matchs de
championnats du monde où le départage
est en rapide pas jouer en longue en
mort subite quoi enfin ouais ouais
pourquoi pas au final enfin sur quatre
matchs tu en as trois qui se finissent
en rapide
je préférais moins que ça continue en
mort subite quitte à un tout petit peu
raccourcir la cadence et genre une heure
trente plus 30 secondes de partie par
jour on va t'épuiser enfin tiens on va
vraiment t'épuiser mais on va rester
dans du long que de partir comme ça en
rapide pourquoi en fait c'est juste un
autre jeu
[Musique]
c'est un grand mot mais oui c'est en
fait si on veut le champion du monde
classique il faut que ça joue en jeu
classique bah ouais pourquoi tu fais du
rapide du Blitz du machin
ce sera assez logique de continuer en
longue et puis OK le premier qui qui qui
perd tombe quoi dégage autant de voler
candidats toi je veux plus te voir
ramenez-moi la tête à Magnus je ma
chance pour le titre quoi
mais comme les tir au but c'est un autre
jeu
ouais non mais c'est différent là tu
peux pas comparer
tu peux pas comparer tir au but c'est
pas un autre jeu
non mais comment dire
là il y a eu que 14 parties on n'est pas
bien sûr autant que enfin autant que ça
continue en long on veut vraiment savoir
qui est le meilleur joueur d'échec en
partie longue c'est l'objectif
au final non mais bon en fait je crois
que à cause depuis le match car peuvent
de 84 qu'ils ont pas fini mais
d'ailleurs bon bah vous auriez dû le
finir
ils sont dit ouais bon on arrête les on
veut plus que le match soit
soit éternel si jamais quoi ouais mais
bon au bout d'un moment il faut faire un
choix soit on veut que ce qu'on veut
vraiment être sûr de qui est le meilleur
et donc on fait de on fait des cadences
longues et on fait beaucoup de parties
soit finalement on joue un match du
championnat du monde sur un coup de dés
avec des rapides ou finalement c'est
quasiment le hasard parce que en 25
minutes plus 10 secondes Fabien est-ce
qu'ils ont vraiment le temps de
réfléchir au cou qui joue déjà là
on se trouve quand même des questions
trois heures distribue un titre de
champion du monde d'échecs à une Fabien
sur une cadence rapide de type 25 + 10
ouais une partie dure qu'une heure donc
au bout d'un moment autant jeter des dés
j'ai envie de te dire
pourquoi
[Musique]
non mais ok question intéressante
demeurant
le truc c'est que bon pendant longtemps
c'était aussi quelque chose d'assez
injuste c'est le champion du monde
restait champion du monde
s'il y a 12 parce qu'il y a 24 parties
très souvent donc on a eu le cas
plusieurs fois dans l'histoire on a eu
la bonne vening Bronstein je crois qu'on
est bonne
crème Nick Lego alors c'était pas 24
parties mais etc et
donc oui c'est quand même un désavantage
pour le challenger ils ont décidé de
mettre c'est rapide mais on pourrait
très bien décider bah écoutez s'il y a
égalité on continue et c'est mort subite
et
basta je sais pas pourquoi pas en fait
est-ce que tu es vraiment le meilleur en
langue c'est la question qu'on peut se
poser regarde Maxime qui dit comment ça
en plus c'est vrai qu'il revient à
rajouter de l'eau à notre moulin
s'il y a deux deux en 25 + 10 qui est
quand même un score plus ou moins
logique les cardons ce raccourcissent
encore donc on pourra avoir un
championnat de champion du monde au
rabais finalement
pourquoi pourquoi Fabien
non mais à la fin
pourquoi pas élargir
son proches c'est pas déconnant qu'il
soit départagé en rapide ouais enfin 14
parties c'est quand même assez peu tous
un ouverture genre historiquement les
matchs étaient en 24 et même même plus
ce serait pas ce serait pas délirant de
de continuer à 1h30 plus 30 secondes tu
peux jouer vraiment deux parties par
jour tu viens le matin à 10h on joue
deux enfin et le premier qui perd voilà
enfin c'est terminé
qui perçoit qui perd ça ouais
un nouveau concept
en tout cas vraiment ça joue ouais
ça joue ça joue encore attention non
mais je crois que c'est juste l'ordi
il transpose autre chose quoi
[Rires]
en fait c'est ça mais c'est censé être
trop blanc ah ouais mais c'est pas la
ouais c'est vrai ce que j'allais dire
je sais pas trop toi
si c'est fou c'est un c'est
extraordinaire non non ça c'est juste
l'ordi qui te fait un fouet
non mais va nous développer le fou en E2
il va faire B4 il va faire un truc un
truc comme ça je sais pas donc normal
quoi quelqu'un qui a pas la rêve de
carpov Castorama en réalité carpov
casparrov c'est un match qui se jouait
au premier à 6 victoires c'était comme
ça avant c'était le premier à ton de
victoire donc six ou 10 ou quoi bon ben
6 pourquoi pas
sauf que ben carpaf il est arrivé très
rapidement à 5 victoires et après ils
ont bloqué à 5,3 ouais en fait
le lendemain 5 3 et puis je sais pas
épuisement ils ont dit ouais bon le
match interminable on arrête quoi ça
faisait des mois qui jouait en fait
c'était ça a duré combien 5 6 mois je
sais plus enfin
et voilà donc
[Musique]
bonne humeur décision je sais pas tu
vois casse pas grave c'est plein à dire
oui je commence à prendre le dessus ils
ont voulu protéger carpov ça jouait qui
était épuisé
après moi je sais pas j'étais pas là
mais en fait depuis ce match là on n'a
jamais plus vu ce format du premier
attend de victoire ils ont chaque fois
dit ce sera 24 parties si annulent s'il
y a 12-12 le champion a ce champion etc
puis après petit à petit le champion on
était à 24 parties puis 16 parties puis
12 parties pourquoi pas deux parties non
mais oui
on part quand même de 24 pour arriver
finalement à 12 là on remonte à 14 ah
non mais oui
pourquoi pas finalement jouer à un match
championnat du monde sur deux parties
rapides Fabien tiens pour te dire un
Fisher lui il te dit que champion du
monde normalement ce qui concerne le
vrai bon format c'est le premier à 10
victoires
là tu me parles et que si il y a 9 le
champion a ce champion ça c'est Fisher
on aura un super match oh c'est tu fais
un carwan à Carlson
en 10 victoires tu es là
je vais bosser pendant un an sur le
match tu reviens tous les jours ils ont
encore fait nul bon pas de bol mais
c'est là pendant 4 ans peut-être mais
c'est pas grave
reste champion du monde tu as plus aucun
challenger le match
dure pour l'éternité
mais voilà bon ça c'était le ce que
Fisher voulais quoi
donc il conserve qu'il y a plus aucun
champion du monde depuis
ce n'est plus le bon format
on peut pas voir les filles qui en grand
et les caves en tout petit non
non pour le pour le dernier jour on aime
bien là on est heureux de voir les
filles qui ont pas le
réel en grand
en profite un peu de la tension de ce
dernier match surtout que là pour
l'instant il se passe pas grand chose on
les joueurs sont dans leur préparation
ou pas d'ailleurs oh probablement
tu as le verding qui joue fouder 2 bon
niveau normal dessin qu'à trois fois 7
après il te fait C5 bon quand même un
peu normal mais donc là
[Musique]
bon je sais pas j'aurais l'impression vu
de loin une B4 serait plus ou moins
logique
mais on peut se questionner sur se fout
des deux par rapport au fait si tu fais
B4 tu es content souvent
mais bon ça me paraît quand même un coup
logique même si moi je suis pas trop
expert de ce genre de position après a
priori j'imagine tu peux te développer
bêtement
je sais pas où
DAMS
mais non mais il connaît enfin ça peut
pas être autrement
dans ce match on ne sait plus faire
non
plus tard ou je sais pas tu vois ça je
peux comprendre mais là de pas connaître
ça
alors tu rentres des deux pieds dedans
un petit partage comme à Koh-Lanta on
fait revenir les joueurs des candidats
et il vote on les met debout sur des
Picasses sinon
qui passe
il doit être content de son ouverture
Yann quand même je pense
bah disons dingue ouais il est pas allé
recherché dans les positions
qui ont apporté du succès donc c'est
c'est Carlsbad
inversé j'ai envie de dire mais
voilà bon il a joué des quatre C4
[Musique]
on va voir
du coup dans cette position c'est quoi
les parties un peu
des masses mais il y a dedans chenko
et donc Shinko c'était
au chemin d'Europe par équipe
ok bon
il est venu
normal rien de trop impressionnant pour
les blancs mais c'est une partie quoi
ça pourrait ça pourrait arriver dans une
position avec un pion isolé donc et puis
c'est et eux qui pourraient qui
pourraient s'échanger mais c'est même
pas forcément obligatoire on verra
bah disons si on prend maintenant
pour le moment oui
mais j'apprends du pion même là pourquoi
pas un pion isolé mais il a pas l'air
particulièrement mal pour le noir quoi
et ce fou c'est un est-ce que c'est si
absurde ça m'a l'air trop bizarre
parce que qu'est-ce que tu as fait avec
ton fond noir finalement ça fait B4 ça
c'est 5 alors attends
il a pas perdu assez de temps avec son
fou il passe par des 6 encore
c'est moi il a pas joué j'ai
l'impression qu'il jouait désolé fausse
alerte
il fait semblant de jouer des fois ouais
de faire semblant de prendre la balle et
pas la prendre c'est complètement
interdit
l'arbitre notre respecte pas du tout si
tu fais ça tu as voulu induire en erreur
la défense c'est pas du tout pris pour
un placement de jambes tu dois citer
dans un dans un rêve
tu fais pas le fifou regarde il est hors
jeu non ça ça
comme le lanceur il y a pas de pas de
filouterie
alors que digne c'est vrai qu'il fait
des feintes de coup
je suis un peu inquiet pour lui quand
même enfin
[Musique]
en fait j'ai peur de prendre mais bon il
va faire cavalier
tiens
bon là quand même tu te rapproches d'une
belle nul quoi
mais bon malheureusement
tu es pas obligé de faire pousser trois
machin et je pense qu'il va prendre du
pion en dessin avec mon époque tu peux
faire dames tes deux trois et taper sur
le rock
si c'est même si on a le foot c'est toi
qui arrive
[Musique]
je t'en fais j'ai promette tu connais
pas ce coup mais oui il va prendre
[Musique]
on en parle plus on va des partages
enfin tu vois ce que je pouvais pas
croire
avec le pion enfin à 2 à 7 là
ce genre de truc
ça c'est bien nul
ouais
on sait pas de toute façon c'est lui qui
a réfléchit mais c'est vrai que là ça ne
veut plus l'impression que je cherche à
me souvenir ou je réfléchis un peu
ça fait je suis livré un par moi-même et
j'improvise
on repart sur les grandes cannes Fab en
attendant le coup de Ding le D comme on
l'appelle ici on a plus les photographes
photographes je pense qu'ils sont
autorisés pendant les 10 premières
minutes et puis après ça dégage la
racaille photographique trop de soleil
quoi surtout je crois
[Musique]
est-ce que ça peut être du bluff non non
pas pas à ce moment de la compétition
pas ici pas maintenant pas pour cette
partie
je sais pas
mon épouse ça va ça le rassure il a pas
l'air trop mal mais bon on sait jamais
trop il a le petit thermos
ah il va en fait il va il va dans la
salle de repos pour se remplir le
thermos c'est très heureux
cafetière un truc
peut-être tu vas te faire son matcha
là-bas
ont le droit à la vare en cas de litige
où il faut qu'ils aient vu il faut
qu'ils aient vu
normalement
b4c5 se crée une majorité
après
je veux pas d'attestation direct mais
j'aime pas te laisser le centre mobile
j'aime pas te laisser des bêtises à 5
casser les pions enfin il y a plein de
trucs qui me
qui te détecte
C5 avec un pion en D4 2 3 bon
ça ressemble à des panneaux qui se passe
bien
ça change un peu
un peu beaucoup
parce que la chemise obligatoire pour
les joueurs alors je sais pas il y a
peut-être un dress code
j'en sais rien
après oui bon pour un champion du monde
tu peux tu peux essayer d'être un petit
peu habillé correctement quoi
Yann
je crois que c'était le coup de
il est plus ou moins logique dans le
sens où tu te libères la case des 1 pour
mettre une tour tu mets ta avancée de
toute façon c'est une case où elle est
contente d'aller tu pourras jouer 3
jours peut-être viser de l'autre côté
donc c'est
une case pour la dame il y a pas de
souci
puis en français 4 à tempo bon là je
t'annonce que le pion C4 va être
grignoté par le fou par le fouet du coup
notre structure c'est typique des
gambinamaxé plutôt structure symétrique
si je puis me permettre le mot le mot
est lâché Fabien carrément quoi
structure symétrique donc un petit
avantage blanc pourquoi parce qu'ils ont
un avantage de développement mais c'est
peut-être pas suffisant pour prétendre
vraiment à quoi que ce soit mais c'est
un peu plus agréable à jouer avec les
pièces blanches j'ai l'impression que
Yann connaît il a pas été surpris non
non mais il est bien préparé Yann alors
des fois une inverse les coups il
confond mais mais sur l'ensemble des 14
parties je verse je suis ravin food 2
quoi le faire du temps il est excuse-moi
Fabien mais ce qui est un joueur classé
aux alentours de 21500 et l'eau peut se
permettre
quand même finaliste du Championnat du
Monde dois-je te le rappeler certes
je me fais un peu l'avocat du diable et
vous avez bien raison
et si un joueur du calibre de Yann se
trompe
quand il vraiment d'ailleurs
tu dis ça parce que tu as l'ordinateur
voilà et voilà merci
bon faut prendre ces quatre pas jouer à
tempo j'ai l'impression que Ding est pas
dans ça pas dans sa partie Fab
il suit un peu enfin il est pas il y a
quelque chose qui sait pas super bien
passé alors est-ce que c'est une
histoire de mémoire est-ce que c'est ils
ont espéré autre chose bon on peut pas
vraiment le savoir en réalité
[Musique]
je ne sais pas mais ça donne
l'impression enfin vu la pression qu'il
a prédit coup en gros il joue un peu
mais qui compte pas
après c'est vrai qu'il risque vraiment
rien quoi
on a la petite turbine et tout ce qui
joue vite c'est la première ligne
7 c'est pas le coup le plus dur ce que
tu as envie de sortir le cavalier mais
si tu sais pas
si ce B5 faut B7 enfin là il y a matière
à à avoir un temps de réflexion un peu
plus long et il y a dans le sang très
serein
il joue vite et il joue les meilleurs
coups donc qui connaît un Yann
il vient
[Musique]
renforcer le cavalier F6 donc souvent
dans genre situation c'est vrai que ça
s'appelle kifi c'est que les gens font
des coups comme cavaliero 4 ou kg 5 kg 4
tu peux manquer de soutien vers ton roi
là bon voilà mais il se souviennent l'un
l'autre le foot casse blanche qui compte
à aller le développer sur la grande
diagonale après un fiancé donc il sera
bien de ce côté et les Noirs vont
égalisés regardez admettons rock disons
B6 tout rêve D1 ce sont des coups
logiques fou B7 sourate C1
il va pas se laisser faire
il se déteste
comme le dit Fab un coup comme fou prend
F3 ici n'est pas fin n'est pas gênant
non non en fait tu es content tu es
content avec
ton droit tu as toujours fait un qui
revient et puis là tu as essayé de
mettre un front C3 et taper sur G7
ça c'est bien tu vois je l'ai même pas
vu enfin comme je joue à vous tous ces
structures là j'ai même pas pensé à faut
prendre parce que vas-y prends viens me
chercher
ça vous je suis en géant viens me
chercher finalement je change
de case
je veux pas mon adresse
mais j'ai quatre envisageable
mais bon ici le fait c'est qui du coup
il joue son va-tout mais
une telle position en vrai tu sais quoi
c'est moins mauvais que ce que j'ai
pensé à première vue non non
tu fais un truc là-bas mais bon bah hier
genre c'est sur grand rock le mec te
garantissait qui joue à h6 franchement
là pour y penser bien sûr mais comme il
est bien ouvert nos trois et puis on a
le pion à trois donc B 5 B4 ça arrive
aussi
j'ai 4
[Rires]
c'est trop
c'est bon
tu penses à H4 là tout de suite ah ouais
c'est vrai que c'est des coups qu'on
voit maintenant
tu sais pas
mais
en fait comme je disais au tout début de
la retransmission c'est soit
ça tu te crois moins fort ou tu te sais
moins fort ton adversaire pour les
rapides et que tu dis ok c'est mon
moment et je dois faire et donc tu fais
des H4 des trucs comme ça
si tu es pas moins fort faut pas risquer
tu joues ton ouverture pour voir si
de gagner mais tu fais quoi tu fais tes
tours au centre tu fais tes machins et
puis il égalise illégalise nul allez à
demain quoi
mais je sais pas comment eux ils ont
envisagé la situation justement en tout
cas c'est pas idiot comme coup d'un coup
tu pousses quoi c'est un vrai coup ça te
permet de pousser le pion H a fait bien
le roi de passer la tour
ça te soutient du kij5 mais bon il y a
le client des sacs qui défend bien quand
même
H4 pour choqué
mais le plan de la Seine en
grand
en direct d'Astana
ça ça peut
je vais voir si c'est si nous parle d'un
H4 ou pas
mais quelle hauteur dans le truc il y a
alors coup numéro un petit rock 0.06
l'union de b4006 qui a eu au 4 0 0 tours
0 0 31 0 H4 - 0,04 donc c'est quand même
coup numéro 6 c'est pas non plus mais
c'est pas c'est pas affreux quoi enfin
c'est juste un différentiel de 0,12 quoi
entre le top coup et H4 ouais je t'en
prie donc ok bon soit il va jouer normal
du genre voilà rock qui avait lieu 4 B4
bien sûr si on veut c'est pas des
mauvais coups tout ça H4 c'est le coup
offensif
bon on attend un Fab voilà c'est plus de
notre
bizarre ce début de partie quand même
on verra bien mais mon ressenti c'est
que
Ding doit être mieux préparé que ça
normalement pour une telle partie ça
fait partie de sa vie quoi et
en fait donc soit tu vas chercher ton
adversaire tu refais le Kars inversé
[Musique]
contre toi et je comprends ce que tu es
arrivé dans un entre deux qui pourrait
rappeler du carpov Caspar of
pas tout à fait pareil mais quand même
pour ceux qui ont la rêve du match
Séville
Séville voilà ou carpov justement avait
les Noirs ils venait 12 ans nous avons
la dernière partie et donc nul lui
suffit pas de champion et tout au long
de la partie en fait il a eu des
décisions à prendre
est-ce que je joue un poil risqué ce que
je garde la position comme elle est en
fait tu es tellement content de faire
nul tu veux juste qu'il se passe rien et
à force tu prends des décisions sub
optimales ce petit match optimal et tu
te fous dans la merde petit à petit quoi
mais voilà donc rock très bien B4 très
bien qui avait lieu au 4 j'imagine très
bien border un souhaitable
et H4 semi bizarre mais complètement
jouable mais du coup au parti
[Musique]
si il part sur un chat c'est que ok il
joue pour gagner ou pas mais on donne
tout d'un coup normal il n'y a pas il y
a pas de souci alors qu'est-ce qui fait
avec les Noirs
il se garde maintenant il se garde pas
vraiment de H4
pour moi pour moi c'est c'est sept tours
là qui allait en D1 et c'est là qu'elle
est en C1 tu vois si on refait la
variante de tout à l'heure B6 petit rock
fou B7 donc les coups logiques
finalement là tu préférerais en grand on
préférerait avoir
voudrais jouer ton FC quoi pour faire
simplement et donc on aurait mis la
mauvaise tour en D1 non alors à mon avis
s'il a fait tourner maintenant c'est
qu'il veut essayer de jouer sur le
vis-à-vis tourdam vite pas laisser le
temps de donner de quoi noir rock
tourner pour je sais pas faire cavaluka
de faire quelque chose mais ce qu'on
peut l'exploiter alors ça c'est une
autre histoire c'est juste quelque chose
comme ça je vous montre décidé de faire
donc là il veut peut-être qu'il y ait
penser 5 mais voilà c'est discutable
enfin discutable ça se joue
4 avec les autres
pour les Noirs tu vas faire un moment
mais peut-être ça va juste bien
s'échanger un truc comme ça mais oui
pardon allez une somme il faut j'imagine
c'est Dame 7
parce que tu t'enlèves du vis-à-vis mais
tu développes pas si vite et après je
sais pas sur B4 ce qui se passe
qu'est-ce qu'on fait du fou parce qu'on
aura bien ramené au stade de base tu
peux l'enlever
5 ça se regarde
il faut ces trois mais peut-être que
c'est rien ben voilà bon là on dirait on
rentre dans le domaine du jeu concret
quoi mais voilà j'imagine torder un il
doit vouloir un truc comme ça de vite
exploiter ce vis-à-vis on ne panique pas
on peut jouer B6 donc comme tu disais
cavalier 4 ça semble être la suite de
l'idée et sur cavalier prend le 4 on
veut dame prend le 4 et on touche la
tour à 8 qui n'est pas protégée qui va
devoir se décaler éventuellement B8 et
fousser 3 donc là on serait très bien on
a on a tous les vis-à-vis positifs avec
les Blancs exactement
le fou qui parvenu en T3 aussi
éventuellement
le piège 4 mais oui sur cam4 a priori il
va pas nous échanger il va faire un fou
B7 on va lui bouffer ses cinq ou F6
avoir et un truc comme ça
[Musique]
ouais où là on a la paire de fou mais en
fait les noirs peuvent s'en débarrasser
assez facilement d'ailleurs une fois de
plus la Tour Eiffel sur l'autre côté
pour faire et cacher le four
des quatre encore non peut-être
peut-être
mais bon ce genre ça va mais on peut
jouer aux échecs là-dedans mais c'est
objectivement ça va pour les Noirs il
faut quand même toujours regarder ce qui
est G5 à un moment c'est pénible ça veut
échanger le calife 3 mais c'est la même
chose que le kf6d noir c'est ce que
j'expliquais à nisky hier pour les
joueurs donc ils sont en dessous de aux
alentours de 1000 et l'eau en dessous
mais quoi que même on va dire 1300 les
fous comme ça quand ils sont trop cent
trop ils sont pas très bien placés au
milieu de partie ils sont bien quand ils
sont reculés genre là on aimerait
tellement avoir du B4 fois deux fois
il est très bien aussi mais pour
attaquer de loin mais là le truc c'est
qu'on se fait un peu prendre de fin
prendre de vitesse on peut on peut le
tenter quand même mais
oui il faut surélever le 5 il faut
surveiller enfin tous les manque un ou
deux temps pour vraiment éloigner les
fous du combat et être mieux ecoute il a
joué 7 direct ok
bon pourquoi pas enfin j'en sais rien en
fait bijou vite mais ce n'est beau mais
je veux dire enfin je suis à présent je
suis sûr qu'il connaissait
là il est un peu réfléchi et donc il est
prêt à la décision très vite pour un
coup pas évident enfin pourquoi faut 7
plutôt que B6
après pourquoi mon probablement qui
connaît le genre de position
qui sait où il veut placer ses pièces
etc donc bon
puisqu'il a joué fou B4
la flèche est bien épaisse le jaune est
bien jaune
bien orangé même
donc il y a clairement vous lui éviter
après cavalier 4 que le fou soit fragile
fragilisé
bon Adeline qui peut évidemment roquet
l'autre option c'est peut-être de
commencer à jouer aux 4
c'est toujours à double tranchant mais
c'est vrai que maintenant que le fou a
beaucoup bougé c'est ça
tout le temps
et au 4 bah ça donne quoi comme ça donne
le fait que le foot est de puisse sortir
de sa tanière maintenant ça peut
permettre parfois de faire le 5 chasser
le fameux kf6 et se donner la case des 6
pour mettre un cavalier dessus donc ça
peut vite devenir sympa c'est cool de 4
béton
[Musique]
donc on peut pas donc c'est seulement ça
l'idée même OK
du trafic maintenant j'essaye de roquet
tu fais à 6 je me barre
on se trompe avec des cartes pour
toucher ses 6 sur B5
peut-être oui tu me touches
j'ai réussi ça y est j'ai mon full mon
portée qui se décale sur les deux
diagonales ça on adore
parce que
le bloc un peu la tour à 8 le foot est
pas encore bien développé
je l'ai pas encore à cause de quel point
F3 échec mais ça roule quand même et sur
B5 est-ce que j'ai un truc
et on bouffe non
donc on voit là il y a peut-être un
petit un petit scénario à exploiter donc
évidemment nous avec un peu l'aide de la
turbine vous nous avez parlé de ce 4
intéressant
non mais c'est un coup
vraisemblable
c'est un coup logique mais après rock et
aussi un coup logique bien sûr c'est ça
la difficulté c'est que là le 4 c'est
logique je crois que c'est logique enfin
tout est logique en fait
par contre rock tu vois B6 4 tu vois moi
je le ferai plus dans ce sens là
personnellement mais
avec les Blancs
mais c'est sûrement bien aussi enfin je
veux dire pourquoi pas faire
bon et on exploite finalement ce fou ces
cinq qui serait bien placé dans cette
structure puisque on aurait affaibli via
E4 les cases noires et ce cadre vient
exploiter le le fou qui a un peu trop
bougé
pour cesser avec 4 et Europe se valent
bah tu vois
moi j'arrive quand même commencé par
rock parce que je sais pas tu en avoir
besoin de ce rock et je vois pas de
coups miracle contre quatre côté noir
non non
premier mais tu vois après ça c'est
ouais je sais pas trop dire
[Musique]
en me disant
mais bon en fait on va dire je crois que
ça va être un peu un peu la même chose
en fait je vois pas d'autres options que
rock avec ide4 direct et le la bonne
nouvelle donc si l'ordinateur confirme
que commencer par rock ni hypothèque pas
l'avantage mais il faut ça c'est
peut-être juste douteux c'est bizarre
comme coup parce que c'est sur anticipé
alors que tu avais du B6 tu avais
d'autres coups jouable et que ton foot
allait remettre
façon c'était pas impossible un jour ou
l'autre et puis d'ailleurs on a vu le
cas de figure où tu laisses se faire
échanger tu joues sans la paire de fou
mais tout va bien il y avait aussi
d'autres d'un troisième cas de figure
qu'on a pas eu dans nos variantes mais
où tu réussis à décaler ta tour en D88
franchement
[Musique]
il y a une énorme erreur d'après
l'ordinateur
mais c'est vrai que
non mais ça a l'impression de
contre-sens ma chérie tu as contre sens
en fait je sais pas j'imagine qu'il
veut peut-être te dire si on faisait
quatre attaquer j'ai le temps de la
ramener en e2f3 je te fais une sorte de
catalane
pour sortir
non mais moi je pense
pourquoi en fait mais je sais pas
l'autre c'est pas assez sympa
est-ce qu'il veut ça aussi
mais bon
pourquoi tu sautes sur les champs
contre D7 en investissant trois coups
non il veut acheter
alors ça parfois c'est quelque chose
qu'on fait quand il y a trop de pression
et que on arrive
pas trop à tenir tu prends l'initiative
quoi tu prends le taureau par les cornes
quoi
non c'est possible qu'on vive pas une
grande partie en termes de niveau de jeu
mais bon niveau émotion et
arrondissement ça peut ça peut être
comme comme il y a deux jours enfin il y
a trois jours ouais effectivement il
veut pas une une partie où il met une
petite pression pendant longtemps mais
un peu comme il avait refusé le tour B8
qui nous a beaucoup surpris il veut tout
de suite prendre à la gorge et essayer
de de mener une attaque de maths et pour
ça qu'il a pas ok et que
je veux pas te laisser sacrifier est-ce
que B6 c'est un coup tu te fais déjà
triviller des trucs sur aussi ou quoi
[Musique]
pour repartir vers B1 et ils te disent
damser si c'est ce qui nous ont dit dans
le chat
il va faire tourner 8 et
peut-être il va trouver un C6 mais genre
c'est pas le coup j'ai rien en premier
quand même bon B6 non
très franchement j'aurais pu ouais genre
ce qu'on dit tu sais
et je m'enlève des cavaliers B5 et
j'attaque ça j'aurais pu
déjà je me dis que au pire je ferai du
roi F1 et puis de toute façon ils sont
vraiment fins mais tu vas faire baisser
faut baisser tu attaquer j'ai dedans
mais peut-être en fait c'est très fort
mais bon oui on va voir une partie comme
ça très convives très tu repars en eux
deux pour venir toucher la case F3 qui
est pas mal dans ses structures là quand
même
et sur B6 comme ça enfin sur dame C6
avait fouf 3 et sur B6 tu pourras mettre
le rang F1 mais ce qui est donc
on a un peu attaqué le vent quoi ok oui
mais juste pour pour ajouter on peut pas
on peut plus faire petit rock à cause de
pions prangés sains
si on joue de la sorte
j'aime pas trop non mais ça va jouer aux
émotions là ça joue plus aux échecs là
ça joue sur les émotions j'aime pas trop
ce que je vois dans ce qu'on analyse
mais
[Musique]
bon après
je préfère largement
oui mais bon
[Musique]
éclairé mais pleutre quand même
début de partie surprenant
les deux âmes qui vont se donner à fond
ok parti à l'image du match ça combat à
fond il y a pas de
combat il y a pas de repos il y a pas de
temps mort
[Musique]
c'est deux hommes face à leur destin
il fait assez impossible de champignons
alors que pour la première fois on voit
du soleil sur l'oeil en bas de Yann
regarde peut-être un signe du destin
Fabien
lumière
est apparu
pour cette dernière partie du match
tu avais les dessins que ce serait beau
une image de café
avec un dise quoi là là comme qui cite
un peu Magnus de toute façon le gagnant
ne sera que champion du monde et pas
plus et rien de plus important quand
même cette précision de Magnus celui qui
gagnera ce match sera champion du monde
d'échecs mais pas plus
toujours des beaux commentaires de la
part de Manu c'est toujours la classe
toujours la grande classe
il a raison ah mais il a complètement
raison ouais
il est un peu le son
du monde mais il sera jamais aussi fort
que vague
j'ai l'impression que quand tu as trop
besoin de tout le temps dire que tu es
supérieur aux autres c'est que tu as un
complexe d'infériorité quelque part quoi
j'imagine pas Nadal pendant la finale de
Roland-Garros tu vois si je joue si il
est pas parce qu'il est blessé ou quoi
tu n'auras le vainqueur de ce match
façons n'aura rien fait de plus que
gagner Roland-Garros j'imagine tellement
fort Nadal dire un truc pareil
j'imagine pas un grand champion de dire
ce genre de truc en fait c'est pas une
attitude de champion je sais pas j'ai
l'impression qu'on est champion du haut
oui bon là bah bravo
mais envoyer 40 millions de d'interviews
à gauche à droite pour tout le temps
répéter ça oui ils sont vraiment pas
très forts
non mais ça donne l'impression que en
fait tu es soit tu es gris soit tu es un
complexe
plus profond quoi
et G6 ouais non c'est un peu trop
affaiblissant comme G6 si tu as pas le
choix tu le fais mais si on fait pas
quoi
un Tyson Tyson il était pas comme ça il
disait enfin moi je suis pas mal
interview de Tyson il disait tout le
temps que le plus grand boxeur tous les
temps c'était Mohamed Ali machin
ouais j'avais vu son livre qui était
sympa biographie
à gauche à droite avant les matchs mais
en boxe un peu obligé mais une fois que
le match est fini souvent ça se calme
d'ailleurs mais avant les matchs
mais tu vas pas commenter les matchs des
autres à dire
[Musique]
il y a que Maggie non mais c'est la
table le truc c'est qu'il est beaucoup
plus direct il est moins sournois il dit
je suis le meilleur je suis un lion je
peux pas
[Musique]
mais Magnus a l'impression qu'il a quand
il a envie de le dire sans trop le dire
quoi ouais je sais pas
il est un peu spécial
mais sans être trop caché non plus
mais je pense qu'il a le somme que le
match soit serré intéressant pour le
public je pense qu'il aurait aimé que ce
soit un match que personne regarde et
regardez ils sont nuls mais d'ailleurs
je crois qu'il a un peu le seum quoi le
truc c'est que beaucoup de gens
pensaient ça avant quoi le match est
intéressé très peu de gens et puis
bon match c'était pas mal quoi enfin je
veux dire il y a de l'intensité il y a
des parties
il y a il se passe des choses et je
pense ça dépasse les attentes
de beaucoup quoi
ok si je jouais
il est 11h52
ou pas on laisse revenir on se dit on
regarde son cou et on pose exactement
femme mais moi je veux une pièce sur H4
parce qu'en fait si c'est pas H4 et qui
fait qu'il y a des G4 la stratégie
uniquement c'est pas fondé revenir en F3
bon bah là et ça se trouve c'est pas si
mauvais enfin tu es pas si mal après
qu'il est F3 mais bon tu bon mais
c'est pour ça quand même donc il va en
voyage 4
et il faut prendre aussi sinon il fera
pas alors déjà il y a je prends G5 mais
combien vous ferez votre fou qui va
aller prendre vous prenez la tour c'est
rarement une si bonne idée que ça de
donner deux pièces dans une tour si toi
dans la partie
en finale la tour a son mot à dire parce
qu'il y a plus de colonne ouvertes elle
peut rentrer dans le CLIN d'inverse il y
a moins de pièces donc couper le roi
attaquer une aile l'autre elle n'ont
plus la partie avance plus la tour prend
du galon j'ai envie de dire trop tôt
comme ça c'est pas trop de bonne idée
mais là en plus vous prenez ici s'il y a
juste à manger
5 tu te fais chasser HK tu donnes pas
une pièce à vrai dire un pion prend si
le cavalier bouge à mat donc tu
récupères la pièce immédiatement donc
c'est pas un sacrifice mais le seul truc
c'est que si les Noirs commencent à se
décaler et à réussir à te taper sur G2
avec les Blancs tu seras juste mal parce
que
ordonné je veux dire le jour où la tour
est fuite s'en va en débite par exemple
tu veux faire Roy fit tu fais de barrer
tu es pas mat facilement quand même donc
oui après ça marche peut-être pas trop
enfin disons j'aime pas trop
je crois qu'objectivement c'est pas ouf
mais maintenant qu'il est parti
là-dessus allons-y et je dois dire que
ouais pour les coronaires en fait on
peut pas enlever sading qui il en a quoi
il envoie il envoie chaque partie quoi
donc
ça lui fait pas peur d'embrayage 4 ça
c'est sûr
son titre en jeu si tu refuses tu le
perds et tu vas planter des tulipes en
silence moi je pense comme ça aussi tu
vas pas donner 40 interviews pour dire
j'ai refusé défendre mon titre mais
regardez comme ils sont nuls enfin c'est
pas
c'est comme quand est champion tu vas
pas après que tu es perdu contre une
partie contre un gamin de 19 ans dire
non regarde il a triché tu as des
problèmes non non personne ne fait ça
enfin si dans le monde normal ou les
gens font ça ils se font plus personne
te respecte normalement mais bon après
c'est c'est pas des trucs qui se font
enfin c'est
mais ça se fait pas trop
enfin elle est très grand champion qui
rentre dans l'histoire et tout tu as
l'impression que ils sont
[Musique]
ouais non je sais pas ouais non mais je
sais pas Djokovic je parle d'une finale
de l'US Open il était dopé attendez
prêt peut-être qu'il le pense mais bon
j'ai perdu l'autre a fait un grand match
c'est beaucoup spécialisé sur cette
surface
il a donné quoi cette histoire de plugin
je crois qu'il y a un procès en ce
moment aux États-Unis mais j'ai pas
suivi de près puis bon vu la vitesse
alors je sais pas si c'est pareil là-bas
qu'ici mais
en France les procès des fois ça te
prend des années des années pour pour
avoir le verdict
et donc je sais pas ça se trouve ça va
prendre des années là aussi
je sais pas si réclame 100 millions ou
500 millions des dommagesment j'ai
toujours pas compris d'ailleurs s'il
demande 100 millions de dollars de
dommagesment à Magnus aikaru enfin ou au
total c'est 4 fois ou cinq fois 100
millions ou si c'est une fois 100
millions et que chacun doit donner 25
quoi ou 20 ou quelque chose
c'est deux fois des belles sommes
et on verra bien
un milliard chat
mais pourquoi pas
cinq fois six milliards
oui il joue pas le H4 bah écoute ça va
être l'heure de la pause qu'on doit
faire les pauses d'autant plus
aujourd'hui les petites les petites
pubasses qui peuvent partir femmes donc
let's go en pause
quand même avant la pause hein parce que
on voyait cavalier hg5 se prendra H6
hésiter pour faire H4 enfin ouais c'est
je sens pas dans son assiette j'espère
que
voilà mais bon c'est très mauvais signe
[Musique]
à combien de pas me dire c'est très fin
de faire les G5
je ne l'entendrai pas je n'ai que
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a eu ce H4 qu'on attendait qui
était prévu et prévisible le cavalier G5
H6 appelé obligatoirement le H4 c'est
c'est c'était tu dis ah tu dis B c'est
quasiment une obligation pour dinguieren
de le jouer et il a joué maintenant
Sayan de répondre et Yann n'est toujours
pas revenu ça y est il arrive il revient
enfin alors
qu'il en salle de repos hein les joueurs
ont des écrans sur lesquels ils peuvent
regarder la la la partie et donc
réfléchir non pas devant l'échiquier
mais depuis leur canapé en salle de
repos ne pensez pas Kyan vient de jeter
10 minutes à la poubelle il était
simplement
probablement avachi sur sur son
H4 objectivement
tu as pas l'air fantastique mais ça fait
ça fait une partie animée ça crée des
problèmes pratiques à l'adversaire il va
falloir les résoudre pour Yann quoi
donc voilà ça maintient donc lequel est
en G5 et là l'idée des blancs donc c'est
de faire ici trois ou quatre C3 enlever
les cavaliers
CE4 admettons
est-ce que je peux prendre maintenant
probablement pas tu prends F6 et tu
reprends G5
non oui donc là dessus
donc ça veut dire
peut-être maintenant tu as le temps de
faire un B5 à sa fin touche le fou avec
l'idée sur fouder 3 de prendre en C2
est-ce que tu
est-ce qu'on a mieux que personne
on annule mais bon te prennent toujours
pas G5 mais oui en fait faut pas croire
que le cahier est imprenable à vie
c'est-à-dire que pour l'instant il n'est
pas prenable et chaque coup on se repose
la question quand même surtout que ouais
avec le dame C7 ce vis-à-vis qui peut un
jour provoquer un échange de dames et si
la tour était en D8 ben là on pourrait
changer les dates mais sur X7 on aurait
roi F8
donc attention voilà la partie
mouvementée non ça peut ne pas de très
longtemps et qui a un KO de partout il
peut y avoir un chaos ici il peut y
avoir une gaffe
tu fais quoi si ton adversaire touche
son cavalier FC c'est obligé de dire
jadoub ben je lui dis toucher et puis tu
veux même si tu vois qu'il était en
train d'adouber tu lui dis toucher ouais
final championnat du monde là tu fais un
truc enfin c'est juste la règle quoi moi
j'y peux rien quoi
pas de chance
de RADEX
trajet j'ai quasiment envie de dire ce
serait mieux pour les deux joueurs de
rejouer ça sur quatre parties en rapides
plutôt que de s'infliger là une partie
mais qui peut
[Musique]
bah écoute c'est bien si genre on a
souvent connu
pas être au top justement non ces
moments-là alors sauf qu'on est là où il
a bien sûr volé de fois de suite je
comprends pas vraiment le coup mais non
mais enfin on en a déjà parlé quoi enfin
je rappelle analyse à chaque coup comme
on a dit que ça sert à rien de bouffer
deux pièces pour une tour en fait je
comprends pas en fait
qui le 5 et des trois afin de la blague
quoi
en finale oui si j'enlève plein de
pièces pourquoi pas
on a vraiment déjà fait quoi je veux
dire on a dit quoi attends j'ai une
question surtout étroit B6 si je fais
prend aussi maintenant
mais là par exemple vous B3 B6 il y a du
cavalier des 5 qui rode avec elle
le fameux
est peut-être plus intéressant que X 2
parce que il protège la dame il y a plus
de poison dans le cou
OK et du coup dame C6 prend doublement
son sens parce que ça
[Musique]
évite la menace et je pense qu'à faire
ouais enfin là dessus
bah oui parce que
[Musique]
c'est naze en fait avec les Blancs
non non mais je crois que H4 c'est pas
trop bon objectif mais juste
[Musique]
tu espères pas non plus jouer tous les
meilleurs coups et que que
ça a l'air d'une catastrophe
industrielle à l'ouverture de Ding le
cavalier G5 H4 alors qu'il avait on le
remontrera dans notre récap d'après
partie mais il avait la simple option
rock 4 qui donnait pas forcément un gros
avantage aux plans mais tu étais en
contrôle et tu mettais une petite
pression toutes les erreurs étaient là
sur l'échiquier attendu d'être fait de
la part de nepo
alors que là j'ai l'impression que que
les erreurs sont sont possibles aux
côtés Ding harnisky qui nous demande ça
se passe comment aujourd'hui du bon jeu
écoute finale finale de championnats du
monde toi-même tu connais hein c'est
dernière blocs
un petit peu côté blanc pour le moment
mais il prend des risques il joue il
joue offensif
par rapport à ce que ça ça mériterait je
me tente à une métaphore lol vas-y bah
je pense que c'est comme si à cause du
stress il engage un peu trop vite un
fight alors que alors que il doit juste
ta peau et attendre un meilleur une
meilleure fenêtre
je pense que c'est une bonne analogie ou
pas alors mets-moi le problème c'est
comme je vais trop mal mais ça sonne que
vous quelque chose de franchement
tu as eu l'impression que ouais tu sens
ouais tu sens tu sens que je suis tout
terrain
ouais ça comment tu sais ouais ça
commente les World ici ouais attention
non mais des fois tu as envie de il a
envie d'être trop entreprenant
il est stressé donc il a envie de faire
le jeu quoi en gros en gros c'est ça
mais ouais
bon là en tout cas il faut décider où
mettre ce fou ces quatre
en B3 il y a une sorte de piège mais bon
niveau il y a de bonne chance qu'il le
voit qu'il fasse pas baisser donc
[Musique]
tout d'un coup c'est moins bien je monte
le piège
joli
et donc vous B3 on avait dit ouais
madame C6 pas bête évite le piège à tag
G2 et après c'est 5 qui va toucher sous
B3
donc c'est ce qui nous embête un petit
peu sur Foot B3
mais on n'a pas de grands coups à donner
parce que sur parents E2 pourquoi pas au
moins on peut venir vers F3 contre
balancer cette diagonale mais c'est
moins offensif que d'aller vers a2b1 ou
pas de liant dans les coups de G5 à H4
un peu à la battoir là-bas puis se
ressemble à mes Blitz
un peu la bâche c'est même pas pourquoi
en fait je veux dire que quitte ce qui
est pas enfin quitte à te dédire et
faire piéger 5 H6 tu vois cash cadre en
fait j'ai reviens sur tes pas c'est pas
trop bon mais il y a rien de trop mal de
fin encore maintenant qu'on a fait H4 on
a commencé quand même à bien se comité
dans cette voix pour moi pour moi Yann
au moment où on vous parle et de et
redevenu favori pour le match
championnat du monde là pour moi il a
50% de chance de gains avec les Noirs
bah le truc
je dois dire
pour Yann c'est peut-être le scénario le
mieux pour lui alors s'il en état de
calculer mais en fait quand t'aimes pas
trop les nerfs tu aimes pas une position
où tu te vois souffrir lentement mais
c'est ce qu'il a très mal fait tout le
match avec son F5 là au moment où il a
le pion de moins qu'il a joué longtemps
quand il a fait qu'il y ait des quatre
il essaie de qualité c'est à chaque fois
des positions pas perdantes tu sens que
ça risque de mal tourner à terme mais je
sais pas peut-être même barbe sur
barbeul et que tu vas pas perdre 100% du
temps non plus et ça explose en plein
vol
[Rires]
et
et ouais donc juste pour dire que des
fois
là il a plu
à se poser de questions quoi c'est juste
c'est dans calculer jouer les coups
c'est
vrai c'est un épaule pour l'instant on
va voir si ce pépaume
[Musique]
non mais du coup il est un peu en
difficulté
je sais pas enfin
déjà 20 minutes derrière alors qu'il a
les blancs bah écoute il passe un peu à
côté de son début de partie
c'est c'est compliqué là pour pour
[Musique]
les ailes mais ça sera ça sera l'un ou
l'autre la chance furieuse audacieux oui
mais
est-ce qu'elle serait toujours aux
autres
mais là on a pas eu deux fois il a pas
eu deux fois du bol quoi
les grands joueurs ont toujours de la
chance
mais erreur plus psychologique et là
pour moi côté digne pour moi c'est
vraiment ça c'est
ça c'est une dinguerie quoi tu es là
ça a l'impression de te détendre et que
ça va bien se passer en fait c'est une
dingue il a fait une dingue mais en fait
je suis étonné enfin la préparation
psychologique des équipes des joueurs en
fait tu le vois le mec si il en est à
jour ou pas il dit se connaître
et si tu es pas interdit tu joues pas tu
attends mais rapide et tu fais tes
dingues en rapides ça peut plus se
passer ça en 20 minutes
[Musique]
et
donc je sais pas je suis très étonné de
la gestion psychologiquement on va dire
c'est pas des erreurs d'échec c'est
vraiment des erreurs de
c'est mental c'est un peu mental là ça
joue que dans la tête mais bon tout peut
se passer en fait on a déjà eu ce genre
de scénario voilà il y a trois jours de
ça
franchement la partie 12
sur le chat
c'est trop ah c'est trop
le niveau ici pourri bah c'est pas au
moins un niveau pourri c'est qu'il prend
la mauvaise décision mais c'est par
enfin ça se voit les temps de réflexion
sont pas juste
mais c'est la pression en fait il craque
sous pression là pour le moment digne
mais bon ça veut pas dire son
anniversaire le rendra pas l'appareil
dans quelques coups donc
[Musique]
il faut à deux bah j'imagine il y a
juste B6 ou B5 même j'en sais rien en
fait
pas bien
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est particulier ouais
c'est particulier ça se joue dans la
tête les échecs à un jeu qui met les
nerfs à rude épreuve
mais là les nerfs ils sont à très très
rude épreuve Fab
et ce qui est terrible c'est qu'il y a
des vases communicants sur la pression
c'est quand tu sens que l'autre est trop
en train de craquer ça te détend tu dis
ouais bon bah l'autre est déjà tellement
plus en état de jouer que si je fais de
la merde ça va passer c'est c'est
terrible
demain on a regardé mais trois dames et
peut-être tu dois décider juste de faire
cavalier le 4 et de d'essayer de
liquider
tristement
c'est peut-être qu'il y a de mieux à
faire
mais bon c'est un des aveux terrible
parce que tu viens de faire mais
la su le faire pendant le match ça
va je veux dire en fait je sais pas il a
envoyé qui j'ai 5 bon c'est une dingue
h6 il a senti que ça allait pas son H4
il s'est pas résolu à reculer alors que
tu peux faire quelques
je bouge madame j'attaque ton fou je me
prépare tour des 8 enfin je fais un truc
normal pourquoi faire le désavu
maintenant et pas avant H4 ce serait ça
ce serait une décision de haut niveau de
dire ok bon j'ai fait une dingue on fait
tous des dingues dans la vie je reviens
en arrière
et la plus qu'une heure six oh j'ai peur
qu'on le voit sombre et là on est en
train de le voir couler Ding
ah il se met le feu tout seul
il s'est mis le feu tout seul
on va remettre un petit coup de sale en
grand pour voir Yann Rodez on le voit le
rôdeur
ça pour rodéiroad
ouais
le vautour d'Astana il est là
il rôde autour de la table et Ding qui
suit
il fait nain il a fait n'importe ce
début de partie il va falloir qu'il
retombe sur ses pattes
il le sent que Ding en face est en train
de craquer
il ajoute de la pression il a bien
raison
c'est l'attitude correcte à avoir
l'attitude de Yann il faut le faire
craquer là
la muraille Fabien qui est en train de
fissure et là mais bon
il chiale pour une petite fissure murale
ça pique un peu
ça pour piquer ça pique
mais
[Musique]
je revois un peu de parade dans sa
démarche
il est bien pourtant ouais mais ouais
mais qu'en Paramé bien il a
insupportable comme ça
il sourit
il tourne un peu
mais non mais c'est dur pour Ding mais
je sais pas enfin là pour le coup il
s'est mis tout seul il s'est mis tout
seul le truc on rappelle il y a trois
coups de ça il peut ok en fait
[Musique]
là
et il y a aucun souci c'est tout va bien
enfin peut-être il y a même un peu mieux
bah c'est impressionnant symétrique et
il a un petit avant une petite avance de
développement peut-être qui pourra en
faire quelque chose ou pas on sait pas
si vite enferré dans ce truc là et là
il va vouloir faire marcher euh je sais
pas c'est ce que j'ai l'impression c'est
un peu comme un poisson alors c'est les
poissons tu mets tu vas manger sur les
sur les hameçons et là oui un hameçon il
y avait rien dessus
je vais quand même voir s'il y a pas un
truc à bouffer il a vu l'hameçon et il
sait que c'est toi
seul dedans quoi bon maintenant il faut
voir s'il peut se démêler quand même
c'est jamais ce qu'il y a de plus simple
après peut-être que le pêcheur peut
échapper le poisson enfin il peut encore
se passer des trucs mais
mais c'est ça normalement il a
il a vu passer il sait pas ouais c'est
et je le mange je le mange
ici
le problème du rock maintenant c'est que
la tour ne peut plus vraiment quitter la
colonnage bon alors là il y a un
problème avec le fou mais même admettons
qu'on rock maintenant pour protéger le
pion G2 le problème c'est quand on prend
on prend le Cavalier rouge et la bague
tu pars en H7
et
voilà donc non c'est ça le problème de
rack maintenant c'est que tu as plus ta
tour qui qui soutient la dame
la boulette
je suis pour le départage quand même je
préfère aussi mais
ça en prend pas le chemin on va dire là
après une heure une heure et demie de
jeu
ça prend le chemin de victoire de Netto
et moi c'est parti de Ding mais
tout peut se passer quoi on a déjà vu
dans d'autres jours qu'à un moment
contre dingue etc donc avoir
déjà deux résultats oh que non pour
aller dans ce match là ça reste toujours
à trois résultats mais il y a plus de
victoires de Yann parce que
bending il a il perd déjà beaucoup de
temps sont au rouge là pour pour
réfléchit beaucoup ça il y en a déjà
passé une heure pour jouer très court sa
position objectivement moins bonne et il
va être créatif pour justifier tout ça
et trouver des idées alors qu'avec les
Noirs c'est simple il va mettre il va
peut-être pion B mettre le feu sur la
grande diagonale attaqué G2 mettre les
tours au centre si les blancs restent
avec le haut au milieu ben des échecs
d'ouvrir la position donc tu peux avoir
du key qui sautent du B5 des pièces qui
s'activent ici ou là et ça se joue
simplement avec les Noirs quoi plus
facile les coups on n'est pas sur le fil
du rasoir c'est plus les blancs qui le
sont
après pour Ding même
si venait à perdre le championnat du
monde il vaudrait mieux qu'il perde
demain en départage parce que il y a 100
cas de plus les 100k
ah oui bien sûr donc j'ai pris mais il y
a 2 millions en jeu il y a 1,2 millions
pour le vainqueur 800000 pour le pour le
finaliste mais en cas de match nul et de
décision des partages sera 1,1 pour le
vainqueur et 900 millions 900000 pardon
pour pour le perdant donc oui la partie
à qui tu as perdre le match autant aller
gratter 104 plus quoi
c'est important
mais bon après champion du monde donc ça
vaut l'argent en plus que le million
d'eux c'est déjà tu prends le million
d'heures et après tu auras des beaux
sponsors des belles invitations un autre
statut tu seras payé différemment donc
c'est beaucoup d'argent
qui
plombe là non mais ok mais il sait que
c'est de la ça va pas sa position et
maintenant il faut trouver comment
bricoler tout ça quoi
c'est quoi le meilleur coup de l'ordi
c'est fou B3 je crois finalement l'un
dans l'autre mais bon
foot B ou deux je sais pas mais bon
après donc écoute je suis sur CC là pour
checker il dit que lui pour lui pour
cesser le Mirco c'est fou B3 je te donne
la ligne dame C6
bon admettons peut-être enfin impossible
là le meilleur coup bon en fait le
problème c'est qu'il dit qu'une ligne
c'est comme ça c'est fou c'est 5 ça je
suis pas convaincu que n'est pas va
jouer ça mais E4 en fait je crois
comprendre l'idée peut-être j'en sais
rien c'est que si on veut faire un coup
de pion B il y a à nouveau le cahier des
cinq
donc il y a toujours pas le B6 ou B5
qu'on appelle le fou B7 et donc fousser
5 je peux comprendre plus ou moins le
principe c'est que mon réactive le foot
par ici et on se donne la possibilité de
tomber et là-dessus il fera quel F3 tu
vois donc
petit rock donc clairement les Nords
sont mieux mais il te dit que peut-être
ça va enfin il donne que -033 mais je
viens humainement tu fais passer le coup
déjà avec les Blancs c'est trop dur
parce que tu te fais un tel des aveux et
en plus le problème c'est que tu vois la
position tu te dis mais je suis vraiment
mal qu'est-ce qu'il fait un SketchUp
c'est une arme faire qui est de 5 qui
ont attaqué le KF3 nous essayé sur H2
vous et 5 bien placé donc en fait c'est
donc oui c'est un problème enfin
c'est-à-dire si ça c'est la meilleure
ligne c'est que dans foodo
développe le four et là je comprends ce
qu'il a raté
peut-être raté c'est clair alors dit
j'avais remarqué il proposait x 6
vous prend à 8 et tu reprends à 8
cavalier F3 moi je pense que la partie
elle va plutôt continuer comme ça tu
mettais tout au centre tu fais B5 ben
c'est le problème c'est que voilà un
pion H4 complètement idiot quoi
complètement
lui-même et qui t'a fait mis le roi
simplement c'est vraiment très mal joué
la part des blancs là c'est début de
partie catastrophique pour dingleren oui
mais tu sais il a vu des choses que tu
ne peux pas imaginer c'est pour ça c'est
très fin
tu es con
tu as pas compris toi tellement bien
pour toi tu n'es pas capable de
comprendre les coups
mais ok mais on va voir des pots mais
bon B6 parait juste méga logique
développe le fou c'est la fin c'est la
seule pièce qui joue pas et c'est la
mauvaise pièce qu'on a pour l'instant en
plus elle va taper directement sur elle
vient avec tempo quoi
dans cette dernière partie
vraiment n'importe quoi il y a pas un
coup qui va avec l'autre en fait
qu'est-ce que ça a tout fait faire la
pression c'est terrible
bon après dans ce match il a déjà montré
qui
il revenait sur ses pas mais souvent on
arrive dans ce genre de situation c'est
vrai quand il a commencé à défendre il a
su souvent revenir deux trois coups sur
ses pas à bon escient avant de
complètement imposer c'est vraiment ce
qu'il sait ce qui s'est passé on va voir
si aujourd'hui il implose aussi réussi à
poser les barbelés et à défendre et
deuxième truc aussi une époque se voyant
si proche du but comment il va réagir et
s'il y a se sentir obligé de gagner tu
vois enfin fait un peu comme Ding
l'autre jour c'est-à-dire vouloir un
gain forcé parce qu'en fait la pression
avec le plan H4 il le sait que c'est
cool pour lui mais est-ce que ça va lui
suffire ou alors il va chercher un gain
forcé de te faire une sorte de tout re
cinq de digne de l'autre jour et de
et de relancer tout ça
on sait pas quoi
là je pense que cette fois il va pas il
va pas être chaud que Yann mais après on
sait rien je suis un peu stressé pour
eux comme toujours
en départage évidemment voilà
je vais voir le cirque Pinder
le retour de Pinder
[Musique]
ou quoi mais
j'ai quand même simplifié la position en
tout cas peut-être pas bête qu'est-ce
que donc si on fait pas fou mais ça
c'est ce qu'on fait
entre ça c'est un très bon coup je sais
pas qui l'a proposé mais c'est très
intéressant comme coup
[Musique]
des fous des six faux Branger 3 des
cavaliers
là il va y avoir j'ai trois mais on va
pas le jouer si je réussis à me placer
comme ça je pense qu'après là je
consolide bien quand même
en fait si j'arrive à cette position
avec les blanches je pense que je me
sentirai de bonne chance de tenir
mais voilà ça c'est jamais super
agréable ce grand diagonale est quand
même faible tu peux toujours avoir des
plans de assez Histor à 7 d'Ama 8
etc mais en tout cas il y a pas
catastrophe énorme et
c'est peut-être tenable mais voilà il va
falloir trouver des bons coups chez
digne oui non il va falloir mettre deux
trois barbe
de repos il analyse sur les chiant 2D
il se passe voilà
qu'on préférerait pour le spectacle
l'avoir dans la reine mais alors fais
voir cette arène justement toi qui me
parle d'arène Fab la reine elle est là
avec les deux rois
un des deux princes même assis à la
table 1 2 sera couronné roi ce soir ou
demain Fabien
exactement
on dit pas ouf la moquette moi j'aime
beaucoup cette moquette que j'appellerai
ou zébré même ouais est-ce que c'est du
jaune ou du blanc enfin tu vois ce que
je veux dire le zèbre il est bien blanc
et noir quoi
avec cette petite estrade en fait
sur mesure avec une moquette un genre de
duvet je dirais même noir
oiseau il serait malade il déteste la
moquette ah bah là si tu as des
allergies aux acariens ou quoi tu vas
pas être bien je pense qu'il sortirait
pas du rond noir
son duvet ici pour dormir et ne jamais
marcher sur le truc
zébré slash
tigré et compagnie quoi
en tout cas c'est c'est une magnifique
arène qui nous est proposée pour cette
finale de championnats du monde
surtout cette magnifique estrade qui met
en valeur les deux joueurs
avec tous les sponsors autour qu'on voit
pas très bien ici mais qu'on aimerait
voir
on sait quelles sont les sponsors
en tout cas de
de ce match
qui nous offre tant de rebondissements
et tant de surprises dans un écrin on
peut le dire je pense que le mot le mot
est lâché Fabien l'écran d'Astana
une salle et un lieu mythique Kazakhstan
qui restera dans les annales du jeu
Fabien
la perle d'Astana
vous montrez
confortablement sur ce siège tu le sais
si bien
un petit une petite gorgée de café pour
la route et on va jouer le coup ici côté
Yann il prend une pièce dans sa main
pour la toucher
il va maintenant réfléchir DIN qui va
probablement quitter maintenant ça
chaise pour bien être sûr qu'il ne soit
pas assis tous les deux en même temps
Ding qui consomme un petit peu d'eau
Fabien qui s'hydrate il en aura besoin
c'est une partie qui peut qui peut durer
et tour D8 ok alors il se passe quoi sur
désolé j'étais encore dans ma danse 7
dans ma chute mais non mais j'étais
encore dans le fou B3 désolé j'avais un
résidu de dames défendues
alors peut-être tour c'est un maintenant
le coup qui nous a été proposé dans le
dans le chat
et je veux dire autour des 8 a priori
pas le coup optimal pour mes pots un
coup qui ne développe pas ce fou qui qui
appelait alors
on appellerait du dame B8 maintenant
pour sortir de ce vis-à-vis désagréable
et peut-être maintenant cavalier Geo 4
ont réussi quand même à gagner un de
tempo avec les Blancs non mais là il va
te faire G4 G5 après il est très chaud
pour t'envoyer
bon voilà comme prévu on n'est pas au
bout de nos surprises
ton D8
et il a joué Torcé un assez vite allez
ça relance les idées de cahier des 5 à
ce tour des 8 fait plaisir quand même
pour les supporters de Digne hein ça
relance complètement
et bravo qualitatif aujourd'hui en cette
journée de finale on ce samedi est-ce
que il peut vouloir
poutrement entre guillemets cavalier et
fuite n'est pas
avec l'idée sur car elle est des 5
Fabien attention je te laisse le dire
bah de faire qui est prendre des cinq
comme ça il y a plus d'un H7
champion du monde non
et dame prend ses 7 qui prend tout
reprendre
et après on prend G5
du coup je pense que kfit ça peut être
l'idée de dépôt qui explique le tour des
8 complètement il blinde il blinde le H7
il a peut-être qu'il y aura lieu 4 et
c'est ça change tout parce que
maintenant le cavalier qui jaillissait
rapidement on va faire un échange qui
allait prendre à me prendre vous parler
de cette case G4 affaiblie côté blanc
qui ne l'est plus maintenant enfin qu'il
l'étouffe est toujours faible mais
cavalier a perdu deux temps et donc les
blancs réussissent à s'organiser en plus
les Blancs ont pris la priorité sur la
diagonale
et donc finalement l'un dans l'autre ça
va pas si mal pour pour Ding
mais oui il va faire quel effet
je capte pas trop s'il y a aucune vente
il a l'air dangereuse en fait après V6
mais bon c'est comme ça as-tu le niveau
voilà pour
j'ai envie même dire pour parler d'échec
qui êtes-vous pour parler monsieur que
faites-vous là quoi
allez-vous la légitimité finalement
de parler dans ma chambre
tu es d'où
mais
ouais
assez vite donc par Ding bien joué bien
joué et qui a rejoué vite donc il remet
un petit coup au moral
mais bon et on voit que la lumière a
quitté l'oeil de Yann
lumière
qui lui allait pourtant si bien
alors on demande pourquoi H6 Franki G5
ne marche pas alors après pion prend le
cavalier F6 serait attaqué tu aurais
très envie de faire un décalage avec
cavalier 5 pour venir taper sur le kic3
et donc là les blancs allez allez il
faut trouver le coup
pas trop le choix
tu aurais parti en F8 seul coup et là
elle attaque un peu bloqué comment
ramener du matériel pour terminer le
alors ce qui tombe bien c'est que la
dame va être autosuffisante elle va
aller en huit
et voilà donc trop dangereux de
prendre en G5 les amis vous ouvrez la
colonnage il y a cette tour dessus il y
a la dame qui va venir
en renfort donc ouais ne réveillez pas
une tour endormi en H1
c'est le conseil du coach c'est le
conseil du coach
un conseil qui peut valoir dans d'autres
ouvertures aussi par exemple
dans le système de Londres quand il y a
le vis-à-vis que les deux fous en G3 D6
sans rien de faïence tu veux pas prendre
en G3
on peut retourner sur le plan le plan
qui nous plaît le plan caméra qui fait
toute la difficile ces deux chaises
laissées vacantes vacantes un peu
orientées trois quarts trois quarts
favorables est-ce que ça pourrait
vouloir dire qu'il y a du vent qui qui
vient qui tape qui tape trois quarts
on voit le centre est vide ça souffle
fort ça souffle fort le carré magique
n'est pas occupé et donc
[Musique]
il a son blouson sur lui pour couper le
vent contrairement à Digne attention
hein si l'équipe jumbovisma se met à
rouler Fabien
avec les huae
c'est mon rôle à contretemps bah oui ils
ont que trois échappés seuls devant il
en roule dessus quoi alors que Fabien
Thibault Pinot est lâché
n'ont pas réussi à mentir le leader de
FDJ dans le peloton il perdrait 4
minutes 30 déjà sur cette sur cette
étape
devant le contrôle
c'est peut-être l'équipe à Stana qui
roule pour le coup
c'est un vin au courant qui qui s'en
occupe
pas du tout ouais
ça de
reposer
sur le dos quoi
le soigneur de Yann on arrive à son
chevet quoi je change les choses changer
les chaussures
et ça repart
poussé par son directeur sportif qui
alors que qui tombe sous le poids de
Yann
deux hommes sont à terre
je vais pouvoir faire venir le second
danseur frise pour épauler tout le monde
ça va être bien cramique qui arrive le
tien péniblement sur ses épaules
une souris pour jouer depuis la salle de
repos quoi
ta voiture balai qui arrive qu'il est
balaye
on attend hein
quoi qu'il en soit made in il peut nous
emmener du quattro à tout moment
la chute était pas trop grave
c'est vrai que Yann il a plus le
physique d'un rouleur
peut-être il faut sprinter au cinéma ou
tu pues
[Musique]
je pense que ça pourrait très beau
poisson pilote
[Musique]
les pourcentages sont là
d'une petite pause Fab bon on peut de
toute façon
on se retrouve dans une petite dizaine
de minutes à tout de suite les amis
toutes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon alors Fab on a on a eu parce qu'on
avait prévu un tour c'est un cavalier à
fuite qui a value 4 cavaliers prend donc
la partie qui se dirige maintenant
plutôt vers un match nul
alors oui bon déjà ça va dépendre de
Ding et ce que il tolère l'échange des
dames après cavalier prend E4 dame prend
C2 tours C2 en disant bon peut-être je
rentre en C7 bon après tu la chasseras
facilement quand même genre ça te fait
ni chaud ni froid aux Noirs
où il se dit bon écoute je fais de me
prendre et aller
autour des 1
et puis moi je sais pas
mais je le vois plus partir
son avantage avec ses couilles
défensif ouais en fait il a voulu ne
rien risquer du tout s'il y a les
blindes avec le Cavalin et fuite il va
rien m'arriver et donc bon ça veut juste
dire que c'est des décisions
psychologiques c'est que Yann il pense
que jouer quatre parties de départage il
est favoris et qui préfère jouer quatre
parties de départage que de tout risquer
sur cette partie là
bon c'est un choix
la suite de dire s'il était bon ou pas
parce que objectivement si on parle que
d'échec pur c'est pas le meilleur coup
donc voilà mais c'est fini par gagner le
match on dirait rien c'est comme la
dernière ronde de Carlson contre carwana
quand il est mieux et qu'il fait et qui
propose nul
bon le lendemain il y a une 3 € les
départages donc personne s'en souvient
et si car on a gagné c'est parti là on
en a reparlé longtemps de cette partie
où il fait nuit alors qu'il est beaucoup
mieux quoi mais
donc voilà c'est le résultat qu'il y a
si le raison ou pas
d'un point de vue échiquier un pur c'est
pas les meilleurs coups mais on peut
comprendre le raisonnement le
cheminement le cheminement intellectuel
donc voilà
il semble que les joueurs pensent que
c'est Yann puisque Ding prend des
risques oui pour éviter les départages
et que Yann ne prend pas de risque pour
s'assurer les départages mais après en
réalité c'est quelque chose qui va se
jouer sur les nerfs donc
[Musique]
c'est difficile à dire en réalité oui
bon mais en fait ce que je veux dire
c'est que même intrinsèquement moi je
suis même pas persuadé que Yann soit si
au dessus mais après oui donc c'est là
ça va être de la gestion des nerfs déjà
on voit dans les parties là où oui ça
envoie du kg 5 H4 il y a trois jours
c'était pas fou donc il peut faire des
craquages donc pareil toujours trop dur
de se risquer à faire des pronos
donc c'est pas en fait non
mais voilà mon épouse pense confiance en
tout cas il est confiant c'est comme
pour les penaltys c'est la loterie c'est
la chance
plus que penalty car plus qu'a fait
mieux préparer globalement et
l'important ce facteur est décuplé en
rapide ce dont parler nous un petit peu
hier c'est un peu comme le service au
tennis
il peut s'appuyer sur une bonne
contrairement à ping
tu vas te servir la cuillère
[Musique]
non mais je sais pas je sens bien
prendre de la dame
le seul avantage de la colonne c'est pas
l'air suffisant les normes il va se
développer à contester et voilà
mais vu comme il joue pourquoi pas dame
prend qui
de toute façon ça va depuis un H4 est
moins grave que dans les ventes qu'on
voyait comme tu signales à la 4G4 elle
est plus loin d'être accessible d'un E4
rempli son rôle au centre elle est pas
mal je trouve
la plus intéressante quand même
ouais
en plus tu continues à laisser vis-à-vis
de te refais un amcesseur donc faut
résoudre ça en E4 t'empêche pour
l'instant B6
donc je vais dire c'est pas juste tiens
je garde les dames et je suis
inconscient quoi c'est tu fais vraiment
des choses tu défends H4 tu peux ok si
tu as envie tu peux peut-être te diriger
vers la colonne j'ai un jour
et bien ce dame au centre en fait
je me demande de plus en plus plus on en
parle plus le nom de si finalement c'est
pas les blancs qui sont de nouveau
vraiment mieux
je sais pas s'ils sont mieux mais ouais
je pense qu'ils sont plus moins bien je
vois pas pourquoi
[Musique]
bon étonnant va étonnant je sais pas si
c'est si étonnant que ça mais
ouais je m'attendais tellement à me
prendre mais comme d'hab tu vois c'est
marrant
tu comprends rien en fait autoproclamé
spécialiste des échecs autoproclamer
grand maître tu as aucun coup en fait
j'ai compris qu'il voulait aller vite
quoi voilà j'ai compris deux trucs dans
la position
mais
[Musique]
est-ce que tu as le droit de te faire un
petit clin d'oeil genre autant de clins
de faire un clin d'œil et genre si tu
fais admettons genre je fais
comment faire ça genre je fais un clin
d'oeil et je fais pousser trois tu fais
fouille tu fais foudre
il intervient rien du tout mais moi
j'aurais pas confiance enfin c'est trop
à vous faire gagner
les bons coups mais j'ai peur que tu
trahisses quoi
je te crois pas en fait je vois que tu
veux faire nul ok mais vas-y on fait les
coups normaux on fait nul mais je veux
pas que
je joue en fait je déteste ça en fait
en l'air donc les blancs tu peux pas non
plus y aller les yeux fermés
bizarre ce choix je trouve de cavaliers
prend mais c'est pas un mauvais choix
mais non mais il veut tourner enfin s'il
va pas sur ton C7 maintenant je
c'est incompréhensible qu'il est fait
qu'il prend et pas d’âme prend je prends
le coup c'est la seule idée de mettre le
cavalier en quatre c'est d'entrer
B8 tu fais H5 disons les torcer 8 bon
bah oui oui mais je te dis pas que tu es
mieux mais genre c'est au moins tu as
fait ça pour ça
t'explique rien tu veux faire mieux mais
j'ai si tu le fais pas en fait les Noirs
vont sur la position en direct je
reviens
non juste de faire tout rasser vite
direct tu vas devoir échanger ou je sais
pas quoi auto clouer et tu peux te
retrouver plutôt moins bien alors bon
marginalement mais il a pas l'air quand
même très William sera dingue ça fait
peur pour demain
moi je pense que cette partie elle est
pas encore terminée parce que c'est
c'est une tremblante mais monumentale ne
partez pas les amis ne pensez pas que la
nul est signée même si la position
crinule nul nul nul nul c'est la
position qui crie c'est pas moi
tout peut encore arriver à mon avis
parce que ça a pas l'air d'être très
solide sur les appuis
voilà il y a eu le LED sur un deuxième
service
que ça
on se retrouve demain à 11h pour 4
parties en 25 + 10 donc rien que ça déjà
ça va durer à mon avis
six heures c'est bon
des rapides plus rapides et des Blitz
c'est je pense que c'est une partie du
Runner et une demi-heure enfin là je
pense
c'est les quatre parties d'un coup ouais
c'est les quatre parties le même jour là
demain en fait c'est quoi qui se passe
on aura un champion du monde le feu
d'artifice
le nectar de ce champion du monde quoi
la perle de la perle quoi la crème de la
crème of the cream the cream
demain c'est quoi qui se passe ça va
enchaîner
l'étape des Champs-Élysées exactement
les deux jours auront mis leurs habits
de lumière
mais c'est pour ça que on n'est pas
mécontent du nul en réalité donc on
préfère avoir une huile pour vivre des
départages demain j'en ai deux folie le
dimanche et surtout quitte avoir une
partie comme ça là si ça perd de toute
façon ça va perdre sur des fautes mais
alors monumentales on préférait quand
même voir du quatre parties de rapide
ça arrive souvent ce que certainement
que le match se termine en départage
mais écoute sur les trois derniers il y
a eu deux fois des départages donc ça
pourrait faire trop sur quatre s'il
annule là et pour l'instant du coup
c'est devenu favori le scénario favori
mais depuis que le départage existe donc
c'est après 2004
ouais et ben on a eu on a eu quoi on a
eu un angle
on a eu
quatre ok j'avais pas
scène
carriatine on est Carl Seine Caravana on
a eu un autre attends mais fou B4 ça
peut
[Musique]
est-ce que ça peut être ce que tu fais
comme une concession tu doutes des pions
ouais mais bon tu te dis que peut-être
tu vas l'embêter 5 prendre de l'espace
moi je sais pas ce qui se dit enfin non
mais il veut pas d'une nul sans histoire
en tout cas
je fais même à 5 juste parce que
tu te mets pas un peu trop sur blanc
je sais pas
s'il y a de beau c'est que si
non mais il va prendre il va prendre il
y aura à prendre
ici je fais prise
tu auras C8 tu vois on continue un peu à
jouer pleutre
côté noir
je pense que Ding craignait de toute
façon être juste moins bien pour ça que
je comprends pas trop qui est joué
cavalier prend le 4 et ça me prend le 4
ouais je sais pas c'est bizarre
tu peux commencer par fousser 6 fois F3
tu es tranquille OK et
[Musique]
tu es là
ouais tu passes un peu
la bonne idée mais la mauvaise
réalisation
comme ça je veux dire mais là je pense
tu prends les rois des deux oui mais tu
vois ça se trouve une épaule il veut
juste sa petite nul il cherche pas à
comprendre quoi
il a ça
pas mal pas mal
il se met le feu tout seul quoi
il fait vraiment une mauvaise partie
enfin le droit quand même tu es pas
obligé d'aller que au départage tu peux
être champion dès aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'on a le droit de dire là que que Ding
passe vraiment à côté de cette partie
a-t-on le droit je sais pas est-ce que
vous en pensez
qui décide
qui fixe les règles qui a le droit ou
pas le droit tu vois déjà c'est pas moi
Mathieu qui dit non on n'a pas le droit
bah voilà
fin du débat il passe pas à côté de ça
partie
on peut n'est pas on peut pas
mais bon
on est pas bien pour c'est vite bêtement
il y a pas de problème en tout cas mais
tu peux vouloir plus
ça veut dire quoi cette attitude de
dépôt
un peu mais je crois qu'il est étonné je
crois qu'il est étonné
je crois qu'il est étonné
tu te fais échanger peut-être non
[Musique]
pour pas te laisser rentrer trop
c'est 6 F3 je sais pas moi
ok on se prend une tactique de l'ordi
OK
[Musique]
il joue vite
en tout cas mais bon là
[Musique]
c'est quoi bouffe
pour C5 tu peux redescendre s'appelle un
punto ça je crois qu'il vient de filer
un pion de coup en fait
il a peut-être pas
B français et que même simpe il a
l'option
et peut-être qu'il a pas intégré le
tchichak via C6 avec B5 qui change qui
est quand même plus précis quoi du coup
et qui est pas très dure malheureusement
bah qui est pas très dur dans le sens où
tu l'as pas direct tu regardes faut des
cinq machins mais quand elle est là tu
dis bon bah j'ai aussi la casse ici je
peux peut-être améliorer
et voilà
donc
là pas il fera qu'il est 7 pour échanger
ou je sais pas quoi j'imagine attention
il y a 5 minutes de ça j'ai même si
c'est
pas foncer dans une île parce qu'il y a
quand même beaucoup de fautes qui sont
proches d'être là qui sont qui sont là
pour être faites et là elles sont faites
elles sont faites alors nous évidemment
on a l'aide de la turbinette mais là
encore c'est pas des lignes non ça
franchement c'est
plus que trouvable
mais je dois dire que au fait quand il a
fait fou B4 c'était pour aller là-dedans
[Musique]
qu'on imagine enfin c'est juste un pion
E4 il faut enfermer plus de 15 mais il y
a B6 contre-attaque donc on s'est
bouffer le fond qui allait
au 4 c'est encore mieux donc obligé de
prendre nous on prend ces cinq et là les
blancs choisissent ils prennent aussi
sur quoi le cavalier reprend
en C5 les marques prennent en dessin car
depuis ou de la tour après ça c'est au
choix ça dépend si on veut moi j'aurais
pris de la Tour a priori mais bon et
cette finale oui un peu plus bon alors
après peut-être tu auras des deux tours
tu vas peut-être la tenir quand même
avec les Blancs oui mais d'accord mais
enfin si on joue plus pour tenir on part
pas là-dedans
parce que le roi arrive vite quand même
non non tu as des chances bien sûr
[Musique]
faut pas aller là-dedans quand même quoi
non non mais je pense tu la tiens quand
même mais là tu vas enfin c'est sûr que
c'est pas il rentre pas de gaieté de
cœur
mais il a peut-être un peu de bol
le roi est quand même est quand même
très actif et mais bon tu as des pions
doublés tu as l'équivalent de pions de
moins de côté ils sont durs à pousser
bon dure à dire
très difficile à dire mais c'est encore
une petite imprécision dans cette partie
mais c'est pas sûr qu'il y a le voir
c'est pas sûr qu'il a envie de le voir
peut-être qu'il se dit bon ok il est 7
j'échange tout on en parle plus
mais bon en fait quand même tu as le
droit de regarder frangins enfin si un
pion en prise tu te dis qu'est-ce qui se
passe quand je le prends il me fait
tangent il m'attaque j'ai deux cases de
dispo c'est des 5 ou 6
un peu con parce que déjà tu laisses
baisser en l'air mais bon tu l'auras tu
bon ok tu le vois bon
il prend du pion et du coup je vais
intro ah non mais c'est plus que trois
quasiment le voir rempli franchement
ouais ça c'est rapide
pas à 100% mais il y a du Range et après
bah tu évaluer la position bah tu sais
pas si tu gagnes ou pas mais tu vois que
tu es mieux que tu risques rien donc il
y a pas de raison de parler là-dedans et
de faire cailler des sacs
lorsque Grisha avait joué un match
contre lui en Chine il m'a dit il
tremble pas possible pendant les parties
dingues
il est très très nerveux et là j'ai
l'impression que c'est ces nerfs qui lui
joue des tours il tient pas quoi
mais là il va le faire ça c'est sûr
en tout cas
en plus là il rentre dans une position
il risque rien genre c'est pas comme
tout à l'heure
mais donc on pourrait ne pas avoir de
départage c'est de nouveau le scénario
quand même principal n'est point un peu
favoris la finale elle est pas gagnée
celle qu'on regarde quand même mais bon
en tout cas oui il peut la jouer sans
trembler quoi regarde il est surpris il
l'a vu Yann
un projet de F3 attention la tour-achat
est attaqué
de Fischer spaski alors c'était pas le
pion juste de ce pion H2 donc c'est
parfois une idée mais là attention la
tour est attaquée dans le coin donc tu
dois la bouger
c'est quoi on vient de te montrer en
fait toute la ligne enfin sinon son idée
ce serait de mettre la pression mais en
fait le Kevin était attaqué donc toute
façon tu dois soit le défendre sur le
bouger donc mon frère mais tu bouges
voilà tu évites la menace et parce que
tu as envie c'est de faire peut-être des
seins et de faire bouger toutes ces six
aller prendre B7 bon voilà enfin il y a
pas une grande idée mais c'est juste
qu'il parle à menace et il se dit voilà
le problème en plus c'est fou prends
c'est demain
5 4
et B6 c'est important
mais bon visible parce que en fait oui
enfin tu vas pas jouer en perdant un fou
au milieu donc tu fais le seul coup qui
te donne de l'air à la fois la case B7
mais surtout que c'est le cahier-bouche
tu perds4 donc toute façon pas le choix
et ça rentre en force dans dans ça alors
là puis on prend ça c'est le choix
ouais c'est facile
[Musique]
intuitivement je ferai ah mais quoique
et tu l'attaques et je sais pas donc oui
en fait mais là bah le truc c'est que de
toute façon tu vas pour ça et au moment
où tu prends des 5 tu réfléchis
là tu rends réfléchis
est-ce que ça ça gagne ou pas j'en sais
rien
donc
il faut décaler la tour pour pas se
faire clouer
ce que tu vas te prendre pour toi donc
ils ont eu Max qui pouvait faire pour
monter le blocus mais maintenant les
noirs
le roi il rentre pas c'est ce que je
voulais regarder en fait et tu rentres
pas par là non plus on peut améliorer le
roi on peut créer un pion basé le roi
[Musique]
ouais ça a pas l'air trop dur quoi
et il dit quoi c'est c'est quoi comment
ça me paraît juste gagnant s'il rentre
là-dedans alors après faut peut-être des
vies avec les Blancs quelque part mais
[Musique]
il met que moi dans 65 ok mais c'est
quoi la ligne c'est fou pour ranger deux
d'accord pour il a la position jusqu'à
Thor français 5 eux prend des mini mais
bon peut-être c'est le moins pour rien
déjà le premier
il faut prendre des batteur prend moi je
sais pas là tu vois j'ai pas
parce que la tour prend bah il a pris
j'ai deux
on ne comprenant pas trop ce qui se
passe
ah c'est dommage ça nous enlèverait les
départages avec une partie
un peu triste pour une dernière partie
de championnat du monde
alors E4 est-ce que
x 2
B3 B6 tu reprends A2 puis on prend C5
puis on prend ça ça va pour les blancs
enfin comparativement
c'est E4 ou C6
B5 x 8
qui est
mais pourquoi rentrer dans
[Musique]
ça reste dangereux pour des 4
en fait mes Ding il a vraiment fait
le foubecca puis on prend en fait c'est
pas tu as pas une variante qui refuse tu
en as deux ou trois
oui
je crois
ouais
non mais ça peut quand même gagner pour
Yann il reste favoris il dit quoi c'est
c'est
6b
6 ah c'est fort
oh c'est dur
c'est un truc que je t'ai montré que
j'ai fait un stupide
donc du coup je peux comprendre non mais
du coup je comprends le choix Diane
parce que là le coup le plus humain
c'est la F3
et tu vas faire tomber 8 et tu vas
gagner B5
ouais non le choix de Yann est
compréhensible en fait c'est le truc de
Ding de faire de rentrer là-dedans c'est
incroyable mais le choix de Yann si
c'est pour fousser 6 B5 fois 8 qui est
B7 tour des 4 c'est complètement
compréhensible je dirais pas que c'est
une erreur
non mais c'est fou le choix là de fou B4
pendant un fou incroyable
je sais pas pourquoi tu préfères jouer
ça que l'autre
il se passe rien
plus tôt ouais c'est
c'est jouer ouais ce sont les coups donc
les Verts font 8
après il va le voir enfin un moment il
peut avoir un coup
oui non mais je veux bien mais bon dans
tous les cas
tu avais tellement de séparationnel
la pression
c'est comme ça
dur de jouer des bonnes parties
sous une telle pression
maintenant est-ce que Yann va réussir à
garder sa composure comme disent les
Anglais
et à mettre la pression
la question est entière ah bah oui
mais Maxime je pense la journée de repos
a été maléfique pour Ding tu veux dire
que c'est un Darking qu'on a non mais il
a dû faire 1000 fois la partie dans sa
tête mal dormir pensez à ça tout le
temps
s'auto ouais ouais se bouffer par le
stress quoi
ah là c'est le stress de toute façon
c'est que le stress qui peut expliquer
ses coups de la part d'un joueur d'un
tel niveau quedding c'est très impulsif
ok
c'est que des ouais c'est que faire la
décision tout de suite tactiquement
vraiment
par chance il se trouve que c'est pas
encore grave
pas encore trop grave
et tu peux la voir du coup parce que tu
es dans le fait accompli que tu es là tu
as des pu attaquer partout et que tu dis
tiens c'est un double chance tu peux
aussi gagner ça le mettre en PLS et puis
que c'est impulsif c'est un peu ce que
tu fais depuis ton sein en fait tu sais
pas à quel point ça va ou pas mais tu le
fais tu le fais quoi
c'est demain qu'il faut jouer comme ça
rapide mais je suis pas sûr qu'on rapide
ça passe mieux
peut-être qu'il y a une joue comme ça il
sera plus détendu et il va peut-être
même trouver les fous des cinq ou c'est
fou c'est 6 ou des cinq ou quoi
c'est quand que les joueurs soient si
imprécis en fin de match de Coupe du
Monde honnêtement autant
ah si ça arrivait quand même
non
même le cramique Lego oui
c'est vrai que les deux c'est plus rare
et surtout c'était que sur une partie à
la fin c'était moins sur les quatre cinq
dernières
je sais pas
non mais il y a beaucoup de pression
dans ce match on ressent chaque partie
ça aille aussi que les autres matchs
d'habitude la plupart du temps mise à
part les carpov cortenoi mise à part car
je t'as toujours un champion
donc le champion c'est il a déjà
l'expérience d'avoir gagné donc il va
pas craquer sous la pression donc si
c'est l'autre qui fait n'importe quoi je
parle de cramique l'écho là par exemple
un exemple assez récent bah tu as
cramique et champion en titre tu as
l’écho qui a besoin de faire du la
dernière pour prendre le titre Les ko il
craque mais cramiques il est déjà
champion du monde donc il va pas
il conserve du son titre il a déjà
l'expérience de cette pression donc là
on a un cas de figure un peu particulier
avec aucun des deux joueurs qui n'a
jamais gagné de match championnat du
monde donc en fait il craque tous les
deux quoi un peu il peut prendre ça
comme
un rêve au bout des doigts quoi un rêve
de ta vie
et que tu as envie d'être à la hauteur
de la tâche et de l'événement et c'est
dur et
sûrement fou et 8 mais tu as raison de
de le souligner c'est à dire qu'il
aurait pu prendre son temps de réflexion
juste avant
c'est-à-dire qu'il a fait fou des seins
que 4 ou 6 B5 il s'est enferré là-dedans
et maintenant il réfléchit
j'habite ou B6 maintenant c'est quand
même
il y a fouder
il croit que c'est pas si mal je sais
pas
c'est bizarre mais ok il peut
c'est difficile cette dernière partie
elle est découdre et souvent quand c'est
des cousu quand ça commence à être trop
décousu ça devient difficile de trouver
des bons coups
pour les deux je veux dire après
tu es surpris à chaque coup
[Musique]
Yann qui réfléchit maintenant et parfois
ça arrive que tu te rendes compte à
contrecoup que tu as raté genre là
peut-être qu'il se dit
genre il faut en B5 j'aurais B6 si on
prend puis on prend ça irait
non mais ça peut vraiment ouais c'est
dommage de se rendre compte
en fait mais bon il peut se rendre
compte qu'il a raté quelque chose ouais
parce que c'est une intervention de
course
j'ai pas de chance machin je sais pas
[Musique]
un peu là non
il peut se rendre compte qu'il a raté là
c'est comme ça tant pis
il vaut mieux ne pas s'en rendre compte
que tu peux t'en rendre compte
mais bon fallait
il va jouer B6 à B6
ça c'est absolument impossible
c'est sympa avec les erreurs et ben je
suis complètement d'accord avec toi ça
rend le jeu plus humain et plus
intéressant on se résumé
en plus on peut comprendre les erreurs
et pourquoi et
après il y a des erreurs parfois
évitables mais après c'est un jeu très
compliqué les échecs et
quasi personne toute ma mère parfaite
alors que des positions sont assez
simples ou que les joueurs connaissent
la prépa et les plans et qui savent tout
ce qu'ils ont à faire
c'est plus tellement que tu joues tu
restitues quoi mais
quand tu es lâché par toi-même ça je
complexe et voilà logique après des fois
oui des erreurs plus compliquées que
d'autres quoi on est bien sûr que c'est
naturel
oui c'est vrai que
il y a plus d'erreurs dans ces matchs
champions du monde que dans des rapides
sur Internet
naturel
terrible pour Yann réfléchis au mauvais
moment
je crois qu'il veut vraiment faire du
bien attitude qui
veut un truc ça s'arrête de partir là
senti aussi et du coup c'est pour ça
qu'il abuse qui c'est
on sait pas ce qui se passe dans leur
tête là c'est trop trop difficile à dire
le mauvais moment on peut pas savoir
sans ordi non mais bon arrêtez des fois
on peut pas ça ressentir c'est bon les
joueurs d'échec quand même
tu comprends bien que
là c'est une variante forcée tu as des
choix tu comprends que tu t'enlèves des
choix enfin faut arrêter de dire sans
ordi enfin arrêtez de nous prendre pour
des bains quoi ou de les prendre pour
des bolins d'ailleurs un joueur du
niveau de Yann a largement le niveau
pour pour trouver fousser 6 en premier
pour mettre le pied en B5 ou des 5 E4 et
quand tu fasses B6 sur pion français 5
et plus on peut penser 5 enfin il en est
capable en fait arrêter de prendre les
joueurs d'échec pour des abrutis quand
même ces trois coups de trois coups et
une petite finesse mais c'est pas c'est
pas facile c'est juste que si il a ses
nerf et que et qui réussit à bien
réfléchir à sentir le moment bah il
réfléchit au début de la variante forcée
pas au milieu ça c'est quand même ce
qu'on apprend c'est le livre de Kota
quoi
tu apprends ça à 10 ans il en est
évidemment capable et après avec la
pression etc ben il veut bien faire et
on t'explique d'où vient l'erreur mais
dire que oui vraiment très difficile
savoir comment réfléchir oui bon enfin
allez tu penses qu'on réfléchit au
hasard qu'on est vraiment des abrutis
enfin je sais pas vous ne prenez
pourquoi en fait
vous prenez vraiment pour des cons
il peut le faire après c'est difficile
et il a pas réussi à le faire et il a
pas réussi à accomplir la tâche et c'est
normal et ça arrive et ça s'explique et
tout le monde comprend tout
mais le truc c'est qu'il est même
capable de s'en être rendu compte
maintenant après coup après coup et
c'est terrible
fou 8
qui prend B7 et le tour G3
j'imagine qui
est étonnant mais
en fait ça te donne comme tous les pions
4 H 4 mais bon si tu fais tour à trois
et que tu abaisses et que ton pion passé
à toi il a une case de dame et que les
autres sont tous sur le système rangés
tu as quand même un peu d'avance quoi
dans la course
que nepo lui aussi il a pas le finesse
mais c'est pas enfin vous comprenez pas
ce qu'on vous dit en fait c'est terrible
enfin évidemment qu'on regarde avec
l'ordinateur ou quoi on essaie de te
commenter la partie et de te dire les
coups qu'il aurait pu trouver ce qu'il a
pu rater t'expliquer pourquoi il a raté
son cheminement de pensée comment ça se
passe enfin si tu veux on va rien de
commenter on va dire à jouer B5 on va
attendre qu'il joue son cou il va mettre
son fond 8 on va dire bah là je fous 8
non mais si t'expliquer le cheminement
de pensée de ce qu'il a raté de ce qui
est dommage ce qui peut imaginer
maintenant de pourquoi il fait cette
tête parce que ah ben tiens finalement à
contrecoup tu peux te rendre compte là
parce que c'est une interversion macula
trompé mais enfin je vois pas
enfin ce qu'on te dit de mal en fait
c'est quand même tu vois un joueur de
tennis il met la balle faute son rythme
cardiaque était peut-être trop haut
machin bah du coup c'est plus dur de
servir ou quoi mais
[Musique]
ouais donc on était là tout reprend le 4
non là tu aimes en B5 au passage
parce que du coup il est ici tu reprends
H4 et donc alors qu'est-ce qui se passe
c'est toi
ça m'aurait terrifié parce que tu
ramènes une pièce en jeu pas terrifié
intermédiaire bon mais disons cette
variante là est-ce que ça te terrifie
oui ben
encore que je te mets une tour devant
ton pion
et j'ai tout F4 et je te pousse les
pions à la tronche quand même
parce que ça terrifie
non mais en fait tu
as un truc ok tu vas gagner ou au pire
nul tu vois que tu déconnes tu peux
perdre
et 4h ça sera pas joué 5 pour faire bah
j'imagine pour sur tout reprendre le 4
mais il fait qu'il est ici maintenant
étape et tu reprends H4 tu prends pas
plutôt et tour des quatre ok on bouge
ici et toi
ouais bon après tu peux toujours tu dis
je veux F3 je vais prendre un 7
j'y crois pas à cette ligne
Mathieu qui tord des 4 tours
peut-être
c'est pas possible ça
dans ces cas c'est possible aussi
non non c'est pas simple pour ne pas en
fait
devient chiant
en fait il va très vite
et surtout peut-être que tu as des
variantes ou tu peux monter le roi et
faire tourner
et si tu veux juste effacer la partie tu
peux parce que tu peux encore en fait
juste effacer
mais bon
c'est la même chose c'est de nouveau
cette tour qui se ramène là-bas
et en plus ça ta tour qui est là donc tu
vas pouvoir décaler ta tour auquel là tu
souffles
il y a un deuxième
temps
ça va tomber vite ouais
c'est ça la
tour de cette tour
de l'ordi j'en sais rien mais que sur ce
qu'on voit ça va être ça
de l'autre côté
mais ok je vais venir enfin je reviens
aussi je tape un peu là
je suis un peu romanesque
non mais c'est chaud mais je veux dire
par là que c'est plus la connerie avec
la tour qui arrive là-bas le machin le
truc j'ai m'attendais ça je suis
tranquille non il va faire ton dessin
on sait pas mais il peut
mais après c'est faut voir aussi son
moral parce que si il se voyait gagner
d'un coup tu as ce truc là moi je te dis
qu'il a je suis sûr qu'il l'a vu après
coup je suis sûr qu'il l'a vu il a fait
trop de tête bizarre et
ce qu'il a joué là ça donne l'impression
qu'il provoque aux cartes pour avoir des
cartes quand même c'est ça
j'aurais foutu le fou en D5 il aurait
fait ça j'aurais eu B6 maintenant
c'est très possible mais du coup faut
voir à quel point il est dégoûté et à
quel point tu te remets et tu te mets un
match champion du monde ça peut jouer
là-dessus
sur le fait de se rendre compte que tu
as fait une connerie et ça peut te miner
quoi non mais c'est terrible et en plus
il revient pas il a joué son fouet B7
surtout bah c'est sûr qu'il l'a vu le
pauvre ah c'est terrible
ah c'est terrible
on est pas au bout de nos surprises dans
ce match incroyable mais ouais ton D7 ça
a l'air de
fermer les débats ok on sait pas en fait
parce que
plein de rebondissements à cette partie
c'est comme tout le monde
4 c'est pour ça qu'il faut vraiment une
nulle aujourd'hui parce que demain
quatre parties ça peut être
rebondissements
dans la même journée
demain il y a quatre parties dans la
journée s'ils font nuls sinon il y aura
un champion et pas de partie de
demain ils embarqueront peut-être déjà
dans l'avion pour aller à la remise des
du de la couronne de laurier quoi qu'il
en soit
plutôt courtes dans ce match on nous dit
ouais elles sont très courtes parce que
là attendez 4 il part sur ton truc quand
même donc le meilleur coup d'après leur
dire
par Ding le coup de Mathieu le coup
humain on abuse ordi proposer des torgés
3 dh5 des trucs bizarres compliqués mais
tracteur C4 pas tellement logique aussi
H5 c'est un jouable
mais bon dans ces cas tu as pas une
paire de catch oui c'est juste qu'on
aimait pas trop les variantes donc après
tu pars sur tout ces quatre clairement
et du coup faire tourner cette
maintenant c'est c'est pas bête dans le
sens où la tortue a moins bien placée
parce qu'elle te bloque le fouet 2 qui
défend plus B5
mais d'un autre côté quand tu reprends
le plan écarlier à 5 et ici c'était un
peu de tour à 4 que tu avais pas tout à
l'heure
oh c'est des choix il a fait tant des 7
ok très bien joué là
il vient de faire ce qu'il est pas fait
avant avec tous ces 6 ou 5 il vient de
le faire avec toi
parce que tu as moins de clouage en fait
tout à l'heure les tours c'est 7 ça
cloué
peut-être B4 si besoin de de sécurité
et
là faut trouver sur ces trois d'après
l'ordi
mais ce que je peux entendre parce que
tu as B5 attaquer donc
[Musique]
problème cette tour qui est resté bloqué
maintenant il y a bien joué là il y a
c'était vraiment pas facile non c'est
bien
c'est marrant
je refais
et donc c'est ça si jamais digne il a le
coup
il est logique pour le coup ça protège
et ça protège
toi si vite je peux comprendre
il veut ce qui va trouver moi c'est
peut-être BK
[Musique]
tu peux la perdre enfin oui
mais tu prends un jeu de 43 du coup là
tu peux pas ok
[Musique]
c'est 5 ça ça
étant ici c'est pas beck4 enfin juste ce
qui est notre couple déjà
et Machin et il veut s'activer mais
c'est pas trouvable
[Musique]
et cavaliers à 5
G6
[Musique]
de nouveau favoris
5 alors on pensait à Tours
litre des 6 mais je sais pas
non attendez si c'est bizarre
hein
[Musique]
tu crées un petit clouage tu attaques
dessin etc
mais bon c'est pas introuvable l'autre
mais bon attention aussi sur toi aussi
de pas se prendre un décalage avec cinq
tours G4 non mais
elle a l'air bizarre
je pense qu'ils avaient le droit de se
proposer nul il y aurait déjà eu dans
cette partie
je sais pas si tu avais le droit il a
l'air complètement fou quoi
il
m'énervement taré mais je sais pas je
crois que c'est tellement hors contrôle
et Yann je pense qu'il est quand même
pas compte de faire une nulle non rien
n'y est pas contre
sur quatre rapides ce sera plus facile
tu prends moins de risques
non mais ok il y avait que cavalier ça
nous paraît introuvable
c'est hyper fort mais c'est hyper dur
c'est hyper dur
ok si la Bravo il mérite ça
c'est l'heure de la pause Fab ah bah oui
il faut qu'on le fasse si jamais ça se
termine allez au moins on est on est sûr
de pas avoir de soucis et de pouvoir
bien suivre le direct note quand il
arrivera à tout de suite les amis on se
retrouve rapidement il devrait y avoir
tous ces 7 et on verra si Ding trouve
les coups on se retrouve dans 5 petites
minutes
à tout de suite les amis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les amis Fab va revenir il est de retour
mais on s'attend à la variante suivante
donc cavalier B7 le coût de l'ordi Paris
introuvable on s'attend plutôt à B4
cavalier D7 Road D2
français 5 tours C5 tours C5
on n'a pas regardé ça ok peut-être ça
peut changer de ce que on va bouffer on
va on va déjà regarder celle-là et
est-ce qu'on bouffe de faux ou pas ça
c'est la question je crois pas moi fais
deux fois on peut perdre non
on devrait pas la gagner
donc on ne change pas deux fois
on échange une
ou faites d'abord
mais c'est plus la même parce que moi
j'ai Torah 3
je vous prends en B5 tu reprends à 7
je suis obligé de te prendre comme ça
tout à l'heure
donc
on reprend le 2 admettons pour mettre
cette finale là
ça c'est nul enfin faut y arriver mais
c'est nul
bon je vais faire travailler un peu
non mais ce qui m'inquiète pas c'est
tout ravi th5
bon qui est en B5 et on fera F6 déjà
[Musique]
5 maintenant
tu reviens vers ton client
et puis et puis peut-être ça déforme
plus
soit il rentre là dedans Ding et c'est
soit ou soit il trouve cavalier
et après c'est à le coup dans le fait
accompli quoi ouais c'était là tu
refuses parce qu'elle est trop dur tu te
demandes est-ce que j'ai autre chose
donc il essaie du coup tu peux y penser
parce qu'il y a pas ton problème bon ça
évidemment tu le vois
et tu veux faire roi des deux
franchement
et donc le problème c'est que français
tu vas faire roi des deux tu attaques la
tour qui va soit aller en A3 soit en C7
mais tu ouvres quelque chose
d'adversaire suivant à 3 il y aura tort
c'est un
et il va te rentrer par là-haut
et si tu vas sur la colonne C il va
aller en couple plus logique très Torcé
7 pour regagner du temps il fait quelle
idée que le foot tu fais fout des 7
est-ce que tu auras maintenant ou autre
chose avant je sais pas il a joué B4
c'était trop ça a été annoncé c'est D4
le coup
et 17 quasi sûr chez nepo mais c'est pas
si simple à défendre pour c'est pas si
simple c'est pas simple
alors dites nul
je sais pas on verra bien la perdre
quand même là le nouveau enfin 50% pas
plus mais
ah ok
géométries trop bizarres quoi
c'était pas possible ça c'est la partie
je suis le cours logique
mais cette Finale 4 contre 3 un peu
disloqué je sais pas enfin
après peut-être pour dingue c'est
évident qu'ils connaissent depuis l'âge
de 9 ans et que il va s'y flotter mais
après le truc mais non c'est flotte pas
ici le truc qui se passe c'est qu'après
les coups sont assez forcés pour les
blancs
donc il peut trouver jusqu'à arriver à
une finale qui est peut-être pas trop
dur à bon on s'attend à qui aider cette
Roader de caille prend C5b prend C5
tourages C1 ça je suis quasiment
et là tout reprend C3 tour d'éviter
chaque intermédiaire j'en vois pas
l'intérêt non pas trop bon
logique bon ben je sais pas comment il
compte défendre tu peux réfléchir à
tourcer 5 c'est ce que j'allais dire
pour défendre le pion monter ton roi et
faire du contre-jourd’hui
mais peut-être tu t'en fiches en fait
mais tu peux partir sur ça voilà c'est
un choix c'est soit pour C5 soit tour à
trois slash tour C7
pour voilà B5
il a fait cahier
il va aller là-dedans le roi des deux je
pense quand même
attends question
[Musique]
roi des deux donc
donc on rappelle il faut prendre le 5 tu
reprends mes 5 87 pas envisageable c'est
la tour sur la 5e rangée trop bien placé
pour aller gagner le pion H4 et donc
cette finale là
et là moi je pense à tomber trop bon
perso je sais pas hein
donc là tu seras obligé de faire tour à
huit trois H7 tu auras 7 bon nombre ici
c'est un autre coup non mais c'est très
très dur de défense
voilà il y a qu'un coup c'est le 5
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait les coups chaque
fois qu'on les vend du ok c'est
truc compliqué sur truc compliqué sur
autre truc compliqué
la paire il pourra s'en rendre compte ou
alors il va pas jouer pour les danser ça
attends il va jouer pour pour ces cinq
ou quoi
c'est 5 ou 3 ou pas
[Musique]
intermédiaire il a fait torcer G3
il est parti là-dessus
ça paraît mille fois logique
parce que quoi d'autre enfin après
[Musique]
logique mais ok pas sûr qu'il fasse
c'est pas très bon en fait mais si tu te
barres en G3 c'est pour bouger ton
cavalier sans le clouage donc si tu
prends pas des 7 tu fais quoi tu vas pas
faire caisse tu vas pas
tu peux en B3
en fait
il a jugé avec autre chose
on attaque pas G6 donc il te prend deux
fois c'est 5
c'est pas un coup je sais pas après
j'ai FG et tu as été finale avec un
champion de main après bon est-ce que
celle-là tu peux être niveau entrer dans
celle-là
peut-être il veut ça
ok moi c'est un choix
mais tu dis que le foyer tient bien
baissé
ouais je pense si tu en veux une tu veux
celle-là
tu bouges plus
bon les Noirs vont travailler au corps
longtemps
mais pourquoi pas
là je serais pas c'est pas un choix
délirant de la part des blancs de
rentrer là-dedans
non mais je pense qu'il va c'est sûr
c'est sûr qu'il va ce que
la question on peut faire du G5 enfin
H55
[Musique]
je pense c'est ça c'est ça qui veut là
c'est trop dégueulasse
tu vas perdre H4 en force
[Musique]
on va voir
et ben il a pris en C5 direct
[Musique]
on veut interdire la case C2 à
l'adversaire et on veut monter non mais
ça
tu fais alors
parce que du coup s'il y a des ventes
avec oursins autant avoir laissé le roi
sur F8
donc si ils ont tous les deux refusé la
vente avec la qualité de plus donc ils
ont dû penser qu'elle tenait mais c'est
pas délirant c'est pas délire
peut-être je sais pas
[Musique]
un peu dans le style des autres qu'on
avait mais un peu différente mais un peu
chiante mais elle est plus facile que
les autres je pense enfin tu es déjà la
position que tu galérais avoir dans
l'autre
histoire G8 meilleur coup ouais mais moi
j'aurais fait fout des trois je suis
désolé mais
quand j'ai eu de meilleur coup si vous
voulez mais je vois pas l'intérêt de le
jouer tout de suite en fait je le fais
quand je veux
donc voilà pourquoi je ferais ton G8
échec en fait
personne va me l'interdire au prochain
coup par contre sur toutes les variantes
où tu fais tour C1 roi des deux tours G1
bon tu vas pas le faire mais genre dans
toutes les vacances ça ça pour arriver
bah je préfère que ton roi soit F8
trouve une finesse que Laurent E7 dans
une variante tu auras un tour reprend à
7 sur échec mais il se trouve que moi
humain le rond est fuite est moins bien
et tourage 7 le problème c'est tour
c'est un
c'est une autre des raisons pour
lesquelles je préfère des trois d'abord
c'est que ça te laisse aussi un peu de
tourage 7 dans le range
et tu en es donc on le rappelle il y
aura un match de départage demain demain
va se faire décoller du coup D1 et tu
vas te le faire bouffer
bah demain ouais je pense que c'est 11h
mais on y est pas encore les amis il
peut y avoir un vainqueur aujourd'hui et
un vaincu
il peut y avoir un vainqueur et un
vaincu
mais on espère pas évidemment on espère
se retrouver demain parce que ce match
encore beaucoup de fruits à nous offrir
si annule demain alors il y aura pas nul
demain parce qu'en fait c'est
[Musique]
ça se finira demain quoi qu'il en soit
il joueront toute la journée je sais ce
qu'il y a un vainqueur elle sera des
parties plus courtes
[Musique]
de garder cette partie mais pas plus
je sais pas toi Fab
[Musique]
je sais pas
le F qu'est-ce que tu me dis ouais
non il y a des chances mais bon ça va ça
peut se tenir il fait le coup de
cave le coup normal
cette couche ça va pas d'affolement à la
pendule
il fait pas une affolante
demain ça sort les kimono peut-être
donc des trois c'était bien joué quand
même son tour cG3 je trouve finalement
ça fait un peu peur sur le coup mais
c'était bien joué moi
il reste assez de temps pour jouer 21
minutes contre 25 mais il y a plus
énormément de coups
les armes sont que les coûts les plus
difficiles là sont passés maintenant ça
va être une souffrance
est-ce que c'est pas des cornes dont tu
es plus F4 parce que j'aurais peur que
mon roi ait plus de cachette
je reviens 7 ah mais c'est pour ça
pour continuer
cette ça paraît logique creux de
maintenant vous prendrez 5 vous prend B5
et tenir ça
ce qui est pas fait
comme ça mais après j'en sais rien
c'est pas tenu quand même non mais c'est
chaud
de sa position il a plus de risque de
défaite et il peut jouer
donc
sans drame qui puisse lui arriver quoi
pourquoi pas essayer de manger à 6 bonne
question
très bonne question
tu peux pas y être
d'abord
du coup il prend B5 tu prends B5 il
prend B5 tu vas en H7
moi je dirais qu'il va en H5 et si tu
veux ranger ça tu vas en F8
c'était vraiment une grosse faute parce
que c'était réfuté de deux manières
différentes
quand d'une manière tu dis la peut-être
raté mais quand à peu près tout refuses
il a dû penser qu'il devait en faire
trop quoi
mais bon donc en gros tous les snow
qu'on voit c'est c'est final avec un
pion de plus pour les Noirs il va
falloir défendre difficilement avec les
Blancs ça se peut mais
quand même dur
c'est 3
je veux bien admettons tu auras 3
ok bon retour de D8 enfin vite fait
[Musique]
pour le fou
ouais elle paraît tellement dur pour les
blancs quand même bien jouer de la part
de Yann de pas être rentré dans le truc
avec qualité plus il a commencé par
tourner 8
ok attaque le fou
et
et donc le seul coup c'est roi des deux
tu te mets dans le couloir quand même
ouais mais oui vraiment parce que
ça va mais
ça me ferait supercherie avec les Blancs
tu as fait H4 dans les G2 c'était une
heure encore des chances avec ça quoi
enfin je sais pas quoi dire d'autre ça
va en fait
et donc ça c'est forcé
[Musique]
juste la main faire
G3 ou dont j'ai 300 tours
[Musique]
et ok enfin je sais pas après faut voir
hein
il a pas le temps de prendre tes
protégés vite
[Musique]
recette
et ok donc il y a pas de petite tactique
comme ça qui viennent sauver
dans cette position peut-être dans B3
comme ça
il va finir par la perdre en fait ça
c'est dur c'est maintenant on se
retrouve
donc tout tient un fil et tu as les
pièces mamies j'ai des faiblesses
partout
c'est très dur de défendre
je pense qu'il va la perdre en fait
probable terrible le scénario quand même
pour Ding qui aurait été trois fois
perdant avec les Blancs quand même
Championnat du Monde c'est
mais celle-là celle-là un peu tout seul
comme un grand il la donne en fait juste
ok
si tu fais que l'erreur de H4 je te dis
pas que tu la donnes mais ça fait H4
l'autre tu as remis sur pied tu as vu
c'est G2 tu as relais CG2 enfin là au
bout d'un moment tu la donnes et là tu
peux faire
tu as le droit aussi de faire
un bon coup
bizarre cette fin de championnat du
monde Fab
ok elle était possible on sait que les
nerfs sont à vifs et que et que c'était
possible que digne prenne beaucoup de
risques le problème c'est que là il a
pris un semi-rise avec qui j'ai 5 H 4
mais le risque était calmé très vite et
que
[Musique]
après je sais pas ce qu'il a risqué en
fait la justice de perdre mais pas de
gagner non le risque avec H4 est
compréhensible entre guillemets le
deuxième c'était plus une faute gratuite
quoi
premier bon il a tenté quelque chose ça
a pas marché ça arrive deuxième c'est
plus un cadeau
mais là ouais je crois que c'est mort en
fait les variantes qu'on a vu elles ont
l'air assez simple
il y a plusieurs choix pour les Noirs
t'as pas un ordre de coup de toute façon
on trouvait hyper dur tu mets ton
recettes avec le B5 Hector B3 machin tu
laisses roder les tours prendre des
trois donc les blancs sont un peu pls il
faut pas s'activer l'attaquage 6
[Musique]
finalement ce rayon de soleil était
prémonitoire peut-être ouais sur sur la
pancarte de dépôt
c'est vrai que c'est une partie un petit
peu à l'image de tout le match
finalement
je trouve
des joueurs qui jouent un peu à contre
sens
mais une époque avec quand même l'air un
peu plus solide sur l'ensemble du match
donc s'il gagne ce sera quand même je
trouve mérité
là ça paraît difficile après dans ce
match on a vécu beaucoup de retourne en
situation mais là on arrive dans des
positions qui sont quand même plus
simples bon on va dire c'est pour ne pas
ok enfin tout ce qui peut craquer c'est
si la peur de gagner
mais il peut pas être en danger avoir
des fantômes on va dire merde je vais
perdre je vais me faire mater ou comme
l'autre jour là c'est il y a pas il sait
qu'il peut pas perdre
il a pas ce stress là donc c'est souvent
ça ça fait la grosse différence
mais voilà il y a plus trop de matériel
sur le JT il peut calculer loin précis
et depuis le début de la partie c'est
plus digne qui se ment pls
[Musique]
mais il a pas fait d'erreur
allez il était plus gestionnaire
torrent
en fait
et le fou des 3 au choix
là c'est dur
non il sait bien remis quand il a vu
qu'il avait raté le fou c'est fou c'est
6 la foutait 5 ou 6 c'est quand même
bien remis après il a enchaîné les bons
coups en fait Yann il a fait que des
erreurs qui se comprennent complètement
il a fait que des erreurs qui se
comprennent complètement alors que que
Ding il a fait des des choix je dirais
pas des erreurs mais des choix
étrange
c'était impulsif ah il a fait des choix
impulsifs ouais mené par ses émotions
nombre de coups il en reste 5 à jouer
mais après faut dire que
dans ce match il a pas vraiment été puni
pour faire ça moi qui peut y croire de
tempérament mais il en a peut-être trop
fait en fait
je change pas mon style maintenant quoi
bon j'ai pas le choix
assez vite
ça y est c'est fait
il y a pas mieux kimono
je sais pas il était en chemise à un
moment il a remis
je pense que c'est bon signe
pareil que si tu remontes le maillot tu
montres parce que c'est bon
c'est jouer à Tanger 3 il y a une qui a
l'air partir qui va revenir
non
il y a une qui revient pas
mais on s'attend à tourbé 3 ici
et c'est pas encore 100% gagné non plus
mais bon
sinon
il va gagner voilà
tu as beau défendre le mieux au monde il
a son destin entre les mains
alors c'est pas 499 % là c'est
90 pas plus non plus
c'est final de tour ouais et puis des
fois tu auras un choix à faire entre une
finale de tour et une autre qui on se
ressemblait une qui est gagnante l'outil
est nul parce que je trouve que le très
bon choix qu'il a fait c'est vraiment de
refuser la finale avec la qualité de
plus oui
ça c'était vraiment très très bien joué
il y a une qui revient
allez
alors c'est pas un coup qu'on avait
mais qu'on va essayer de comprendre je
comprends pas à quoi il sert en fait ah
il veut tout Rachid tour des 6 filles OK
[Musique]
ouais ok bon en fait l'ordi te fait un
truc encore une fois pas trop mais c'est
pour vous expliquer
bon enfin pas trouvable non mais qui va
pas trouver mais qui est trouvable
mais oui ok
c'est juste que dans ce match là c'est
pas trop trouvable
et en plus là où il bug caille jusqu'à
la ligne mais bon c'est sûr qu'il a même
pas vu la variante mais c'est ça et si
tu prends des trois intermédiaires tu te
prends je pensais que c'était on reprend
vite des prends à 7
et prend à 7 non parce que surprend des
trois jeunes mais même tu reprends des
trois fous B5 tu pousses tu prends tu
prends tu prends et tu pousses
quand je t'ai montré le Blitz que j'ai
joué contre Laurent l'autre jour
sur un truc que j'ai trouvé avec 5 6
secondes quoi l'autre soir
faut y croire en fait c'est plus ça
je sais pas le truc avec prise B5 et
tour à trois à la fin c'est à peu près
l'équivalent non non
c'est pas tu vois que tu as un vis-à-vis
ici tu vois que sur toi je suis bah il
va faire tourner 6 pour défendre
non là tu peux quand même avoir tu
reprends le 8 et fou baisser un thème
ouais c'est quand même non mais attends
c'est on est quand même en train de
parler d'une finale de championnat du
monde ma sœur qui me tourne en C3 pas
protégé
non je sais pas j'ai tellement
l'impression qu'il
parce que lui c'est le roi de ce genre
de choses
il peut la voir les amis
après c'est pas facile mais franchement
c'est trop trouvable
non mais un jour faut faire un beau
temps
8 ouais c'est ça droit
c'est déjà mieux que tout ce qu'on avait
avant
E5 bizarrement parce que ça t'a plu le
chemin avec le roi en fait tout à
l'heure avec le pion E6 le roi il
rentrait par là et là il y a tout qui
est bloqué et en plus il y a la sixième
rangée qui permet de taper H6 et il y a
le chemin pour le roi blanc je pense que
c'est nettement plus facile à jouer avec
le pion E5 quand aussi je sais pas ce
que tu en penses Fab ouais ouais on est
visuellement ça donne plus
de possibilités allez
on vient de passer de 80% de chance 885
à 55 de nouveau
et c'est le c'est la seule manière tu
auras ensuite tour des 6 d'ailleurs
parce que j'ai l'impression quand même
que on a accompli quelque chose
et B6 mais après même l'ordi tu as dit
tout droit ça va
bon mais ça après je
[Musique]
oui parce qu'il te fait baisser dans
chaque ligne mais je vais manger
le roi quoi
ça c'est forcément tu as amélioré ta
position quand même en PLS avec ton fou
tu as toujours pas peur
qui peut monter quand les fous
s'échangent tu as bien amélioré il a
tout rachuite
mais tu as vu comme il a claqué la
pendule
dans ce match mesdames et messieurs qui
fera la dernière faute
Fabien
qui fera la dernière faute dans ce
championnat du monde ouais vraiment tout
peut t'arriver c'est extraordinaire
comme match c'est un des plus beaux
matchs de championnat du monde qu'on vit
Fabien simplement ah bah ouais c'est
l'un des meilleurs
arrêtez tout
ce match est extraordinaire il attend
des sommets
c'est ouais c'est vraiment l'équivalent
du Virtu mais en finale de l'US Open
c'est vraiment le pendant qui était un
extrêmement grand match dans tout le
monde se rappelle
à une époque qui vient de se rendre
compte qu'il avait merdé
terrible
terrible terrible les amis
ouais c'est un match mythique
magnifique match en 5 7 qui se joue de
mémoire dans le tie-break du 5e je sais
plus je crois qu'ils avaient servi pour
le 7 chacun il commence à tout
dehors c'était extraordinaire comme
match c'était Tim qui avait finir par
l'emporter
juste quand tu avais des baltes quand tu
étais à deux doigts de gagner tu faisais
double faute d'envoyer la balle 4 m
derrière le cours c'était fini le tennis
ok oui il y avait eu des crampes à la
fin c'était ouais extraordinaire
final improbable ils disent ouais mais
extraordinaire de mon chat
qui a également servi pour le titre dans
le 5e 7 une drôle de finale souvent
irrationnelle enfin ont-ils le niveau au
tennis pour savoir le droit de dire ça
Fabien je ne crois pas très mauvais
article dégage moi ça Fab
à une époque issue il a compris qu'il
avait gaffé terrible
plus que trois coups pour atteindre le
40e
mais le 5 en plus que j'arrive pas à
trouver
après il a pas dû voir tu sais quoi tu
sais ce qu'il a dû rater enfin il a dû
penser à tour des quatre directs mais il
s'est dit peut-être il y a B6
mais c'est un peu trop le coup en fait
et du coup il a pas dû se dire ah bah
tiens je commence par tomber 3 vous avez
dit je vous fais avec ma tour des quatre
et maintenant sur B6
je prends avec ce que je veux et il a
pas dû en fait il a dû rater l'idée de
tomber trois femmes mais qui était très
difficile à voir il faut quand même le
dire tomber trois avec l'idée sur ton
reprend à lui de pouvoir prendre
c'était vraiment très très difficile
donc ça ça se comprend
c'était très très difficile à voir
tomber 3
oui mais il faut voir des découvertes
c'était le cours avec nisky hier les
découvertes
un petit peu et je lui envoyais mais bon
ok
quand même pas n'importe quoi ni ski
voilà découverte de quoi à l'avance
c'est quand même
le coaching quoi
c'est un match de dingue mais bon ça se
joue que sur les nerfs c'est ça ça se
joue que sur les nerfs
qui est incroyable très très doué tu vas
voir que ça va s'il fait du try hard ça
va faire très très mal
bon après ouais
donc c'est
ça vaut pas le coup de quitter une
carrière de champion d'Europe
sur LoL
on a des partages c'est demain si on est
aujourd'hui
et donc que maintenant il fait tourbé
trois maintenant bah la différence c'est
que tu as donné un tempo gratuitement en
plus on a même torgée 8 maintenant on
peut même venir doubler en fait
on associe de venir clouer le fou
là-haut
et surtout reprend des trois bon voudra
faire tout reprend à 8 intermédiaires
et on a cette finale ou c'est même les
blancs qui pourraient prétendre ouais
symboliquement que symboliquement
il a compris qu'il avait raté
mais bon il peut quand même être content
de la nul Yann parce que s'il prend les
100ks
et puis de toute façon ce qui était venu
chercher avant la partie mais juste le
scénario du match fait que tu es déçu
mais elle est sans cassée quand même
important est-ce que c'est Fabien ben
non justement
[Musique]
il y a une tissu
c'est champion du monde 20 personnes ce
sera ce sera le dénouement sera demain
dimanche
30 avril
2023 une date qui sera notée sur un
calendrier Fab il faut la mettre sur un
calendrier
d'autres choses les 30 avril puis
notables je sais pas avoir
je ne suis pas sûr je ne suis pas
surface
dure encore un moment parce que B6 ce
qu'il abaississe de toute façon même B6
c'était encore un film avec le plus
quand même pourquoi donner le pion si tu
pour le moment il le prend pas en fait
ce pion
mais bon tu es un peu c'est juste que tu
sens que tu vas finir par le perdre
c'est le bon moment pour rentrer une
finale de tour que tu sais nul
mais ce que tu le sais
tu fais tour à 8 il va te faire tout
reprendre c'est ça le problème en fait
le dé est relancé ouais
je pense que Ding si tu veux le mettre
en PS sur quelqu'un d je pense qu'il dit
parce que c'est quoi son nom en fait je
crois que OK
peut-être que c'est peut-être que c'est
l'Iran son prénom
[Musique]
c'est Monsieur
alors
bah c'est le l alors
[Musique]
évidemment il va avoir il va avoir le B6
quand même
bon après il a aucun risque hein
au pire il sera de retour demain
se prononce l'hygiène mais quand on a
posé la question adding il a dit qu'il
entendait pas la différence donc je
pense qu'on pense comme on veut quoi
c'est une vraie question
qui voulait savoir pour sa culture perso
on dit liren ou l'hygène alors
mais Ding est là
[Musique]
la même chose en fait non
donc je pense qu'on peut le dire comme
on le sent nous aussi quoi
on dit le L et basta
[Musique]
alors le L qui a plus de 6 minutes 30
mais à trois coups donc si la B6 il
vient de les enchaîner
doit avoir quand même il a pas l'air
très dur
ça a pas l'air d'être le coup le plus
compliqué du monde
c'est pourquoi ça mix entre le R et le J
quoi
[Musique]
ils vont s'enchaîner tout seul la frise
jusqu'à prendre sa décision et une fois
qu'il l'aura prise ils vont enchaîner
c'est dur V6
après ça dépend ce qui est dur c'est de
décider si est-ce que je dois donner un
pion je voulais finale de tour ou je
fais tout retour je vais essayer de tout
défendre mais en soi
tu as envie de mettre un coup de fouet
chaque quoi et là tu sens que tu es pas
loin tu as envie de te faire fouter 5 tu
as un pion dessus tu te débarrasses de
ton pied et tu fais après
tu aimes pas introuvable on parle quand
même des joueurs qui sont numéro 2 et 3
au monde
qui en ont bouffé des exercices
tactiques depuis son petit ce genre de
truc quand même
mais faut encore faire nuit après option
de faire ça ou des sept est orbé 8 pas
qu'il est sur tu reprends ton reprend
qu'il y a plus de tout prendre B5 ouais
bien sûr après j'ai l'impression d'être
enchaîné quoi en fait c'est tout le
genre de position qui se refusait tout
le match et l'autre jamais voir des fois
un truc comme ça ou tu es un peu mal tu
souffres machin donc là tu as l'occasion
de te délivrer de ça d'avoir un truc où
tu fais tu joue tes trois coups en plus
40e et tu joues la finale donc
faire l'autre ça ira dans le sens de
mais ça y est comment ça se stresse
ce serait extraordinaire que ça fait
statue Fab
mais oui allez la coulante ah ça peut
être magnifique ça peut se finir
là-dessus par un chouk monumental
enzynque
ouais ce serait extraordinaire alors ça
ce serait magnifique
allez on est pas loin les amis on est
pas loin d'un choc monumental un de plus
un
ultime un ultime ouais il peut là oh il
peut
il y a plus que 350 il peut ça y est il
est de nouveau dans le dans le tuful
frérot il est dans le brouillard dans
l'aquarium comme disait mon entraîneur
Murtas parce que tu es comme des
poissons
incroyable les amis match championnat du
monde qui peut se jouer là-dessus et on
reviendra Fabien en détail sur ces
cadences quand même assez courte
qui coûte peut-être
la chance qu'il a c'est que les deux
prochains coups il va pas tomber
non il va pas tomber
à se comprendre la tour
se rapprocher de notre un
mais bon même ça veut dire qu'il est en
pleine cool en temps
ça y est c'est passé et supérieur une
heure digne
va être joué et tu en penser 3 par
défendre cette finale
non plus tu peux pas prendre tes propres
pièces et donc
et donc Ding qui se lève et qui c'est
une libération pour pour Ding ici
qui rentre dans cette finale qui doit
théoriquement être nul
et on est content puisque ce pion il est
tellement mal placé en E6 il était bien
il couvrait cette sixième rangée il
laissait la case au roi il peut te
laisser tout racheter des trucs en fait
je fais beaucoup plus confiant de la
tenir avec le pied en E5 surtout que tu
mets la tour en raciste contre le
direction H6 mais c'est peut-être pour
ça que tu vas jouer un truc comme tour
B6 ici
[Musique]
ouais mais quoi faire d'autre en fait je
pense qu'il faut qu'on fasse la dernière
pub
il va nous faire un tour à trois
logiques
[Musique]
Tour Eiffel 3 touches roi 6 pour C3
touches
roi des 6 to F3 et tu as pas tombé 7
j'ai tout F6 peut-être que ça j'arrive à
la tenir Fab ils sont les joueurs
viennent partir Ding va aller
tranquillement
parce qu'en fait que ça ça fait du
direct en fait je suis en train de me
dire
du coup il faut faire cette petite pause
merci à tous petite respiration on se
retrouve très vite à tout de suite les
amis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors les amis je reviens un seul un peu
plus vite que Fab en train de faire le
café parce qu'on s'est dit que ça
pouvait une finale qui pouvait durer
mais en réalité il a fait le tour C3
tour F3 dont je vous parlais
et on pourrait être proche en réalité
d'une
d'une nulle pas répétition
quoi que sur A5 tours C6
A4 tour à 6 tu reprends H6 à tour à 5
donc non ça va ça va pas faire nul
rapidement on est quand même revenu pour
être bien sûr donc il va sûrement y
avoir à 5
tours C7 3 F6 torset 6 3G7 et tout
raciste
ton FK 3G3 bah ça ça doit être nul quand
même sans trop forcer j'imagine
ça peut rentrer dans quelque chose comme
ça mais ça va encore un peu jouer juste
son a pris un petit peu peur
et on a décidé d'éviter
de rater la fin de la partie
donc je le rappelle demain
les départages à partir de 11 heures
point d'exclamation format je crois dans
le chat je rappelle aussi si vous ne
l'avez pas raté de tactique et trouver
le B6 qui a trouvé
notre ami dingly Rennes vous pouvez vous
pouvez acquérir le nouveau livre de
Fabien libyevski le livre de Fabien
bizetzky les tactiques 300 exercices de
tactique et des mots mêlés je crois que
186 si je dis pas de bêtises
le livre de café
pour la modique somme de 9,90 €
magnifique livre d'exercices un
magnifique cadeau
avec
avec du Fab
avec du keV avec des exercices avec des
portraits de joueurs avec les tactiques
idéal pour tous les joueurs des
débutants c'est un livre qu'on peut
prendre jusqu'à même de mille et l'eau
en les tactique
ça mange pas de pain moi j'en faisais
deux trois heures par jour un livre
comme ça je leur ai dévoré en trois
jours je pense à l'époque où
je m'entraîne beaucoup
mais très très beau livre donc qui
arrive le 25 mai
et on a un lien ouais j'ai mis le lien
dans le chat juste au-dessus de ton
message fanov
c'est un très très beau livre en plus ça
ne feront 90 en couleur faut-il le
rappeler un livre coloré
et Fabien mettra peut-être dans le dans
le prochain livre de tactique le
B6 fubé 5 c'est possible pas mais
peut-être en train déjà de le mettre de
côté
le chapitre défense le chapitre défense
exactement Fabien un livre que tu as
écrit avec le coeur avec amour avec
amour avec amour avec un ingrédient
secret
c'est l'ingrédient secret
à quel niveau les mots alors c'est pas
les mots fléchis c'est les mots mêlés
des mots mêlés des baumes aux mêlés de
beaux mots
pourquoi il joue ben là moi je pense que
ça appartient en roi FC
pourquoi non j'ai une autre ligne
j'avais quoi comme parent j'ai même
oublié
à ça
c'est bien ça pour bien je pensais
[Musique]
et après si ça se trouve on peut juste
faire un statut quo et pas donner le
cadre d'ailleurs je sais pas j'ai pas
trop suivi
je fais rien
tu auras 5
h 5
[Musique]
tours je sais pas moi
oui bon beaucoup de choses ça va quoi
et raison au Canada coûte plus cher que
le cahier
en France et quand un ami qui vient il
te le ramène après il sera peut-être
trouvable au Canada ouais possible dans
les bonnes librairies
il y a pas de livraisons offertes à
partir de
[Musique]
Canada aussi en tout cas c'est un super
livre je pense le meilleur livre de
tactique trouvable en rapport qualité
prix en français en tout cas
je vois pas de
d'équivalent
et tout à 5
F6 H5 le problème c'est qu'à un moment
donné
et plus cher avec des tactiques plus
compliqués bah les tactiques c'est les
questions de
bah nous on peut faire un livre au même
prix avec des tactiques plus compliquées
c'est pas la question moi je disais
juste en rapport qualité-prix tes
exercices et le fait que le livre soit
en couleur bon la qualité du papier
disons que tout mis bout à bout la
qualité de l'édition donc rarement des
livres à moins de 20 euros
déjà
bon déjà c'est deux fois moins cher et
puis voilà après
je sais pas ce qui est mieux moins bien
du radis quoi
mais doit être plus ou moins
agréable à lire on va dire
c'est super c'est ce que je conseille à
nisky on s'est super tu les fais tu
cliques et puis après quand tu vas avoir
un autre type de tactique que tu as plus
besoin de te poser ou tu vas moins
cliquer ou tu vas moins chercher
rapidement tu vas plus prendre le temps
bah tu fais sur le livre et aussi ça
permet de reposer les yeux mine de rien
donc c'est bien ça te fait un autre
un autre médium pour travailler et c'est
assez complémentaire si tu fais les deux
tu remarqueras que l'attitude n'est pas
tout à fait la même en train de notre
pointure il va faire ma variante tu fais
de manière motive sur un livre
je vous en profondeur alors celui-là ce
cahier-là il sera probablement qu'en
français à moins qu'il soit traduit je
sais pas il y a pas mal de mes livres
qui ont été traduits en italien mais
quoi qu'il en soit même si tu parles pas
très bien français honnêtement tu
l'achète pas pour le texte normalement
il y a un petit peu de texte pas trop
dur à comprendre
est-ce que tu peux partir aussi turbo
dro bah écoute ça semble turbo droit
après c'est deux foufous l'un contre
l'autre donc
je dirais de 600 700 hello à partir du
niveau de nisky jusqu'à 2000 vraiment
parce que ça fait pas de mal en fait de
faire cette tactique elles sont pas
toutes simples loin de là
donc si tu as 2000 Elo il y a bien une
centaine d'exercices que tu auras du mal
à trouver c'est déjà pas mal
ça te fait 10 centimes l'exercice bon
et sympa tu l'as tu le mets dans tes
chiottes quand tu as des gens qui
viennent chez toi bah ils ont un truc tu
vois c'est pratique quoi
et ça nous soutient quelque part aussi
ouais
bon alors pas en précommande mais à
partir de 25 mai
[Musique]
a priori oui
un bon livre pour les adresses à mon
livre de chiotte aussi c'est vrai non
mais vraiment
et fils ou chess com
s jusqu'à 18 1900 feed
dans l'histoire champion
peut-être on n'a pas eu d'autres mais
déjà il y a eu lui quoi
il sera quelqu'un après l'épée comment
il se rend au même prix mais juste si tu
le prends précommande tu es sûr de
l'avoir
dès le 25 mai sinon tu es moins sûr quoi
je rappelle que le premier livre mon
premier livre il avait été en rupture de
stock assez rapidement
bon là tout fait nul mais je pense
toujours c'est 7 jours c'est 6 l'un ou
l'autre toute façon tu mets la tour
derrière le pion
c'est clair et
puis après
passer sur la carence classique quand on
n'a jamais fait ce que c'est dur ouais
ouais il te faut un temps d'adaptation
mais
carrément tu risques de pas forcément
bien jouer au début de ton temps ou je
sais pas mais
petit à petit ça va aller tu vas t'y
faire
mais c'est pas mal hein parce que ça te
fait te poser des questions tu te
poserais pas en temps normal et donc ça
te fera aussi progresser pour des 15
plus rapides
de facto
il y en a pourtant la précommander 3 à
l'instant ouais le frérot merci mes gode
et si vous avez un club d'échec et que
vous voulez en commander vraiment
beaucoup pour faire des lots ou pour vos
jeunes oui vous pouvez nous contacter
parce que l'éditeur qui bon en fait on
gère pas ça c'est pas nous qui avons le
stock ou quoi mais on peut toucher un
petit mot à dire ouais machin mais
grosses commandes 5 ou 10 ou même 20
c'est je sais pas j'ai pas de chiffres
exact mais moins de 50 non c'est
vraiment pour
mais en gros en plus ça peut être une
idée de l'eau dans les tendres pour les
enfants pour les enfants pour les
enfants même pour toi tu fais des prix
particuliers 1200 moins de 1400 c'est
sympa
t'offres un petit exemplaire etc ça peut
ça peut ça peut se faire et ça fait un
stock pour faire des des lots des prix
dans les tendances
non je dis rien que pour ça aussi c'est
complètement jouable
[Musique]
de le prendre sous cette optique là
ouais ça vous intéresse que vous avez un
club vous pouvez m'écrire en mp sur
twitch ou sur Twitter
il y a très bien à côté de l'autre rouge
et du bleu et ouais les toilettes vont
être remplies de trois livres côté fine
horaires du bus
est-ce qu'elle est à le bas sur cette
position non il y a trop de pièces mais
c'est nul hein il y a pas besoin de
table basse là c'est
parce que la table basse quoi c'est la
vente que j'avais donné
c'était la plus logique
la tour raciste vraiment un très bon
travail n'empêche le roi noir de venir
se rapprocher des pions blancs et elle
empêche le pion d'avancer
est-ce que la carrocane il joue après un
autre premier coup que 4 non la 44 c'est
après tu peux jouer ici sur d'autres
coups mais tu l'appelleras pas qu'un
juste
mais tu veux faire C4
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est possible que digne la
perde franchement je donne 98% de
chances de nuls et 2% de chance de
gagner pour mais je dirais pas 100 parce
qu'ils ont été trop fou
je l'imaginais le perdre quand même
ça me paraît impossible mais bon dans ce
match l'impossible est possible
d'ailleurs juste pour la petite anecdote
s'il restait que F et H contre un autre
et une tour chacun et qui est plus de
pions ce serait quand même nul
il va monter
jamais en fait
surtout que le roi blanc peut aller même
vers F5 si jamais
OK
donc le truc intuitif suffit pas
faire ça mais
donc jusque là on fait rien et après on
reste quand on reste là on passif
[Musique]
et dernier truc si au lieu de donner
comme ça
[Musique]
le problème d'échec
peut jouer un long moment encore ça peut
le droit de se parler pendant la partie
non non pas tu peux proposer nul mais
c'est tout tu dois pas
faire perdre la concentration à ton
adversaire ni vous taper la discute ou
quoi
c'est une sanction si t'insulte ton
adversaire pendant la partie qui est
prévu
je sais pas ce qui est prévu mais par le
règlement je pense qu'on peut te
disqualifier quoi
ça arrive en fait j'arrive quoi c'était
très pénible
mais après c'est moi qui était en retard
quoi
en plus j'ai pas gagné j'ai fait nul
mais non tu as pas le droit de proposer
nul à tous les coups non plus
une fois tous les 10 coups non enfin
c'était ils ont peut-être changé la
règle depuis pendant de quoi proposition
de nul
ah ouais ils ont le droit mais tu
proposes pas à chaque couple je sais pas
moi en fait pour du principe que je
propose pas de fois de suite si je
propose une fois que le Mac refuse
si il veut
mais la digue en fait ça se fait pas
trop poser OK
[Musique]
genre de règles tacite quoi c'est très
très mal vu où il peut
c'est très nul il peut rater
c'est très très nul mais il peut rater
enfin avec tout ce qu'ils ont raté
jusqu'à maintenant
on en a l'abri de rien
alors moi ça me fera un peu chier de
français avec les Blancs personnellement
longue
ouais mais en fait tu étais tellement
mal
quand même chier
qu'en fait tu peux être content d'avoir
ça
après là si tu défends ça là tu gagnes
déjà les 100 K ah c'est bien alors super
en fait ouais si tu tires tu annules
avec les Blancs c'est les 100 K
donc tu es quand même
tu es quand même très heureux
pour 104 tu la défends ah tu donnes tout
pour la défendre
en train de jouer pour les 100 car là
tu gagnes c'est quand même en fait si tu
gagnes c'est un million deux si tu
gagnes demain au départage c'est que 1
million 100 tu perd son cœur
en plus non mais les deux millions c'est
1,2 et 800 mille
c'est le prix total en fait
il joue pour 400K
après on est ça va pas faire grand-chose
pour pour Ding
tu penses
je sais pas comment ça marche en Chine
parce que je sais qu'en Union soviétique
bon
il fait ce qu'il veut et puis voilà en
Russie oui c'est sûr
des passions de philatéliste les timbres
c'est pas des prix
c'est ce que c'est ce que c'est le l les
100k
merci le crack
en Chine garde tout et peut-être même
que l'État les récompenses en plus ah
c'est beau
ah c'est peut-être l'inverse en fait
non mais je pense si ça sera un héros
national même si tu vois ils s'en
foutent un peu des échecs c'est beau
dans un titre mondial à la maison quoi
première fois de l'histoire etc ils en
ont beaucoup des titres mais pas échec
aux échecs
sur la chaîne de télé de sport il
diffusé le Go sur un plateau et ça j'ai
déjà vu
ça joue beaucoup en Chine
le Mahjong
que j'adore
c'est Emmanuel
non j'ai pas j'avais essayé d'apprendre
ça a l'air trop compliqué
c'est quoi le
mais voilà enfin ce qui se passe en fait
mais moi non plus
c'est un beau jeu j'avais essayé d'y
jouer c'est trop complexe c'est un peu
karcher
il paraît que c'est très très beau jeu
poker avec des tuiles
peut être une idée bof pour l'instant
pas top tu te fais bouffer F2 tu te fais
bouffer au 4
un jour peut-être mais dans le noir
qu'on avait regardé on finissait ma télé
donc
c'est mieux de pas faire grand-chose
tranquille ou
là non pas du tout est-ce qu'on pourra
dire si gagne qu'il est fait doré de
platine
c'est qui gagne
celui qui gagne quoi
pourquoi pas ça doit être un coup
non mais il y a plusieurs manières de
défendre en fait donc là il choisit quoi
c'est hyper logique ce que ça prend de
l'espace ça bloque le roi d'un autre
côté tu peux te dire que le pion sera
peut-être vulnérable mais bon
mais il a raison à me prendre son temps
déjà il a le temps donc il peut le
prendre et puis maintenant si proche du
but faut pas faut pas craquer donc
ça sert à rien de faire un coin impulsif
maintenant
dure à commenter parce qu'il y a plus
grand chose à dire mais mesdames et
messieurs en attente qu'il fasse nul ou
qui se trompe mais
bon pense qu'il va faire
mais rien n'est sûr
jamais
surtout pas dans ce match
il n'y a pas de monde où il se trompe en
vrai comme j'ai dit 2% de chance
je pense à peu près ça
peut arriver
ça peut toujours arriver après
il joue pas du tout comment en fait
on croisait trois
et alors là l'ordi te redonne avantage
net avantage en après H5
alors pourquoi
ça a demandé trop de travail
ce cours
il sera peut-être un jour avec fable de
vous proposer des cours sur chez sable
ce sera plus ouverture
après ouais mais après c'est un format
que moi j'ai déjà plus ou moins fait
ailleurs sur d'autres
et ça va donc ouais si un jour tu es
chaud pour faire de la scandie je sais
pas quoi
ce qu'on dit c'est bon ça peut être bien
mais bon on a tellement de projets
partout que
on a encore un projet pour la fin
d'année là c'est terrible
sur un projet cadeau échec de fin
d'année là
on est de partout en fait
parce que là on va sortir le notre
nouveau livre dans un mois le 25 mai un
peu moins maintenant il est déjà en
précommande cahier d'entraînement avec
le Fab qui vous a concocté
petits oignons petits oignons ah bah
tiens l'autre vie qui a mis le lien le
livre de Kia et de fab
et
[Musique]
cadeau échec
on travaille on travaille on travaille
sur un
sur un objet cadeau
de repos c'est pas robot pour tout le
monde
pas du tout même
pour une finale un peu d'autres promo ok
mais trop c'est trop et ben écoute pas
qu'est-ce que c'est tu vois bien qu'on
attend qu'il fasse nul en fait qu'est-ce
que tu veux qu'on fasse
tu commentes les trucs à fond quand ça
joue et quand ça c'est intéressant mais
bon là quand il se passe plus rien et tu
dois attendre deux heures et qu'il se
passe rien
tu veux faire quoi en fait
c'est nul ça peut durer ça peut dur
encore une heure et demie c'est déjà
plus d'une demi-heure qu'on est sur la
position bon
c'est une finale pour 400 tours la tour
derrière le pion a bon je sais pas
combien j'en ai bouffé des finales comme
ça quand on jouait
non j'arrive avec les cours les stages
les machins ce genre de finale Murta
c'est tout il nous est toujours défend
des trucs à la con comme ça
en fait
au moins une demi-heure encore
non en fait dépôt peut-être même à faire
nul tout de suite mais qui sache que
c'est nulle ou pas c'est pas le problème
c'est que lui il peut pas perdre il a le
pion de plus il y en a qui se trompe sur
son adversaire donc ça mange pas de pain
tu fais et puis tu vois et puis s'il se
trompe pas sera toujours temps de faire
dans une heure dans deux heures
et voilà
c'est pas fun et final c'est pas que
c'est pas fun en fait parce que c'est un
c'est hyper intéressant le truc c'est
que
c'est très très long
c'est long et quand c'est nul c'est nul
quoi
mais
non c'est un beau jeu les finales c'est
un autre jeu que les échecs en fait
quelque part c'est une autre partie du
jeu
c'est intéressant et même c'est pas bête
de commencer par les finales pour
étudier le jeu parce que tu as moins de
pièces et donc tu as pas en plus à
utiliser à pleine puissance ta pièce
joue quand tu as une tour ou c'est un
fou ou un coordonner tes pièces entre
elles tu sens aussi que le roi
finalement il a son mot à dire dès qu'il
y a la finale qui arrive donc c'est
autre chose c'est sympa c'est aussi une
course avec les pions passés c'est voilà
tu joues plus tellement pour mater à ce
moment là donc c'est autre chose
mais
là le problème de cette finale là ouais
c'est qu'en fait c'est assez bloqué et
voilà quoi
mais comme je disais là c'est pas la
faute des joueurs c'est à son Ding il
joue pour faire nul parce que il faut
qu'il se battent pour l'un et l'autre
espérer et nepo ok il sait qu'il y a pas
grand chose à faire mais que c'est ton
jamais une erreur adverse un coup de
marlou un truc voilà c'est un titre de
champion du monde derrière donc tu vas
pas donner la nul cadeau à ton
adversaire sans son tenter un dernier
truc
c'est normal mais juste après à meublé à
parler
mais oui parler des coups des variantes
il n'y a pas grand chose de mieux à dire
le problème pour les Noirs si vous
voulez qu'on vous explique le scénario
on a déjà fait 1000 fois vidéo mais si
les blancs font rien je fais rien les
Noirs en fait ils ont passé et qu'ils
ont envie d'amener à dames donc il
pousse je fais rien il pousse je fais
rien
H2 peu importe et il fait ça ok il va le
plan qui peut une fois qu'on est comme
ça les Noirs maintenant ce qu'ils
veulent c'est bouger la tour pendant le
pion bon problème c'est que si il bouge
la tour pendant c'est le pion je bouffe
celui-là donc là bon passerait dans
autre chose à trois comptes 200 ml ce
qui est une autre nul mais voilà donc le
pion a pour l'instant on peut pas le
passer donc le rêve des Noirs c'est que
ce roi là il arrive ici défendre le pion
qu'on puisse bouger la tour du coup on
pourrait plus prendre
et il ferait un problème c'est que même
si le roi arrive en B3
donc bon ben je te laisse faire
donc comme vous voyez j'ai pas envie de
faire ça ça serait une grosse connerie
parce que je laisse le temps de se
décaler sans que je prenne donc moi avec
les Blancs je suis bloqué avec ma tour
sur la colonne mais ok je suis bloqué je
fais j'attends il vient là sur la
colonne il m'attaque je reste il
m'attaque je reste et donc le jour où il
arrive bon bah le jour est arrivé là je
dois quand même réagir un jour mais bon
ça y est il est temps c'est que l'humain
échec
alors si je fais rien vous avez compris
il bouge ça tourne si je fais ça bah
dommage et là je peux plus vite bon ok
je mets chaque droit est en échec il
bouge bah je reviens sur mes pas
et il se reprend le même dilemme qui
peut pas bouger cette tour sinon
j'encaisse le pion donc en fait ça ça
gagne pas pour les marques parce que dès
que Laura vient se coller au pion pour
le défendre il se prend un échec il a
pas de cachette donc deuxième situation
que les noirs peuvent tenter c'est se
dire ah je suis malin je pousse pas le
pion jusqu'à 1 à 2 je m'arrête à 3 comme
ça quand je ferai la même chose avec mon
roi ici tu me mettras ton échec je
pourrais me cacher
mais la différence dans ce cas de figure
c'est quand le roi vient se balader
bon bah d'ailleurs là c'est déjà trop
tard j'ai fait le coin avec les Blancs
quand il est là ça pourrait gagner parce
que quand il y a échec il se cache
mais donc les blancs quand c'est comme
ça ils doivent aller chercher le contre
jeu
[Musique]
pour pour aller bouffer un pion donc
peut-être je peux faire ça d'abord
soit il fait F6 soit il parle là-bas
mais au moins j'aurai le temps de
prendre le pion c'est ça la différence
donc quand on est comme ça et que
j'attends et qui fait ça et que et que
j'attends et qui vient là j'ai le temps
de prendre le pion parce que tout à
l'heure il partait des dames là s'il
part j'ai le temps de revenir derrière
et ça ça change des choses parce que le
temps que le roi vienne faire tout son
trajet pour pour monter jusque là j'ai
le temps
de me créer un pion passé moi aussi etc
donc ça c'est le seul espoir de gain des
Noirs qu'il faut
essayer de faire mais bon
qui normalement passe pas quoi en fait
dans ce genre de situation voilà bref
c'est nul
mais tout ça il le savent ah bah oui
mais donc comme vous voyez en fait c'est
une hypo qui a les cartes en main qui
peut tenter parce que si Ding un moment
se trompe des formats même à la tour ou
quoi ça tourne dans le bon sens donc
ouais turbine donne 0-0 bah je sais pas
je peux aller voir Cécile mais ça
m'étonnerait pas que c'est
oui
mais en retard ça nous en donner à
défendre de temps en temps
des plus durs
mais ce que je sais c'est que tu la
perds pas
tu vires tu reviens plus jamais quoi non
mais bon
je propose pas nul parce que c'est pas
moi de le faire
mon adversaire serait très bien au
courant que je serais heureux de faire
une donc si lui faire nul qui fasse qui
propose et je serais la main sauterait
sur la main comme mais
si j'ai les Noirs jamais je suis nul je
l'ai jusqu'au bout je suis nul à la fin
quand l'autre a tout bien défendu mais
dans sa grande coups dans trois heures
quoi on verra
tellement longtemps
tu es pas bien
si l'autre réfléchit comme ça ça me
motive doublement
tu te dis qu'il est pas bien sûr
mais déjà
bon ça change rien mais objectivement
j'aurais quand même mis mon pion là
parce que dans tous les ventes qu'on a
vu où le roi vient là-bas machin
j'aurais été très content de te bouffer
lui de revenir dans un pion passé ici au
lieu d'être avec eux deux contre lui et
de donc je sais pas enfin niveau réflexe
j'aurais plutôt parti là-dessus alors
après j'aurais peut-être su à calculer
des trucs et mettre mal et me dire là je
vais le perdre le pion enfin ok je peux
tuer à faire à faire n'importe quoi mais
tu me mets en bulles à tout quoi je le
pousse
ah mais sans hésiter
et
là en tant que commentateur je dis aussi
qu'il faut pousser
as-tu le niveau Fabien en tant que
commentateur pour donner des conseils à
ses joueurs je ne crois pas
mais oui normalement ça aurait fait mais
bon
mais bon il se met en PLS il réfléchit
il est capable de la perdre
franchement si un bonnet non mais
franchement si tu perd le match champion
du monde en perdant cette finale c'est
enfin c'est trop on se croirait en 1905
quoi
avec les mecs de grand robinstein qui
était n'importe quoi dans toutes les
finales
tu peux pas en fait
ça tu as pas le droit non ça n'a pas le
droit de le perdre
mais bon il a pas l'air d'être sûr de
lui
ben en fait je sais pas Ding il me donne
l'impression depuis un bon moment dans
ce match de
jamais se fier à sa compréhension mais
de tout vouloir calculer et contrôler
alors bon bizarrement il va quand même
te faire des dingues H4 ou quoi mais que
par moment tu vois il le sait tout ça
enfin il peut être tranquille et non il
veut il veut vraiment être sûr il
calcule
c'est dur avant tout quelques échecs
enfin c'est un beau être un énorme
calculateur
bon on n'est pas désormais à un moment
quoi donc
et ça peut te jouer des tours surtout si
tu commences à stresser que tu es
fatigué que machin tu as un stress je
calcule un peu moins bien peut-être
qu'en temps normal et
compliqué en tout cas
mais voilà
si demain il y a des partages qui
auraient l'avantage bah ça va beaucoup
jouer
[Musique]
en séchant pour les départages
clairement ça se voit aujourd'hui que
ils ont été content de faire nul à
n'importe quel moment
en tout cas au début de la partie et
pendant longtemps dans la partie après
maintenant qu'il a l'avantage il va pas
sauter sur nous il va jouer
mais voilà les pots est plutôt confiant
Ding ça sent que ils veulent quand même
prendre sa chance donc à l'attitude des
joueurs ça donne l'impression qu'ils
pensent priori que Néo serait favori
voilà bon moi mon perso c'est que j'en
sais rien quoi les deux sont pas mal en
fait en rapide et puis là on a tellement
envie de rebondissement de joueurs qui a
du mal
avec les nerfs quoi c'est c'est chaud
que
ça joue à rien quoi donc moi je
donnerais pas de favoris perso voilà
sans sa page aux échecs évidemment mais
ça va se jouer au nerfs après c'est
intéressant ce qui a dit Maxime aussi
que vu le pléthore de prépa qu'il avait
une époque ça pouvait être un avantage
pour pour lui dans le rapide vu qu'il y
a quatre parties
mais bon on a vu dans ces parties que ça
se jouait pas forcément à ça non plus
échecs ça te fait descendre ton roi tu
perds le pion
tu as perdu
ah mais les blancs doivent juste faire
défense rien faire défonce passive
mais bon
on peut peut-être perdre quoi
il peut peut-être la perdre
bon ce serait terrible de perdre ça mais
écoute c'est comme ça possible
de perdre
les blancs il fait nuit à 100%
en face je veux dire c'est pas une
histoire que les hommes sont pas assez
forts c'est que si c'est nul c'est nul
quoi il leur dit il se trompera pas
ok non
non
[Musique]
c'est nul quoi enfin sans que
l'évaluation là quoi mais bref il faut
savoir comment tu le fais
non mais dans calculer les ventes comme
ça les Noirs à 3 il commence à courir
avec le roi
[Musique]
tu vas chercher F il se rapproche tu
commences à faire ton pion passé tu vas
dans ta tour peut-être là-bas machin etc
c'est sûr c'est sûr
je capte pas pour qu'il a pas fait
en gros il a enfin juste il y a deux
coups de ça il a beaucoup ouais il a
passé du temps sur range 3 là ici il a
pas jeté
[Musique]
garage 5 c'était tu lui as laissé
l'option c'est que tu avais rien contre
le fait de lui laisser donc bizarre de
temps qui est maintenant
qu'on comprenait pas en fait donc là ça
change pas on comprend pas
des compotes de double échecs non mais
alors des fois il y a des exiles comme
ça
le macervo qui un truc marrant ou il y
en a un qui dit la pièce à jouer et
genre tu dis pion
et l'autre qui la main donc il doit
jouer un pion mais n'importe lequel tu
vois tu dis pas toujours ou quoi c'est
donc si tu cavalier il a deux choix de
cavaliers et donc voilà c'est un jeu
marrant qui peut jouer à deux contre
deux mais il y a pas de compétition de
ça non
il peut se mettre en PLS tout seul qui
sait et perdre ça ce serait une belle
fin
c'est incroyable mais
mais ce serait une belle fin
de championnat du monde Fabien
sera un bonnet on va voir
physiquement
en fait juste
peut-être qu'il connaît pas bien ses
final c'est possible
je sais pas je sais rien
c'est possible
je fais du mal pour cette partie bah non
pas spécialement mais je trouve que ce
serait ce serait une jolie fin de
championnat du monde en fait de match
champions du monde s'il perdait cette
finale c'est tout enfin après ce serait
une époque qui est les blancs je
penserai pareil en fait un joli
dénouement
forfait physique explosion l'implosion
totale
Dick et faction
parce qu'on serait pas une petite pause
Fab non franchement on peut parce que là
de toute façon il se passe rien on les
écourte habituellement ces pauses mais
là que dire de plus que ton explication
magnifique je pense qu'on a une faille
petite pause on revient quand il se
passe quelque chose à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors il y a eu quelques coups jouets
mais pas pas énorme donc vous avez mis
la scène avec les joueurs sur grand
il a beaucoup réfléchi Ding il a reculé
le roi bon pourquoi pas admettons
il recule le roi
n'est pas qui commence à mettre la
marche avant et attaque latérale sur le
pion donc évidemment il faut le défendre
parce que si on fait à 3 les blancs le
temps de prendre le pion et à deux on
est à deux doigts de faire tomber un
mais la tour fait son retour et bloque
toutes velléité des Noirs donc
surtout à 5 il faut défendre ce pion ça
a été chose faite par le coup F6 et donc
on en est là dans la partie
donc c'est un peu une situation qu'on
avait pensé possible hein c'est le pion
jusqu'à A3 et tenter de transférer le
roi par ici jusqu'à B3 pendant ce temps
les blancs vont prendre F6 et devoir
faire des contre jeux voilà avec
l'option l'option l'option F
éventuellement qui va partir
donc un
une possibilité dans ce genre de
position
on va dire serait de faire un coup comme
comme tout raciste
ne fait rien peut-être
à trois
bon je sais pas je passe sans toi avec
les Blancs
tours chèque ça va
un moment il revient et ça il faut
évaluer donc si on prend le truc c'est
que
ouais la les Noirs tout d'un coup il se
mette menaçant une exception qui fait
avancer et ton raciste pour l'arrêter le
roi qui vient là
on suit un peu avec les Blancs qu'on a
apparemment commencé notre notre contre
je crois
donc faut arriver à faire ça bien quoi
donc pas comme ce que j'ai fait là mais
[Musique]
donc je sais pas et ça ça peut-être
thoracis pour un peu bloquer roi des 7
on va dire comprendre c'est 7
oui mais remarque ça c'est pas mal parce
que je suis pas obligé d'aller en
raciste je peux encore vouloir bouffer
E5
et sur A2 ça vous l'aurez compris on va
là-bas et ça on n'a jamais de cas de
figure on perd parce que quand le roi
ici on lui met des échecs qui se cache
jamais
donc voilà c'est ça le setup qui doit
mettre en place c'est de rester comme ça
d'aller bouffer ce pion le plus tôt
possible si possible
donc pas jouer aux idiots à faire cet
échec là mais à bien faire ça
et là en fait on bouge plus parce que si
le roi vient on a le temps de prendre
s'il est noir patiente notion c'est
faire on attend ici et voilà
donc il suffit de faire ça entre
guillemets il faut pas se tromper
et
[Musique]
voilà
pas grand chose de plus à dire il faut
qu'il ait ça
faut pas tomber non plus alors bon ça
c'est vrai que j'ai pas trop de
d'inquiétude là dessus parce qu'au
centième coup il y aura encore du rajout
de temps à présent les 30 secondes par
coup mais
ouais faut qu'il faut pas qu'il se rende
donc en gros placer la Torah A6 il peut
mettre un petit échec avant si ça
l'amuse mais mais voilà disons que les
Noirs fassent ça t'attend
et ramène son bras tu attends et ramène
son rot attends
et alors je
sais pas
mais il y a peut-être des cas de figure
où ça perd
j'en sais rien en fait c'est pour qu'ils
se mettent autant pls Ding c'est qu'il
voit des sales variantes des trucs qui
lui plaisent pas et où c'est compliqué
du coup
je sais pas
je suis pas sûr qu'il va faire nul en
fait
je crois que c'était ça la connerie non
pour le gâter c'est plutôt une connerie
ouais mais oui oui ça je suis assez sûr
mais
là c'est plus facile en fait
je pense qu'il a peur parce que dans ce
qu'on regardait on faisait une petite
nul tranquille parce que bon j'avais mis
des petits échecs mais en fait si je
fais juste ça le truc qu'il y avait ou
genre les Noirs avance je dis je
patiente
patiente patiente patiente patiente
mardi me dit que je perds
et là j'ai un problème de Tour Eiffel
[Musique]
mais c'est tout ça parce qu'il a pas
fait acheter
de la place 5 mais ce qu'il y a de fou
c'est que ici faire ça devait tellement
faciliter la vie
en patiente bon il peut nous faire son
truc s'il a envie
patiente et en fait il fait ça j'attends
tac échec tac échec encore
jeu des trucs
mais bon
c'est comme ça là franchement bon il se
trouve c'est nul d'après l'ordi mais
je vois vraiment des cas il peut perdre
le ranger de quand il faut et comme il
faut comme ça
ce qui est pas impossible mais je veux
dire un moment je le vois tellement
Suding
je sais pas
on a compris comment il défendait
faut pas laisser tourner
si tu as le pion protégé quoi parce que
d'avoir le pion en F3 oui donc le
problème juste pour pour revenir une
dernière fois c'est quand on est comme
ça ça laisse cette option au noir
c'est que à un moment quand la tour va
se barrer ou quoi
bon je me barre exprès je fais de la
merde la tour va aller sur le côté il y
a échec au roi et mettre le pion à deux
la grande scène
caméra c'est un peu complexe en cette
fin de partie
bon après c'est tout racheteur c'est pas
très grave
au début de la finale si tu fais H5 je
crois que tu es large
[Musique]
là tu peux faire le con mais tu
as la pression et
je pense qu'il va la perdre comme toi
mais c'est bien parce que ça montrera
l'importance d'apprendre les finales et
enfin c'est cool en fait
enfin je trouve parce que tu en penses
Fab qui perdent là dessus c'est une
finale on dit souvent qu'il faut
travailler les finales pas pour rien et
c'est une finale quand même très quoi
qu'il en soit ça reste
classique
où il y a le même nom d'option d'un côté
un pion passé de l'autre et toi derrière
le pion machin ok mais
donc ça arrive ça arrive plus que
souvent
ah non mais pour moi en fait si tu perds
celle-là c'est possible perdre ça ou tu
peux faire H5 pour moi c'est quand même
un peu c'est costaud quoi
le fait que ça se voit qu'il sait pas
faire en fait il suit physiquement il
suffit physiquement et ça se voit qu'il
enfin il panique et il y arrive pas en
fait
et qu'en fait
ce que je disais tout à l'heure c'est
qu'en fait il veut pas la défendre avec
sa compréhension avec un setup il veut
la défendre par le calcul et il va
s'épuiser quoi il va imploser évidemment
il va manquer de temps aussi
et il va perdre donc
s'il change pas de d'attitude ça va se
passer comme ça mais pourquoi il
changerait maintenant
on y va il va se prendre la pression au
temps et plus la pression inhérente à la
partie etc etc
c'est pas possible bah non mais bon
enfin tu peux pas être enfin si lui
connaît pas personne doit connaître vu
que c'est une finale de championnat du
monde donc automatiquement c'est les
deux meilleurs enfin
non c'est que ça doit être très
difficile à défendre qu'est-ce que vous
voulez que je vous dise
trouver le H5 ça doit être extrêmement
dur enfin ça dure la défense et finale
fin pourquoi Murtas mais autant avec
engueulé
les rares fois où j'en raté quoi
trop dur
de toute façon ça change pas des masses
pour l'instant
c'est peut-être plutôt bon signe au
contraire parce que ça veut dire qu'il a
compris qu'il fallait qu'il garde le roi
proche du pion F OK
je pense que tu lui mets la même sans
enjeu en 25 + 10 il a défend je pense
c'est un mélange de tout on dit toujours
que quand il y a de l'enjeu on choque
quoi
c'est normal
ouais alors oui et non
mais oui enfin ça s'entend ça s'entend
après
il y a quand même beaucoup de pression
bien joué sous pression c'est ce qui
fait un peu la panache des grands
champions quoi
mais c'est un peu le problème de ce
match là au final c'est comme les deux
joueurs
jouent quand même nettement moins bien
sous pression et que jouer bien jouer
sous pression c'est la panache des
champions
tu auras quoi qu'il en soit un champion
du monde qui joue pas bien sous pression
donc il y aura pas la panache il sera
quand même champion sans a pas mal
de là à dire le mot apanajed il n'y a
qu'un pas
huit
le Corée Flex c'est
tu t'éloignes F6 donc croise
recette
et donc attention à ceux qui voudraient
prendre F6
[Musique]
dur d'être un champion femme
c'est tellement dur comme je les échecs
tellement dur
le truc c'est que c'est déjà dur de bien
jouer aux échecs
et en fait le jour où tu joues bien
c'est sûr de supporter la pression quand
il y a dans le jeu et donc en fait il y
a plein de choses durs quoi
donc bien jouer aux échecs qui savent
faire ça il y a aucun doute là-dessus
il y a encore il y a deux il y a cette
deuxième étape
c'est horrible ce truc de pression quand
même
mais la digue il se refoule en PLS après
avoir huit enfin c'est
non mais il veut que calculer et c'est
la seule méthode enfin c'est la
meilleure méthode si tu veux perdre
que ceci singing n'a plus de temps
extraordinaire
comme tu dis veux défendre en calculant
et ça c'est
surtout avec la pression et tout ça
devient difficile quoi après je
comprends la démarche mais ouais c'est
la démarche la plus dangereuse
et même s'il faisait nul il est en train
de laisser des plumes pour demain
ouais bon après
je t'aime
ça peut se jouer vraiment à rien
ça part sur une nulle pourcentage tu
vois maintenant
donc je sais pas
trop été surprenante en fait pour qu'on
puisse
prévoir quoi que ce soit
vous voyez un même un an de qui est
généralement pas très dur avec les
joueurs
a raison il disait que même pour lui de
patrouille des 6 ou 6 ou 5 tout à
l'heure
les camions F3 visuellement quand E3 je
sais pas enfin
ah mais il veut se le mettre dans le 3
pour avoir des F4 en un coup c'est ça ce
qu'il veut
bon après je sais pas si ça changera
chose non mais genre c'est pour ça qu'il
se met autant pls c'est pour gagner un
tempo
il a du bol que ce soit pas Magnus avec
les noirs
techniques non non je sais mais je sais
pas pourquoi j'ai l'impression que ma
gus il te rajoute encore un truc dans
ses finales
même si la joue pas mieux rien que le
fait que ce soit maginus qui soit enfin
partie 14 l'anus en face de toi qui a
cette finale là tu
penses même enfin même avec notre niveau
de jeu à nous tu nous mets le masque de
Magnus
je pense tu suis dans une partie avec un
talon jeu tu sais que l'autre il est
hyper fort qu'il a vraiment envie de
gagner
tu as pas le droit à l'erreur non
bon
normalement tu as pas le droit mais bon
le match que des fois c'était pas
exploite quoi alors on me demande si
c'est le temps qui va qui va être
décisif normalement quand même pas mais
bon ça peut non mais il y a plus que
quatre coups donc là bon avant le coup
60 non mais bon à un moment c'était
vraiment une grande compliquée calculer
et que tu as passé tout ton temps là ils
étaient entre 3 et 3
tu peux retenter 10 minutes et puis
après tu as plus de temps jusqu'à la fin
des temps quoi donc
mais après tu as beaucoup quand même
assez automatique on va j'en sais rien
de toute façon on ne sait rien
il y a quoi avec le 60 on récupère 15
minutes et à partir de là chaque jour il
y aura un rajout de 30 secondes
c'est complexe en tout cas
après c'est dommage que le temps influe
sur cette finale parce que non mais je
vois déjà Fab rigoler mais je veux dire
par là si il avait 4 5 heures de plus
pour jouer il aurait vraiment le temps
de faire nul et je vais on n'est pas là
aux échecs pour pour
pour se retrouver dans des dans des cas
de figure où le temps influe aussi
fortement je suis désolé hein Fab
mais peut-être que il serait aussi mal
au temps à ce moment-là et que on a le
débat pourquoi pas 10 heures
je pense que là
c'est pas normal que à ce niveau de la
compétition
au bout d'un moment après on est
content aussi de voir les joueurs
pousser leur retranchement et d'avoir
résoudre des problèmes dans un temps
limité et s'ils peuvent pas ils peuvent
pas enfin après
tu vois
je vois pas la différence entre parce
que de toute façon tu vas revenir en F3
au coup d'après
vouloir carrément donner l'accès à
l'ordinateur directement tu vois
[Musique]
je sais plus
les effets des matchs
[Musique]
je sais plus où je pense Bilba au même
c'est pas complètement dénué de sens
non parce que à vrai dire
ça ne l'était pas aujourd'hui les
ordonnées sont tellement forts que tu
les insistes plus trop mais une époque
c'était pas dénuée de sens
new-yor combien de temps au début de
match bah là ils ont déjà dépensé trois
heures chacun enfin ils ont encore du
temps qu'il reste mais surtout digne
mais il a dépensé bah du coup deux
heures 55 déjà de temps
que ça sur un crémant largement tu peux
[Musique]
la finale qu'il avait au début tu peux
la défendre en 3 + 2 en vrai
non mais même là
c'est une petite amélioration
ce que c'est vrai que le roi F3 bah il
aurait pu aller en G4 il aurait pu aller
en F5 il a pu faire des trucs par là-bas
et on aime bien avoir actif dans les
finales pas bloqué
un problème qui n'existe pas
il s'est mis en PLS tout ça là mais ça
arrive il commence à avoir des fantômes
des machins des trucs et puis tu te mets
en PLS du coup tu fais pas 5 oui il
commence à avoir de vrais fantômes et tu
te
mais c'est pas forcément une grande idée
parce que la Tour Noire peut se balader
sur la seconde rangée votre aura plus
trop de
cacher et vous ouvrez le chemin roi
adverse
peut-être si jamais c'est un pion passé
il vous l'aviez bon là oui ça se calcule
bien mais là
on peut avoir des hallucinations quand
tu as réfléchis aussi longtemps et aussi
fort
c'est pour ça que vouloir tout vérifier
par le calcul des fois cette même
problème mais pour qu'il revienne
d'autant plus fort quoi non c'était non
qui avait dit sur plus de 15 minutes sur
un coup tu as de bonnes chances de jouer
un coup de merde parce que en fait il y
a assez de temps pour calculer tout ce
qu'il fallait et qu'en fait tu vas te
poser des problèmes qui n'existent pas
et te faire des nœuds dans la tête tout
seul et
voilà donc bon après c'est pas une règle
absolue évidemment des fois tu as des
positions ultra complexes et qui
nécessitent beaucoup beaucoup de calcul
mais mec qui vérifie assez souvent
finalement
trop souvent
à chaque fois que tu réfléchis plus
ça sent le problème
qui dit la même chose là non mais c'est
le truc si tu réfléchis
plus de 10 15 minutes ça veut dire que
ce que tu as regardé en premier ça te
plaît pas
et que tu es en train de
choisir autre chose en train de choisir
autre chose et devrait être en train de
faire n'importe quoi
ça nous arrive malheureusement à tous
mais
tu fais pas exprès quoi tu dis pas de 15
minutes mais si tu réfléchis plus c'est
que tu es
que de base déjà tu étais parti sur une
mauvaise piste sur une mauvaise piste et
que tu es en train de mouliner dans la
semoule quoi
il a pas trop d'espoir
il a vu dingue se mettre en PLS il
espère que tu me perdes tout seul quoi
et peut-être il a essayé de trouver un
petit piège un petit
truc le plus piéger
dur à dire quoi que ce soit on a
tellement fait le tour de tout
c'est quoi une tank c'est presque deux
heures
sur les 10 derniers coups
un peu par-ci par là donc ça fait 1h30
qu'on est là dessus
c'est pas du tout le scénario qu'on
attendait ce matin
[Musique]
on savait pas quoi attendre mais c'était
pas le scénario favori digne qui s'en
vont en l'air tout seul n'est pas qu'il
finit pas et finalement longue
gagne pourra quand même entretenir
quelques regrets
ici gagne pas ah bah son de 5 il est pas
beau
pour ce soir tu me parles de la Coupe de
France stomsy
ou du grand match de Ligue 2 Rodez
synthèse
parce que déjà tu vois
Coupe de France
[Musique]
bah Toulouse
mais bon
toujours pourquoi Toulouse
qui peut d'ailleurs réaliser une belle
journée si jamais il gagne au rugby
aujourd'hui et la Coupe de France ce
soir je pense qu'il préférait gagner au
rugby et perdre la Coupe de France plus
une ville de rugby bien sûr mais bon
c'est une coupe d'Europe les deux ils
prennent non mais non bah non tu as
gagné en dernier donc ils sont chauds
dans la compétition mais là j'ai
l'impression ils ont des tracas en
championnat assurer le maintien et je
sais pas ça peut jouer dans la tête
Toulouse sur une belle dynamique alors
le club a été
[Musique]
j'ai pas des saisons difficiles plein
d’années oui en Ligue 2 ils sont
remontés il y a un engouement il y a une
fraîcheur il y a un truc tu dis c'est
peut-être la bonne année voilà c'est
pour ça que je dis ça après
c'est pas une analyse très fine
ça remonte à quand le dernier trophée
des Stéphanois en 2013 il y a 10 ans
bien bien cherché cette Coupe de la
Ligue parce que on a éliminé par nous
c'est pas les autres qui les ont enlevés
et
on profite du chemin tracé quoi c'est
qu'il fallait sortir
[Musique]
demi-finale Lille l'île belle équipe
quoi enfin et finale contre Rennes qui
joue donc bon
c'est un beau parcours mais une autre
époque maintenant on suit
et vous avez fait quoi en Coupe d'Europe
bah tu es bien on a fait plusieurs
années la Coupe d'Europe on n'a pas
brillé de ouf parce qu'à un moment ça
donnait trop dur mais on est sorti
plusieurs fois des poules enfin voilà il
y a eu un regret une année qu'on se
balle on est qualifié jusqu'à la 92e en
gros après une fois on a fait un
huitième de finale contre Manchester
United bon ça me fait balayer mais
écoute c'était cool enfin
c'était non
ma télé
comme des petits pains
il a pas l'abonnement non
avant non non non plus
souvent là et ton grand-père il avait
l'abonnement mais comment c'est possible
c'est n'importe quoi en fait personne
n'avait
quand même assez souvent au stade
d'y aller chaque saison et puis des fois
plus quand je peux mais
tu vois si je fais 5 matchs par an c'est
maxi quoi
il faut supporter avec faire tu vas te
faire marcher dessus le Fab est-ce que
je te dise je suis pas je suis pas là
mais je suis tous les matchs soit
j'écoute à la radio soit à l'époque je
faisais F5 je réfléchissais à des pages
pour regarder chaque seconde
ben maintenant je regarde les matchs
quand je touche à tout ce que je peux
pour voir les matchs je me bats quoi
genre ce soir je suis pas là la semaine
dernière j'étais pas là quoi est-ce que
dans le chat il y a des il y a des gens
qui ont l'abonnement
on va voir
tu vois il y a des
gros supporters des Verts
pour santé ouais
non mais pas au giraudain faut pas au
PSG ça
elle va demander
tu avais quelqu'un qui a
depuis 2009
Standard de Liège
[Musique]
mais ça va il suit un peu cette année
aussi
ils espèrent encore un peu oui
mais bon être européen on va dire oui
mais être européen dans la coupe
des champions non non voilà Ligue des
Champions je crois que c'est acté le
podium ça te Paris Marseillan sous Lens
Marseille on sait pas mais
c'est Marseille non
dans l'affrontement direct lance a gagné
quand même largement
je sais pas ça compte quoi les
confrontations directes
pour ça je dis ça après bon pareil il y
a quelques jours tout peut se passer
et Marseille joue contre qui là
je sais pas alors ce weekend ça joue pas
enfin nous on joue en Ligue 2 c'est bon
on est en Ligue 2 mais la Ligue 1 ils
font une petite trêve Coupe de France
alors c'est quand les prochains matchs
de Ligue 1 je peux vous dire ça les amis
c'est demain
demain on a Marseille Auxerre
ok bon Marseille gros favoris mais bon
Auxerre il peut toujours te faire un
truc et lance qu'est-ce qu'ils font et
je vous le dis il joue quand
juste pour vous dire le calendrier de
l'OM
c'est là dessus
c'est Marseille bébé
ils sont où alors je vais
[Musique]
s ils vont à Lille pas facile à la ligne
reçoivent Brest alors elles sont gros
favoris mais il me reste qui va jouer sa
survie peut-être donc bon et dernier
match à Ajaccio qui pourrait être déjà
relégué à ce moment-là
donc Marseille écoute à domicile ils
sont bien il faut se faire un carton
plein ils ont deux déplacements dans le
Nord pas évident
lance de l'autre côté
est-ce que ça fait
ah ils vont à Toulouse à Toulouse
euphorique ou déprimé selon le truc
le 2 mai ça jouera
après il reçoivent l'OM donc le fameux
match il reçoit 20 ce qui est un peu
moins fort
Ajaccio ils vont à Auxerre
donc voilà et juste Marseille un peu
dedans mais je passe pas beaucoup un peu
ou deux donc bon
[Musique]
vraiment ça tourne il se passe rien sur
la partie devant à deux ça vend un
alors ouais je vois pas pourquoi il le
ferait pas mais
là dans un coup encore un coup à jouer
il va y avoir un rajout
là il y a encore
une bonne une belle heure dans cette
finale
à minima
amine
qui récupère son quart d'heure donc il
est parti
en salle de repos se reposer
partir rallonge
ah on va un peu gaspiller du papier
ah oui
peut-être qu'un jour il y aura roi des 7
bouffer F6 mais il va monter son roi
une petite pause avant le retour de Ding
et un retour de Digne qu'elles ont passé
les amis repose
après qu'il y a absolument rien à dire
c'est
bon on fait une pause de surveillance
quoi
c'est la même position depuis depuis 2
ans quoi au bout d'un moment
il revient il revient
à ma chaîne ce serait beau ou quoi le
top à la machette et ça y est quoi ça
relancerait tout l'intérêt
remplacer les feuilles de parti par des
tablettes numériques est-ce que c'est
plus écologique je sais pas parce que
il se passe un truc
tu branches ta tablette
on sera des batteries je passe une du
lithium ce que tu mets dedans
tu suis aussi quoi
les arbres pleurent quand il t'écoutent
Fab oh peut-être plus noté des parties
par contre la forêt vient d'agresse les
arbres souris si je dis ça non
comment jouer sans noter la partie
vient de donner son pion F7
F6 pour au moins que le roi parte un peu
sur l'eldame
il va y avoir tout racisme
puis on sait pas trop
âgé ou e je sais pas
[Musique]
comme tu veux
surtout pas à si là tu peux te donner
[Musique]
attention à cet échec qui dévie
directement aller plutôt en A4 ne pas
suer
à 4
ça c'est débile quoi je sais pas quoi
c'est peut-être pas obligé que ça dure
une heure plus
il a fait tomber 3
un roi G2 Roissy 7
ok ça c'est malin
il est donc après tout à 5 rois B6 tours
E5
donc crois un ou 3 g déjà est-ce que ça
change quelque chose
six recettes
et au milieu avec les Noirs tu vas voir
ça ça
c'est nul
et en plus là c'est peut-être facile en
fait ça tourne un peu bloqué
[Musique]
OK
bah écoute
c'est forcé hein ça a pas l'air c'est
pas non plus giga dur quoi
non faut juste qu'il
pense à faire il va y penser et qu'il le
fasse surtout
genre c'est facile dans le sens où c'est
forcé sinon ça perd sinon tu perds en
ligne
je suis sûr pareil aux échecs c'est
difficile quand il y a un des options
qui paraissent bonnes à vue d'oeil il
faut comprendre qu'elles sont mauvaises
ça c'est dur mais là il a vraiment pas
le choix
donc pareil d'élimination tu tombes
dessus
ouais
en fait
donc il va trouver
je vois pas comment tu trouves pas en
fait
je vois pas comment tu trouves pas
avoir un
un pays d'accueillir champion du monde
de foot ou d'échec donc coupe du monde
de foot ou champion du monde d'échecs
moi tiens les échecs
mais je suis pas complètement sûr mais
disons évidemment ça coûte beaucoup plus
cher au début la communion de foot mais
la construire les infrastructures les
stades à des choses c'est des trucs qui
te pourront peut-être utile à long terme
parce que tu as des stades de deux tu as
beaucoup de public qui vient ton pays et
tu vas quand même faire beaucoup de
tourisme
donc peut-être tu finis même positif le
truc le problème des chats c'est que ça
te coûte 400 millions pour un match
comme ça et que ça intéresse absolument
personne mais du coup au foot est-ce que
à la fin tu finis négatif ou tu es
positif c'est ça la question
d'échecs tu vas faire un petit peu les
émotions procurées et le bonheur ok
c'est largement le foot qui est plus
rentable sans aucune discussion possible
mais moi je pense que les échecs c'est
le sport le plus cher du monde en
rapport qualité-prix en nombre de
spectateurs
procurées de tout ce que tu as je pense
vraiment que c'est le c'est très très
cher je pense c'est le pire sport du
monde en fait à financer de très très
loin
mais après l'avantage c'est que ça fait
ça c'est facile à organiser quoi
[Musique]
et il a fait le F4 hein
donc c'était le coup important
pour faire du mais bon comme on dit
c'était pas dur parce que c'est enfin
c'était obligé quoi tu fais pas tu as
perdu tout de suite donc
et là en plus avant de combien de voir
et ça va faire nul tout seul
en tout cas Ding en plus il y a pas pris
trop de temps là pour jouer au moins il
se met pas trompé sur la pendule encore
un quart d'heure c'est 30 secondes par
coup
et a priori voilà
il y a plus de coups trop difficile à
trouver non
non
là ça fait nul tout seul il s'est mis en
PLS tout seul en fait Ding
[Musique]
on a eu peur à un moment donné
oui
à vrai dire
il le sait donc on se retrouvera demain
pour les départs
après une partie pharaonique aujourd'hui
femme 6 heures de jeu quasiment
[Musique]
partie magnifique un niveau de jeu
exceptionnel aujourd'hui encore dans ce
match beaucoup d'intensité d'attention
de jeu
l'enjeu n'a clairement pas dépassé le
jeu Fabien aujourd'hui les deux joueurs
ont réussi à jouer à leur meilleur
niveau
et donc on verra demain je pense qu'il
va encore réussir à élever leur niveau
de jeu demain
est-ce possible
ton
est-ce que
ce qu'on peut encore aller plus haut
repousser les limites
se dépasser se surpasser
qui vient complètement éteindre Yann
il y a une complètement éteint
bon qui soit va prendre l'avion sur la
faire roisser d'abord mais ça va pas
changer de masse
pour que la tour côté blanc
ok oui
oh que oui Fabien
celui que j'appelle aussi
effectueusement mon Fab ou le F
F1
en gros tu donnes ce pion à l'abattoir
donc il va te bouffer maintenant dans un
coupe important tu envoies lui donc en
fait le roi il va pas pouvoir le faire
le malin hier
donc ok tu l'envoies quoi enfin donc bon
on parle de torgée 3 on peut mettre là
on voulait votre tour j'ai trop échec ça
vous amuse peu importe on le pousse
bon bah à un moment voilà bon bah on
guette quoi donc soit vous prenez soit
vous faites rien mais moi pareil le jour
vous prenez je prends lui
et même si vous êtes très bon et que moi
je suis très nul et que je vous laisse
gagner ce pion c'est-à-dire que bon bah
là vraiment je ne fais rien et que vous
le prenez bravo
et après bon je monte
de prendre donc la finale le pion va
être nul échec attention dernier piège
je ne prends pas pour pas me faire
enfiler je dis ok pas mal je recule je
ne prends pas je ne prends pas je ne
prends pas donc là je veux prendre
celui-là
bon si on revient je reviens si vous
poussez
j'aime prendre et puis et puis voilà
donc basiquement c'est pour ça qu'on dit
ça après on va voir c'est le scénario là
il y a eu prise il y a eu 5 jouets
et tout rage 3 tu auras un scénario vous
avez vu que le pion H4 je vous l'ai
donné elle est vraiment
donc même si vous venez le prendre
maintenant de toute façon je vais aller
prendre le A3 et on aura un truc
similaire
je ne viens pas jouer les départages
demain je ne viens pas je vais faire
bûcheron
[Musique]
quoi je ne viens pas
ouais non c'est engagé après de la fille
de pour aller se mettre de championnat
du monde
tu travailles ça tu travailles sading
est-ce que tu veux
sors de la table de jeu il bouscule tout
le monde les arbres
c'est du respect ça
toute la partie Suisse
le temps ne tient pas
ok non
un jour ouais moi je trouve ça très très
dommage de faire des matchs aussi long
un cycle aussi long en partie longue
pour finalement finir sur 4 à
quelle sera réellement la légitimité du
champion champion de partie longue
champion de partie rapide
Fabien on ne sait pas
pourquoi ne pas jouer finalement ce
champion de chifoumi oui ça pourrait
tous ces efforts a fait tout un tas de
tournois
ultra long que le truc la saison studio
des plombs va jouer des finales nuls que
tu t'emmerdes à les regarder pour au
final
foot du rapide quoi enfin je sais pas je
trouve ça incohérent en fait
40 milliards de tournois le grand Suisse
la Coupe du monde le machin des trucs
qui durent des mois puis tu as les
candidats les tournois à vélo au milieu
enfin c'est un cycle ça te dure des 6
mois à regarder des finales insipides et
tout d'un coup quoi il te décide
finalement on décide en rapide sur on a
marre quoi
on est plus à ça près quoi
chaque jour quoi
on est plus à ça après
on dit la coupe du monde de foot elle
dure un mois un mois quoi c'est quoi
c'est un moins un mois et demi
c'est 50 fois plus long qu'une Coupe du
Monde quoi donc au bout d'un moment bon
non mais c'est un truc en plus j'ai au
foot un moment les mecs qui aiment plus
debout tu fais jouer Deezer
non mais raccourcir un peu la cadence
que ça reste du long mais un romanesque
un nom romanesque deux parties par jour
mort subite 1h30 + 30 secondes
mais passez la directement rapide je
trouve que c'est un peu un peu rapide
justement
mais ça dure deux ans il y a le cycle de
qualification dure 2 ans le match dure
un mois et tout d'un coup tu vois bon
bah finalement on fait sans rapide sur
ce départage en rapides sur une journée
quoi on enchait dans les parties je
trouve ça un peu bizarre en fait
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe si on
bouffe le pion
bonne question
on peut suer
on suit à cause de ça peut-être
j'en reviens derrière il nous prend et
il va venir nous travailler au corps et
que ce roi qui va revenir se faufiler et
dès le pion donc attention attention
ne pas prendre le pion
si on pousse ça risque d'être peut-être
un peu le scénario mais si on prend on
n'est pas obligé de le prendre c'est ça
la question et donc hop ça a beaucoup
mieux on garde ce pur en vie on peut le
perdre mais au détriment de celui-là
donc ça c'est le bon setup c'est
peut-être tu sais quoi c'est de rentrer
là-dedans
du coup tu vas décaler que Laura on dit
tu fais toujours il vient là tu fais ça
il vient là tu prends là et il réussit à
te prendre ça et toi
H4 elle est vraiment prisonnière c'est
nul facile ça je pense
mais oui il peut aussi une dernière
pause allez dernière pause avant la fin
vas-y à tout de suite les amis avant le
finish
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et bien mesdames et messieurs nous avons
eu un coup toi aussi c'est chèque
il s'est mis en sacré pls en Ding quand
même mais la plus que 5 minutes pour
finir la partie
ça va mais bon aussi
mais il s'est mis en PLS il se met en
PLS tout seul en fait
donc on attend on attend les 6 heures de
jeu mon fable
les gâtés on est là
et ça joue ça réfléchit
faudra vraiment qu'on mette un chapitre
final sur les prochains exercices livre
d'exercice pour dingue
[Musique]
la finale était pas si simple bah ça
dépend si tu fais H5 au début ou pas je
pense
je pense tu fais H5 au début quand même
elle a pas l'air trop complexe
non non
il passe tellement de temps réfléchir
je pense pas je sens que tu es vraiment
important
oui je sais pas pourquoi il l'a pas fait
en fait
bon
donc ne plus échecs il va en B ou en d
après ça lui doit
du roi des cinq
mais bon après on sait rien tellement
dur à dire
ouais
et donc
je me dis
c'est
du coup aussi tu dis voulais faire quoi
tu penses
et E7 on va dire je comprends pas trop
ce qui pourquoi il a pas commencé par
ici pour enlever le des options
mais c'est ça je vous demande en B5 ce
qu'il veut sécher comment quoi
tout à l'heure c'était pas trop
compliqué
on fait rien en fait on faisait rien
et s'il fait tout refroidi on prend à 3
et sinon on fait rien quoi
ouais donc tout à 7
de toute façon
je probablement rien je sens que il y a
peut-être peur de HF on arrive à manger
non mais même si tu as un chef c'est une
théorie quand même
et en plus ça tourne en H4 elle a l'air
hyper facile à annuler
et puis c'est nul enfin je sais pas
comment dire oui c'est nul quoi
tu peux avoir peur de la jouer au final
de champion du monde quand même enfin un
moment donné ouais mais je sais pas quoi
après il suce sous pression ça je veux
bien l'entendre
bon de toute façon il peut toujours
faire aussi s'il veut ça retombe
exactement ce qu'on a vu finesse du truc
en fait non
mais le problème
tu peux pas non mais en plus je crois
qu'avec la tour elle va vraiment l'air
facile hein plus que un cas normal tu
peux suer
pas l'impression que les Noirs ils
pouvaient vraiment te mettre une
pression
à tête reposer mais je vois mal en tout
cas là il fait le seul truc pour perdre
le temps et se mettre en panique tout
seul et mais bon
mais oui bon il a plus il a moins de 5
minutes
là
moi ça j'ai pas envie
il fait thoraciste
mais c'est quoi l'histoire de
l'ordi en fait
tu peux pas rentrer là-dedans par
rapport à FH qui est nul tout seul là
c'est déjà tourbécile enfin
l'ordi mais ça je comprends bien
je comprends pas en fait comment
il y a un truc qui nous échappe parce
que eux aussi on va partir du principe
que tu dois jouer avec ça non mais ça
c'est bon ça c'est sûr mais tu vas être
obligé de rentrer là-dedans en fait je
comprends pas de quoi tu as peur là
ça me dépasse je sais pas quoi
enfin ok mais tu rentres là-dedans il
fait ça si tu peux pas quand même avoir
peur de ça il y a peut-être un truc
qu'on voit pas en fait c'est plus ça le
truc
genre si tu as peur de jouer cette
position c'est quand même inquiétant
quoi
dans le sens où il y a peut-être peur de
ça mais avoir peur de ça c'est fin c'est
pas une tête un truc qui nous échappe ou
une variante qui fait peur ou quoi qu'on
a pas vu
si le mec fait Roy F6 non non
je vois pas en fait il a peur je vais
bouger ma tour là tu t'approches du pion
je vais te faire des échecs fin
d'ailleurs je peux même commencer à te
faire des échecs tu as plus de cachette
non avant toi
F5 ok peut-être ça E7 tu reprends le 7
tu reprends à 3 et roi G4 ça c'est plus
ou moins la vraie la plus dure
mais bon ça c'est complètement nul aussi
ça c'est déjà plus meilleur et c'est
pour les morts
mais oui mais nul quand même
parce que normalement à ce niveau là il
s'affaire nul facilement oui je pense
que ça doit savoir faire depuis
longtemps
alors toi
[Musique]
il s'est mis le feu quoi on va voir
mais le manque de temps ça peut être un
souci je pense que tous ces problèmes
quoi qu'il en soit ils viennent vraiment
de là passage j'en suis convaincu
que tous ces problèmes ils viennent de
là
j'en suis convaincu à 200% parce qu'en
fait tu as les mêmes varante mais tu as
rangé 4 x 5 avec les Blancs quoi
non ça j'en suis convaincu
un problème ou pas problème du coup mais
faites pas si trivial ça c'est sûr que
ça vient de la tous les tous les
problèmes viennent de là donc la finale
de base elle est quand même je pense
assez facile après il se met en PLS tout
seul mais bon
il peut proposer alors ils ont le droit
mais
fading lui il serait ravi de faire nul
et juste néo
il est conscient que la position est
censée être nulle mais il essaye parce
que il y a que lui qui peut gagner ici
donc il va avoir proposé comme ça quoi
en tout cas pour moi pour moi tu mets
Magnus en face dingue
alors pas que Magnus va forcément mieux
la jouer que nepo mais juste de par
Laura de Magnus en face qui va peut-être
jouer plus vite et puis en plus qui a
ouvertement le prendre pour un con en
mode
c'est tellement nul je vais la gagner tu
le vois en face il est là puis il va
rester sur l'échiquier il va te il va te
la tourner te faire tous les trucs les
plus marlou du monde je pense que contre
Magnus tu l'as perdu
ça il montre pas une assurance
suffisante pour tenir à coup sûr contre
un Magnus
surtout avec ce niveau de pression
vu comment il est tremblotant pour
défendre et vu comment le Magnus peut
être
un beau à constructor la recherche du
sang de moindre goutte la moindre trace
il renifle la peur chez toi quoi
mais elle est en PLS
oui c'est vraiment mis sale en PLS quoi
il s'est mis tout seul en PLS
et
[Musique]
une question je sais pas j'aurais pas
trop chercher à faire ça mais RAV4 tu as
le droit de jouer la finale de dame
ce qui peut être content d'avoir
calculer ça comme un ouf
ouais
parce que je me dis qu'en fait tu tiens
bien les cases et que tu te rapproche de
la nuit elle doit être nulle mais
[Musique]
du coup enfin moi je regardais 1000 fois
préféré jouer le vôtre avec les tours
mais
après si ça y est ça quoi enfin
cette façon le but c'est de faire nul
donc tous les chemins en même temps
mais c'est peut-être ça qu'il a calculé
comme un fou furieux quoi
[Musique]
c'est sûrement ouais mais juste je veux
dire c'est bizarre que
tu as trop influencé par Vlad mais là ça
se défend pas comme ça
tu dois faire H5 tu dois faire
il va y arriver
puisque
au candidats alors non mais deux Factory
puisque je crois qu'il y a une place à
l'ELO cette année
et j'ai du mal à imaginer Magnus perdre
90 points et l'eau en trois mois
non mais après ce qui l'intéressait pour
y aller c'est plutôt ça la question en
fait il peut être intéressé par y aller
gagner les candidats
non par contre
rien n'est fait d'avance
c'est plusieurs de gagner les candidats
que de gagner le match très franchement
c'est dur de gagner candidats
c'est plus facile de battre mes pots que
les candidats mais j'en suis convaincu
en fait candidat tu dois tu dois enlever
cette des gens en quelque sorte et là tu
dois un verre
un championnat du monde super aucune
partie
tu es pas mal quoi
ouais alors que candidat il fait
beaucoup de nuls tu as un mec qui va qui
va marquer même si c'est pas le favori
tu auras forcément un gars qui va être
en feu quoi et donc c'est ça la
différence et en fait dans un match tu
peux plus ça dépend de toi en fait
uniquement de toi tu perds jamais au
pire tu sais qu'un rapide tu es bon
plus simple à gérer quoi
non non clairement c'est plus difficile
de gagner les candidats il en serait
favori mais
bien évidemment
oui mais pas enfin
j'attends de regarder 5 je sais pas si
on gagne 4 quoi
ah non non
parce que c'est
un truc une fois tous les deux de trois
ans
on organise 5 Magnus népaux
à chaque fois c'est jamais fait d'avance
mais
il Caro il a fini à la vente avant la
dernière ronde des candidats c'était lui
qui aurait été à la place de Ding mais
c'est digne qu'il a battu et qui a gagné
sa place en battant Naka
d'ailleurs tu vois la différence que ça
fait Ding il aurait su il aurait sué
il a faussé le cycle leding il savait
pas que cette victoire là
lui donner
la place pour le match et vu comment il
suce sous pression on peut imaginer que
s'il avait su il aurait sué alors que
Naka au contraire qu'il y a beaucoup de
pression il joue même mieux
les candidats il y a 8 joueurs qui
participent qui sont qualifiés via
différents qualifyers
ce n'est pas en PLS tout seul et qui
joue enfin vite beaucoup plus vite Yann
il essaye un peu moins enfin et du coup
on s'est il s'est éteint dommage ça
tienne son truc ce qu'il est tremblotant
en face
bah
[Musique]
non je sais mais c'est marrant que Yann
il aurait jamais réfléchi autant non
plus pour essayer de gagner ça avec un
pion blanc H5 premièrement et siding
avait eu l'air plus sûr de lui
faire F2 et puis c'est la même chose
faut pas attendre le bras là il faut
continuer à la jouer côté Yann
Yann doit tout tenter ici il y a eu des
dingues dans la finale genre un raté
ouais il y a eu pas dans cette finale
Maxime mais
plutôt dans la finale il y a eu gros
avantage raté par Yann genre - 2 et en
plus ça paraissait dur à jouer pour les
blancs
puis après il y a tu nous donneras ton
avis mais on a halluciné bah la vie de
l'un des tous meilleurs joueurs du monde
c'est toujours intéressant mais on est à
halluciné ici qui fasse pas H5 Ding et
on sait que Maxime c'est un des
meilleurs défenseurs en finale
du coup est-ce que toi aussi ça t'a
chaud de cette choque à première vue
de pas faire le H5 ici
question pour l'action du monde de Blitz
parce que du coup les Noirs ont fâchent
5 et
ça lui rendu la tâche il nous semble un
peu plus difficile mais on n'est pas sûr
sur quoi enfin on est moins sûr que toi
quoi
bon nous on aurait fait H5 nous on
aurait fait mais bon on est un peu con
aussi
mais il veut pas nous lâcher l'info en
fait oui
non ça me choque pas car H5 torrent tu
as deux il a dû avoir peur OK
bon bah du coup c'est que c'est pas un
si mauvais choix
mais en tout cas ça l'a mis en PLS
après ce truc là en fait
[Musique]
ouais mais après ça peut retomber dans
le
mais il trouve que le pion était pas
perdu ouais
8 je sais plus ce qui faisait et là il
se met un peu en PLS parce qu'il veut
éviter de jouer F4 H5 contre rien ça je
sais pas si toi t'éviterai aussi ou pas
profiter de Maxime pour
poser nos questions
il a peur de jouer à FH roi tour FH
là il veut lui dire
pareil il va faire quoi tu auras 4 il va
faire
c'est que pour éviter il a investi
énormément de temps
il peut se retrouver à la défendre au
lieu que d'avoir 20 25 minutes il va
peut-être rester avec
peu de temps avec peu de temps toi si il
répète
on va voir
ça
fait nul du coup
c'est pour ça que je te demande ce que
ça donne une semaine
oui
les résultats
[Musique]
après ouais c'est pas trop important
comme match j'ai même si même si il y en
a une
c'est pas de revenir donc le titre est
joué
on serait une victoire honorifique bien
sûr
une belle équipe mais pas importante
pour le championnat
et du coup peut-être que Baden si ça
jouait vraiment quelque chose à rajouter
encore des joueurs
en fait cette finale
ou avec le Pione 5 qui réussit pas à
manger le pion aussi facilement
peut-être
un jour
peut-être pas dans les conditions
optimales
[Musique]
en fait
il y a plein de cas
[Musique]
c'est pas mal joué ce qu'il a fait
il a pas mal défendu c'est juste que
dings j'imagine
c'est un peu mis le fou égaux tout seul
alors je sais pas où il va en prison
en plus tu repasses au dessus de 7
minutes c'est quand même plus cool oui
non mais il a bien défendu finalement
globalement
c'est juste que l'assurance qui montre
c'est c'est juste l'attitude en fait qui
a fait flipper qu'autre chose
oui il a jamais de potion perdante enfin
depuis que n'est pas possible
autre chose mais entre guillemets
pourquoi rêver par je crois que les deux
étaient possibles hein
G2 machin c'est je pense se faire rager
deux là plutôt
qui donne tout
Yann qui donne absolument tout ce qu'il
a
est-ce qu'on va mérité une petite pizza
ce soir ah bah oui
j'y pense
j'en rêve et l'oncle d'un vieux qui a la
pizza on a mangé la dernière fois en
fait ah bon
elle est très bien bravo messieurs
toutes mes félicitations
mais avec le pigeon quand même
pigeon pizza
merguez
des recettes
ah c'est beau un bel final 3 heures de
jeu dans cette finale
on va atteindre les 7 heures aujourd'hui
Fab
peut-être pas
s'en approche quand même on s'en
approche
pourquoi pas F3 bah tu peux faire F3 un
F3 ouais F2 tours 2 Rois à prendre et
même si tu arrives à faire E2 et que on
te bouffait pas la tour bah tu vas pas
réussir à faire en fait
des gens qui écrivent je suis là depuis
plusieurs
bravo à toi ouais
le nombre de tactiques que tu aurais eu
le temps de résoudre
non mais vraiment tellement le temps de
progresser
là je suis
heureusement que ça fait pas ça depuis
le début du match
ça te bute non non
je critique aucun des deux joueurs et il
y a la raison de jouer et Nico il a
raison d'essayer
il a raison de défendre d'être bien sûr
de lui c'est trop important mais
bon en tant que spectateur tu es là
Dinky qui commence à jouer vite là il
remonte autant il y a une qui suit
déstabiliser cette tour de la 6
ce serait fou si de la gagner quand même
mais on peut pas aller chercher F4 à
force là
il fait aussi finalement
il va avoir la fin mais du coup roi D87
[Musique]
mais aussi c'est bon finalement c'est le
setup qu'on voulait il y a ouais mais
non il a pas le temps d'avoir le 7
mais c'est bien
ce truc
Age qui nous attendent demain magnifique
maintenant qu'on est là autant qu'il
fasse nul et qu'on aille profité d'un
des partages
des partages quand tu nous tiens
je suis en train de voir que Toulouse se
fait écraser à Fab
c'est pas une bonne journée pour le
rugby Français
en deux mains que La Rochelle s'impose
contre Exeter Fab et c'est là partie
d'ailleurs roi des victoires
c'est bon je lis mes messages mes
commentaires Youtube c'est magnifique
non
[Musique]
pas de rêve en fait c'est pour ça c'est
grave tu as dit ça dégage la racaille
vraiment très très grave c'est fou en
fait
complexe de pas avoir de rêve c'est très
grave ce que tu as dit
elle
il
j'ai juste des gens tu te rends très au
sérieux mais c'est fou alors que c'est
fou le second degré c'est comme des gens
qui disent qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
avec Dania alors que moi ça m'a fait
marrer enfin moi il me dit motherfucker
je suis là en train de rigoler
je le prends pas du tout mal
c'est fou mais moi dès que je dis un
truc c'est très très grave c'est comme
toujours
alors là ça y est ça va faire tourcal
les parois froid il y a Tanger 3 allez
tour à 4 ça marche
3 et 4 avec le roi on l'a dit on peut
aussi faire thoracique tout reprend on
revient et après venir et prendre le
pion
j'ai choisi tout à 500
ça va faire nul
quel combat épique Fab
on va se retrouver demain du coup
[Musique]
magnifique
OK
quoi dire maintenant on se retrouve
demain
pour quatre parties rapides un minima à
minima on espère plus quand même
peut-être un petit de 2 et ça va
continuer à fond
voilà merci à tous d'avoir suivi on se
retrouve demain à 11h au cas où checker
le Twitter de Kev si jamais c'est pour
11h l'horaire enfin nous on pense que
c'est 11h on est quasi sûr mais
connaissons les organisations aux échecs
tu vois mon dernier jour on commence à 9
enfin tu vois je sais pas moi ils sont
capables de tout donc vérifier quand
même mais c'est vrai
et il te met
[Musique]
on sait pas nous c'est un gars qui
faisait aux échecs
si vous connaissez le même il est drôle
quoi mais ça représente assez bien le
match
sympa la petite blague que je vois sur
Twitter c'est beaucoup
merci les amis à demain à demain matin
Ciao